Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wir machen heute Salon. Ja. Wir sind angekündigt zu spät.
Ja.
Wir hatten ja gesagt am 18.
Wir hatten aber auch sehr viel zu lesen, nämlich zwei dicke Bücher.
Die liegen hier.
Über Open AI und Sam Oldman und nicht nur Sam Oldman, sondern natürlich auch alles, was da so dranhängt an Ideologie, an Kolonialismus. Bevor wir dazu kommen, wollen wir erst darauf hinweisen, dass wir jetzt am 23. August live zu erleben sind in Frankfurt. Wir werden also einen Live-Podcast auf großer Bühne machen.
Wir backen uns Politiker.
Ich bin gespannt, was du davor hast.
Wir beantworten eure Fragen.
Und ich bringe auch was mit, aber ich will es noch nicht verraten, was ich mitbringe. Jedenfalls gibt es noch Karten.
Das heißt, ich weiß es auch noch nicht.
Der Link steht in der Beschreibung. Jetzt werden natürlich gerade am heutigen Tag viele sagen, wie ordnen Stefan und Wolfgang das geopolitisch und geökonomisch alles ein? Und natürlich müssen wir uns auch zu dieser Sache äußern. Die Rede ist natürlich von Labubus. Ist das für dich ein Phänomen, wo du sagst, da musst du...
Ich weiß nicht, wovon du redest.
Aber komm, du hast schon von Labubus gehört. Dass diese kleinen Tierchen, die jetzt alle so mit sich führen, oder Monster, die alle dabei haben.
Also heute ist der erste Schultag nach Ferien in Hessen. Das heißt, ich bin in ehrenfreudiger Erwartung, was meine Kids heute alles so aus den Ferien der anderen mit nach Hause bringen. Kann durchaus sein, dass ich heute Abend bestens informiert bin.
Und gezwungen ist, so ein Tierchen zu besorgen. Und das wird sehr schwer sein. Ich habe durch einen guten Mittelsmann ein Tierchen bekommen. Und ich habe gedacht, ich lasse es noch verpackt. Das ist das Kistchen. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht genau, was irgendwas zwischen 20 und 30 Euro hat das gekostet. Ich vermute, der Materialwert liegt bei 30.
20 und 30 Euro, das ist doch Happy Meal Zugabe.
Ja, und man weiß ja jetzt noch nicht, was genau drin ist. Man kauft also ein Sechserpaket oder so. Und dann, wir haben schon über diese Karten damals gesprochen, die Sammelkarten. Und hier haben wir ein ähnliches Phänomen. Jetzt ist also die Frage, was verbirgt sich darin? Für die Leute, die jetzt gar nicht im Bilde sind und denken, was reden die da eigentlich? Es gibt diesen Labubo-Trend schon eigentlich eine Weile, aber ich würde sagen, er ist jetzt so gerade auf seinem Höhepunkt angekommen.
Wo kommt der her?
Der kommt aus China. Und zwar gibt es ein Unternehmen, das heißt Popmart. Und dessen Gründer hat sich vorgenommen, so relevant zu werden wie Disney und auf lizenzierte Produkte zu setzen, die man dann in alle Welt verkaufen kann. Und das scheint ziemlich gut zu funktionieren. Und zwar heißt dieser Unternehmer Wang Ning. Dieser hat 2010, also im Alter von 23 Jahren, schon in Peking dieses Unternehmen gegründet. Er hat dann verschiedene Creator engagiert, die solche Tierchen, solche Plüschtiere gestalten. Unter anderem Kazing Lung. Das ist der Künstler aus Hongkong, der diese Labubus kreiert hat.
Aber hier steht gar nicht Labubu drauf. Also wo kommt der Name her?
Also die heißen so, warum das jetzt nicht nochmal extra da drauf steht. Also das heißt jetzt Big Into Energy. Also es gibt immer verschiedene Editionen. Und du kannst dir denken, es gibt Editionen, in denen sich ganz wertvolle Labubus verbergen, die dann für 2-3.000 Dollar gehandelt werden. Und auch jetzt gibt es natürlich einen großen Secondary-Markt, auf dem die Labubus auch die Normalen gehandelt werden. Da ist es sehr schwer, daran zu kommen. Also ich habe jetzt auch zweieinhalb Monate warten müssen. Ich wollte das dann viel früher in diesem Podcast mitbringen. Und dann bekam ich plötzlich von meinem lieben Freund Thomas die Meldung, ja, das wird wohl eher Oktober werden. Und dann rief er mich aber jetzt an, ich weiß nicht, künstliche Verknappung natürlich, künstliche Verknappung ist ja das eigentliche, worum es da geht. Und dann rief er mich jetzt an, die Labubus sind da. Seine Kinder sind ganz aus dem Häuschen und ich natürlich auch. Und jetzt wollen wir einfach mal diese Packung öffnen. Man muss das oben aufmachen, da ist ja noch kein Kärtchen, glaube ich, drin, hat man mir gesagt. So, jetzt öffnen wir das mal und gucken mal, was wir da bekommen. Ah ja, und dieses Labubu ist dann auch nochmal in einer solchen Tasche. Wir öffnen jetzt die Tasche. Das ist wirklich ein ganz besonderer Moment, glaube ich, jetzt für viele.
Die Tasche nicht kaputt machen dabei.
Und es ist wohl so, dass Eltern in große Nöte kommen, weil sie natürlich diese Dinger nicht herbeigeschafft bekommen. Und was passiert dann? Es gibt natürlich ganz viele Ersatzprodukte jetzt. Die werden aber despektierlich Lafoufous genannt. Und die chinesische Regierung ist sehr hinterher, die zu Beschlagnahmen. Aber jetzt hier ein Original Labubu. Ist das nicht herrlich?
Das ist sehr herrlich.
Und ich kann es jetzt, wenn ich jetzt wollte, könnte ich das jetzt auch hier mir zum Beispiel an den Gürtel oder an den Schlüsselanhänger machen.
Schlüsselanhänger?
Ja, das tragen ja einige der Spitzensportler jetzt in den USA als Schlüsselanhänger. Und man hat das auch bei Rihanna, bei Cher gesehen, bei vielen K-Pop-Stars. Und das hat ja erst diesen unheimlichen Hype ausgelöst, dass also die ganze Welt nach diesen Produkten schreit.
Okay, gut.
Also das ist auch ein ganz neues Design. Also wir sehen jetzt hier, das ist nicht mehr das übliche Disney.
Das ist der Rote, Love.
Ja, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, ich glaube es ist noch irgendwie.
Es gibt Love, Hope.
Gibt es noch ein Kärtchen da drinnen?
Luck, Happiness, Loyalität gibt es auch. Und Secret, das ist nicht Secret, das ist Love.
Also das ist aus The Monsters steht hier nochmal drauf. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob da noch. Ach ja, siehst du, hier ist ein Kärtchen, das ist Big into Energy und dann Love. Ja, genau, das ist das entsprechende Kärtchen dabei. So und jetzt pass auf, dieses hat ja ein anderes Design als diese Disney Figuren. Und viele sagen auch, das ist so hässlich oder so. Gut, ist jetzt sowieso nicht jedermanns Sache, solche Tierchen. Jedenfalls ist doch interessant, dass wir jetzt ein Kulturprodukt haben aus China, das plötzlich einen Hype in der gesamten Welt auslöst, wo vorher nicht schon eine Grundlage gelegt war durch irgendeinen Disney-Film oder so. Also Popmart arbeitet natürlich auch mit Lizensierungen in der Form, dass man jetzt sagt, ja wir versuchen mit westlichen Unternehmen, Lizenzprodukte rauszugeben. Aber vor allem geht es darum, eigene Produkte zu machen. Und das ist also hochinteressant, wenn man das mal nachliest, was ich dann getan habe. Inzwischen eröffnet Popmart überall Flagship-Stores unter anderem auch in den USA. Die Umsätze in den USA sind im ersten Quartal 2025 um 895 Prozent gestiegen, in Deutschland um 600 Prozent gestiegen. Der halbe ist ja so groß, dass die Leute überall campen, um an diese Labubus dran zu kommen. Es gibt auch eine Sonderedition für Coca-Cola und und und. David Beckham hat auch ein Labubu. Jetzt ist aber das interessante, wie der Gründer von Popmart darüber spricht. Also Wang Ning hat in einer chinesischen Zeitung ein Interview gegeben und sagt, unser schnelles Wachstum beruht darauf, dass wir eine offene und integrative IP-Plattform sind, die viele herausragende Künstler und Designer angezogen hat. Wir verwalten diese IPs systematisch. Der Reiz der Kulturindustrie liegt in ihrem Bedarf an starker Softpower, die sich nicht rational berechnen lässt, was bedeutet, dass man ein Labubu nicht einfach mit Geld nachbauen kann. Also der Materialwert hält sich an Grenzen. Aber es geht ja darum, dass man IP hat, dass also diese Urheberrechtliche Lizenzierung da ist.
Ich stelle mich gerade von der Freie. Disney hat ja das Problem, dass dort gerade die Lizenzen auslaufen bei 70 Jahre und so weiter. Also Mickey Mouse ist ja schon gemeinfrei. Und jetzt kommen wir ja auch in dieses KI-Zeitalter. Das heißt, die ersten Streamings z.B. bieten ja schon an, dass du dir deine Figuren selber zusammenpromptest. Also wie man so ein Business jetzt, nachdem es Disney schon schwerfällt, es zu verteidigen, aufrechtzuerhalten, das jetzt neu zu machen.
Ist gut gedacht. Ich würde aber sagen, gerade weil man heute alles reproduzieren kann, geht es wieder darum, das Zertifikat zu haben. Denn das Labubo hat nun nur Labubo oder hat nur Pop-Mart im Angebot. Ich kann natürlich jetzt beauftragen, genau so ein Tierchen zu machen, aber das ist ja nicht dasselbe. Das stimmt. Und er sagt auch, und jetzt wird es interessant, es gibt ein Sprichwort von der Welt zur Welt. Chinas Kultur in der neuen Ära ist eine Kultur von Weltklasse. Wir schaffen Produkte, die die Menschen lieben und nutzen, um die dahinter stehende Kultur weltweit zu verbreiten. Als chinesische Marke der neuen Generation wollen wir Produkte mit höherer Wertschöpfung herstellen und eine Weltmarke werden. In den mehr als 40 Jahren der Reform und Öffnung haben sich die meisten chinesischen Hersteller auf Effizienz und Kosten konzentriert. Wenn beispielsweise der Preis einer Tasse durch Effizienzsteigerungen in der Produktion von 100 yuan auf 10 yuan gesenkt werden kann, unterstreicht dies die hervorragende Fertigungsqualität in China. Dieselbe Tasse kann jedoch mit einem Labubo-Design bedruckt für 100 yuan weiterverkauft werden. Durch die Zusammenarbeit mit Spitzenkünstlern und die Nutzung der ausgereiften Fertigungskapazitäten in China schaffen wir neun Mehrwert. Das ist meiner Meinung nach Innovation. Innovation ist es vielleicht nicht, aber das Interessante ist tatsächlich, dass man jetzt versucht, Premium-Produkte auf den Markt zu bringen. Und das geht natürlich eigentlich nur in diesem Bereich über Lizenzen. Denn die meisten Produkte, wir kennen diese ganzen Figuren, die man von Star Wars und sonst was kaufen kann, sind natürlich in der Herstellung nicht besonders teuer. Aber die Lizenz macht das dann aus, produziert auch dann solche Gewinnmargen. Und das ist jetzt also dieser Shift, der stattfindet. Und interessant ist ja, dass es tatsächlich glückt. Also dass es international angenommen wird. Und dass es auch so zu sein scheint, dass natürlich ein paar Influencer auch bezahlt wurden. Aber dass viele einfach auf diesen Labubuh-Hype ohne Bezahlung aufgesprungen sind. Also ich habe nichts dazu gefunden, dass Rihanna, Cher oder sonst irgendjemand Geld dafür bekommen hat, dass die jetzt auch ein Labubu haben. Das heißt, der Hype ist wirklich viral entstanden und hat sich verbreitet.
Brauchst du halt einen, der es am Ende entzündet? Oder mal anfangen?
Ja, und damit verschiebt sich also sehr viel. Was interessant ist, dass die Washington Post darüber berichtet hat, dass China jetzt sehr hart gegen gefälschte Labubus, also Lafoufous, vorgeht, weil man natürlich jetzt auch ein geopolitisches Interesse hat, beziehungsweise geökonomisches, die chinesischen IPs zu verteidigen, während ja China sonst immer dafür bekannt war, dass dort auch die Louis Vuitton Taschen oder so mal gefälscht produziert werden und die kann man dann für einen Bruchteil der eigentlichen Summe kaufen. Interessant auch, was eine Sprecherin des Außenministeriums namens Mao Ning dazu gesagt hat, die Ästhetik, das Design und die emotionale Resonanz von Produkten wie Labubus trugen dazu bei, dass sich das Land von einem Land, das für Made in China bekannt war, zu einem Land mit chinesischen Marken entwickelte.
Ja, ich bin ja eh gespannt. Ich mache gleich nochmal einen kurzen Abriss des Abbaus amerikanischer Softpower in der Welt. Und das ist ja hier Aufbau amerikanischer Softpower. So albern uns das noch erscheint. Aber in zehn Jahren, wenn diese Entwicklung so weitergeht, werden natürlich chinesische Tom Cruises uns chinesische Flugzeuge erklären.
Also ich glaube, es ist wirklich ein Phänomen, über das man jetzt so viel Kulturkritik schreiben kann. Es gab wahnsinnig viele Artikel natürlich darüber, die sagen, ja, jetzt geben die Leute so viel Geld für irgendeinen Schrott aus und das wird von weit her geschifft. Das kann man natürlich bei fast allen Produkten laufend sagen. Aber viel interessanter ist wirklich diese geopolitische Komponente dabei. Und ich glaube aber auch, dadurch, dass das nicht nur ein Hype unter Kindern ist, sondern unter Erwachsenen, ist das sicherlich auch ein Ausdruck einer Verplüschung der Gesellschaft in der Form, dass man sagt, wir haben diese extreme Härte da draußen, wenn wir an den Krieg in der Ost denken, an den Kriegen der Ukraine und all das. Und zugleich gibt es so den Wunsch, ich will ein Kuscheltier haben, mich auf der Couch zusammenziehen, Decke drüber und ausblenden. Und ich glaube, das steckt auch sehr da drin, in diesem Hype, den wir gerade erleben.
Total. Genug des Schabernacks. Jetzt zur Geopolitik. Oder Geo-Plüsch.
Ja, wie schätzt du das ein, Trump und Putin das Treffen?
Ich habe nichts verfolgt. Also ich bin ganz blank. Ich habe, typischerweise, bevor wir hier Podcast machen, auch wenn ich nichts davon bespreche, höre ich mir noch mal alle aktuellen Heuteschanals und Tagesthemen usw. an. Deutschlandfunk-Tageszusammenfassungen. Nichts davon. Ich war im Phantasialand. Und habe gesehen, dass Trump Putin einen roten Teppich ausrollte. Trump zuerst auf den roten Teppich ging. Dann gab es Videos, wie gezeigt wurde, wie er rechts und links immer bis an den Rand des Teppichs, weil er es nicht geschafft hat, geradeaus zu laufen. Dann hat er, um die Zeit zu überbrücken, eine Verlegenheitsgeste gemacht, indem er applaudierte, als Putin auf ihn zukam. Und dann kam Putin, gab ihm die Hand und streckte sofort den Zeigefinger hoch, im Sinne von, ich mache hier Ansagen, wenn morgen Fotos produziert werden und so, dann ist das mein Zeigefinger. Und ich habe mir gedacht, ja, 10 zu 0 für Putin. Und dann hieß es nur noch, kein Deal, kein Deal, kein Deal.
Naja, dass da so schnell ein Deal bei rumkommt, bei einem Treffen, damit habe ich jetzt nicht gerechnet. Manche offenbar schon. Das wundert mich ein bisschen. So schnell kann das ja eigentlich nicht gehen, mit einem Zusammentreffen. Jedenfalls ist es tatsächlich so, dass Putin damit auf dem westlichen diplomatischen Paket zurück ist. Generell auf dem Weltpaket war er ja immer unterwegs. Das wird ein bisschen ausgeblendet mitunter hier. Aber ja, dass das jetzt nicht die großen Ergebnisse gleich gegeben hat, ist aber erstmal ein Zeichen dafür, dass die Lage sehr instrikat ist. Aber ja, keineswegs so, dass man jetzt sagen kann, und Trump scheitert da mit dem, was er vorhat, wenn wir überhaupt so sagen können, der hat da was klares vor. Also manche sprechen ja die ganze Zeit jetzt auch in Bezug auf dieses Treffen von Trump und Putin von Blueprint, Masterplan, von Playbook. Da denke ich immer so, ja, Trumps oder Trump übernimmt das Playbook von, oder das ist schon lange der Masterplan der Republikaner. Ich sehe nicht, dass die Trump-Regierungen laufen mit großen Plänen, agiert und diese ausrollt und diese sukzessive verfolgt.
Ja, vor allem, da ist jetzt ein halbes Jahr am Abend, und man kann sich auch die Statements aus den ersten zwei Monaten anschauen und jetzt Bilanzen ziehen und sagen, alles fail.
Da passt vieles nicht zusammen, sagen wir mal. Also ich finde, dass diese Begriffe ein bisschen inflationär gebraucht werden. Dass du das nicht so jetzt verfolgen konntest, da du im Familienurlaub warst, ist sehr gut. Dadurch konntest du ja auch gar nicht die 87 Männer Podcasts hören, die schon vor dem Treffen darüber spekuliert haben, obwohl man ja nicht spekulieren sollte, wie wohl das Treffen sein könnte. Und ich sage mal so, wir sind glaube ich kurz davor, dass irgendein großes Medienhaus einen neuen Podcast rausbringt, in dem freitags darüber diskutiert wird, wie die Zahlen vom Samstagslautau ausfallen werden. Also das ist wirklich jetzt so eine neue Art von Journalismus-Simulation, dass man immer so sagt, ja wir können, wir wollen ja nicht, aber das könnte auch dies sein und das sein. Und dann zeigt sich nach so einem Treffen, diese ganzen Podcasts kann man auf der Stelle löschen. Das hat überhaupt gar nichts gebracht.
Ja, wenn du die fünf Stunden zu spät hörst, hat die Realität schon wieder alles eingerührt.
Ja, also völlig unsinnig, damit sich zu beschäftigen. Ich habe dann so ein bisschen in Phoenix reingeschaut und man hat natürlich jetzt so eine neue Richtung, wie man über Trump, Putin und auch die Rolle der EU und die Rolle Deutschlands spricht. Die Ukraine wird ja nicht immer so als letztes genannt, was auch doch ganz interessant ist, wie sich das verändert hat zu all diesen Ankündigungen. Und das entscheidet alleine die Ukraine. Das waren ja immer so Formulierungen. Manche sind aber noch so auf einem ganz harten, alten Kurs. Und ich frage mich, wie geht das so zusammen? Wir hören mal einen ganz kurzen Clip aus einem Phoenix-Gespräch mit Stefanie Barbst, ehemalige NATO-Mitarbeiterin, die da sagt.
Wir als Europäer sind alles andere als zahnlose Tiger. Wir haben in unseren Reihen zwei nukleare bewaffnete Staaten. Wir haben 1,9 Millionen Soldatinnen und Soldaten.
Da frage ich mich dann auch, ja, und was machen wir jetzt mit diesem Pro-Potenzial?
Ernsthaft zu beginnen, der Ukraine zu helfen, gegen Russland wirklich anzutreten und Russland militärisch in ihrem eigenen Land zu besiegen.
Oh, und dann denke ich mir, okay, also während Trump gerade versucht, irgendeinen merkwürdigen Frieden herzustellen und man hofft, dass jetzt Europa daran beteiligt wird und das nicht alles über die Köpfe der Ukraine hinweggeschehen, sagt man dann so parallel, also wir würden dann jetzt schon mal Richtung Moskau marschieren mit EU-Truppen.
Historisch eindeutiges Erfolgsrezept.
Absolut und hintertreiben damit nicht nur die Pläne von Putin, sondern auch noch die von Trump, der zugleich aber noch unser NATO-Pater ist. Also ich kriege es einfach strategisch nicht zusammen. Also ich bin ja auch bereit, manchmal zu sagen, ah, das ist wohl irgendwie gut gemeint oder so, aber hier weiß ich gar nicht mehr, was das sein soll. Wir erinnern uns alle an diese Sätze, jeder Politiker musste sagen, die Ukraine muss den Krieg gewinnen. Davon hört man jetzt fast nichts mehr, weil natürlich auch wir schon sehr früh in diesem Podcast immer wieder sagten, im Bezug auf Mark Milley und andere, dieses Gewinnen wird so nicht möglich sein, zumal ja auch oft gar nicht festgelegt war, was dieses Gewinnen eigentlich meint. Bei manchen bedeutete das jetzt tatsächlich Regime-Change in Moskau, bei anderen bedeutet das, alte Gebietsansprüche wiederzubekommen oder sonst was. Der Ton ändert sich, aber wie wir das jetzt auch schon bei Corona oder so erlebt haben, bezieht man sich natürlich nicht mehr auf das, was vorher als disqualifizierte Äußerungen oder so hingestellt wurde, sondern jetzt ist das einfach eine neue Wirklichkeit. Wir hören jetzt Friedrich Merz vor einer Woche in den Tagesthemen. Er spricht da so.
Wir bereiten uns intensiv auf europäischer Ebene zusammen mit der amerikanischen Regierung auf dieses Treffen vor. Und wir hoffen und gehen davon aus, dass die Regierung der Ukraine, dass Präsident Zelensky an diesem Treffen beteiligt wird. Wir können jedenfalls nicht akzeptieren, dass über die Köpfe der Europäer, über die Köpfe der Ukrainer hinweg über Territorialfragen zwischen Russland und Amerika gesprochen oder gar entschieden wird.
Klingt für mich ein bisschen nach einem Stellvertreterkrieg, was man ja auch lange nicht sagen wollte. Die Ukrainer werden dann immer so als Letztes genannt. Und jetzt hören wir mal hier Friedrich Merz, den Bundeskanzler, was der hier sagt jetzt als nächstes.
Und dann hoffen wir, dass es am Freitag einen Durchbruch gibt. Vor allem, dass es endlich einen Waffenstillstand gibt und dass es Friedensverhandlungen in der Ukraine geben kann. Dieser Krieg dauert jetzt seit dreieinhalb Jahren, hat Hunderttausende von Opfern gefordert. Es wird Zeit, dass er zum Ende kommt.
Einfrieren?
Ist das etwa hier Mütze nicht? Oder ist das Friedrich Merz, der doch sagte, wenn ich Kanzler bin, dann aber richtig mit Taurus und so weiter. Man sieht also jetzt neue Wirklichkeit oder man akzeptiert die Wirklichkeit, von der andere schon die ganze Zeit gesprochen haben. Das ist nicht zu gewinnen, das Ding, sagte Mark Milley im November 22. Aber man lässt einfach jetzt noch ein paar Hunderttausend Leute sterben. Aber dann sagt man, okay, jetzt müsste man vielleicht doch fahren.
Es tauchte einen Text auf, im Freitag oder wo, über linke Podcasts, linke Bro Podcasts, Bubble irgendwie. Wir wurden auch kurz erwähnt, und zwar mit einem einzigen Hinweis, dass wir ja auch keine Ahnung von nichts hätten, weil ich mal vor Jahren gesagt habe, dass es ja offenbar in der Ostukraine nichts zu verteidigen gibt, weil die Leute, die dann vor Ort sind, dann doch sehen, ah ja, da fährt man noch mit der Pferdekutsche irgendwie, und das nennt man Wirtschaft. Und ich habe genau das aber gerade daraus gehört bei Friedrich Merz. Im Grunde ist das Gebiet, um das es geht, nicht ganz so wichtig. Wir haben heute im Salon Literatur zum Thema Demografie und Putins Ansinnen. Da gab es im Krautreporter-Magazin so eine schöne Übersicht, worum es da eigentlich geht. Und ich glaube auch, das wird sich drehen in den nächsten Wochen, Monaten, dass man eigentlich total Abstand davon nimmt, von dem Gebiet zu reden. So wie man jetzt schon nicht mehr von der Panzerschlacht und Raumgewinnen redet, sondern nur noch von Drohne hier, Drohne da und so weiter und so fort. Und alles selbstgenügsam. Jeder produziert sich den Kram selber. Also die Ukrainer kaufen sich einfach alles selbst und bauen für 1000 Euro so eine Drohne zusammen. Also es wird, glaube ich, schon so einen Shift in der Diskussion geben. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt. Also Merz jetzt so zu hören, von Taurus hat man lange nichts mehr gehört. Die letzten, die ich noch im Ohr hatte, vom Bundeswehrverband oder wem auch immer, die Rede und Antwort stand im Heuterschanal, war immer, zu Taurus ist alles gesagt. Und dann fragte Jajali oder Werro immer doch noch mal nach. Zu Taurus ist alles gesagt. Stellte mir richtige Fragen und so. Und ich glaube, dass Schulz vor Jahren sprach davon, dass die Ukraine den Krieg nicht verlieren dürfe und niemals vom Gewinnen sprach.
Das war die richtige Aussage.
Ja, wird sich auch noch als die Aussage herausstellen.
Das war die richtige Aussage. Und das kann man ja alles furchtbar finden. Und es ist auch furchtbar. Nur wir sind ja in dieser Konfrontation. Wir haben die beiden mächtigen, schrecklichen Herren jetzt da gesehen. Wie sie sich in Alaska treffen. Dann ist den ja ausgeliefert. Also nicht vollends, aber doch in gewisser Weise. Und ich kann mir natürlich so vieles wünschen. Aber das wird ja trotzdem dann nicht stattfinden. Und es wird eine solche Sache sein. Ich weiß, wie sehr Heusken durch die Mangel genommen wurde, als er sagte, ja, man wird am Ende dazu kommen, dass irgendetwas wahrscheinlich dem Minsker Abkommen ähnliches, vielleicht etwas besseres verhandelt wird. Und dann hat man gleich gesagt, ja, der wirft die Ukraine nicht zur Fraß vor. Das geschieht ja die ganze Zeit jetzt gerade. Und dass die Ukraine gerade in so Aufzählung, auch bei Friedrich Merz, immer so als Letztes genannt wird, ist ja nochmal da besonders eindrücklich da zu sehen. Und ob man jetzt weiterkommt mit Trump, indem man da mit allen Leuten hinfährt oder so, das wird man sehen. Es ist jedenfalls in einer, wir sind in einer Situation, wo man nicht jetzt einfach in Schwarz und Weiß, also man kann das gerne für sich selbst so denken, aber das entspricht dann nicht der Realität.
Ja, ich will noch eine Empfehlung, die mir gerade wieder in den Kopf schießt, geben, denn als ich zuletzt mit Mick darüber sprach im Fernsehpodcast, habe ich darauf hingewiesen, dass die Amerikaner derzeit 200 Atomkraftwerke planen für das ganze KI-Zeug und so. Und auf die Frage hin, wie viele Uran-Aufbreitungsanlagen haben sie denn, ist die Antwort Null. 60-70% des Zeugs kommt aus Russland und wird auch direkt nach Amerika verschifft. Also da findet allenfalls noch im Papierkrieg so ein bisschen, nee, das haben eigentlich Kanadier gekauft, aber von Inden oder so, aber das Schiff fährt direkt aus Russland nach Amerika. Und die Doku, in der das erklärt wird bei Arte, heißt Die Nuklearfalle.
Ich empfehle die auch sehr, ich habe sie mir jetzt angesehen. Großartig, großartig.
Also wer das gesehen hat, fragt sich bei allen weiteren journalistischen Aufarbeitungen rund um Ronzheimer und so weiter, wovon die da eigentlich reden. Das hat doch gar nichts damit zu tun.
Ja, ich meine, wie kann das eigentlich sein? Ich meine, es gibt jetzt diese Doku, es ist also in der Öffentlichkeit. Aber wie kann das sein, wir haben über alle möglichen Sanktionspaketchen gesprochen und da werden noch Louis Vuitton-Taschen nach Moskau geschifft oder nicht. Ja, so ein Kram. Und jetzt hat man da...
Eine Nuklearfalle.
Eine Nuklearfalle, ja. Also ich kann auch nur sagen, diese Doku ist auch inöffnend.
Die Amerikaner wollen diese KI-Wende, sie haben die Software. Okay. Die Forscher kommen alle aus China oder wo auch immer her, die da im Mittelbau arbeiten. Die seltenen Erden, die man dann in Taiwan verarbeitet, damit irgendwann mal fertige Chips... Das ist alles China, Taiwan, das ist die andere Seite der Welt. Die Energie, ja, Amerika hat sehr viel Öl und so weiter, aber das wird nicht reichen, um jetzt diese Wende dazu machen.
Sam Altman und Peter Thiel sind die beiden, und das schweißt sie ja besonders zusammen, die sagen, wir müssen an nukleare Energie denken, die müssen wir ausbauen.
Ja, das ist, also Nuklearfalle, der Titel, selten so gut hat er gepasst, die Doku muss man da sehen.
Ja, ich will noch einen Punkt machen, Wim Wenders, der Regisseur, ist 80 geworden. Ich bin kein besonderer Fan seiner Filme. Wim über Berlin? Nein, das ist ein wirklich schrecklicher Kitsch. Also ein guter Wim Wenders Film ist Everything Will Be Fine. Oder auch der Film über Pina Bausch, der hat was. Also ich bin, oder Don't Come Knucking, auch ein Film, den man sich ansehen kann. Aber ich finde gerade diese sehr deutschen, überbordend, geschichtsträchtigen Filme sind wirklich hochschwanger und langweilig.
Wim Wenders als Figur, ich finde ja so als Interviewpartner und so.
Ja, aber ich werde dir jetzt was vorführen, um zu zeigen, ich will hier sagen, das ist so symptomatisch eigentlich für die deutsche Kulturbranche. Und zwar wurde Wim Wenders vor drei, vier Monaten beauftragt oder dann wurde es veröffentlicht, vom Auswärtigen Amt, ist auch oft ein YouTube-Kanal zu sehen, einen Film zu machen. Und wir hören jetzt einfach mal rein, Wim Wenders geht also da selbst durch die Szenerie und erzählt.
Es gibt Orte, an denen Geschichte geschrieben wurde, die aber trotzdem kaum jemand kennt. Einer dieser Orte liegt im Herzen Europas, in Raas. Es ist natürlich nicht die berühmte gotische Kathedrale, sondern ein verborgener Ort, der vor 80 Jahren für eine Nacht das Zentrum der Welt war. Eine Schule, ja eine ganz normale Schule. Genau hier ist es, auf der Rue Franklin Roosevelt, das am späten Nachmittag des 6. Mai 1945 ein amerikanisches Armeefahrzeug vorfährt, aus dem zwei deutsche Offiziere aussteigen, die sofort in dieses Schulgebäude eskodiert werden.
Wir sind also in den letzten Tagen des Zweiten Weltkrieges und wir ahnen schon, es geht hier um Verhandlungen und der Film ist natürlich nicht nur als Erinnerungsfilm gedacht, sondern will einen Bezug zur Gegenwart herstellen.
Generaloberst Alfred Judel und sein Adjutant Major Wilhelm Oxenius. Niemand weiß, schon gar nicht die Schüler dieser Schule selbst, dass im Mai 1945 das alliierte Oberkommando hier residiert und General Eisenhower vom Kartenraum dieses Gymnasiums aus die Geschicke der westlichen Alliierten leitet. Unter allen geheimen Räumen Europas war dies der Geheimste, schreibt später ein Zeuge dieser Nacht. Die Deutschen waren gekommen, um eine teilweise Kapitulation nur an der Westfront zu verhandeln. Sie wollten an der Ostfront weiter gegen die sowjetische Armee kämpfen. Aber Eisenhower bestand auf einer Gesamtkapitulation. Schließlich wird spät in der Nacht, im Morgengrauen des 7. Mai 1945, um 2.41 Uhr, die bedingungslose Kapitulation von Hitler Deutschland unterschrieben. Sie tritt erst am nächsten Tag am 8. Mai in Kraft. Auf Wunsch der Soviets wird das Dokument auch noch einmal in Berlin unterzeichnet. Die dunkelste Zeit in der Geschichte Europas geht damit zu Ende. Zwölf Jahre Terror, sechs Jahre Krieg, der Holocaust, die schlimmsten Verbrechen, die die Welt je gesehen hat, enden hier, in einer Schule im Gras.
Bis dahin alles gut und schön aufbereitet noch einmal, aber jetzt kommt dieser Sprung in die Gegenwand, der noch etwas irritierend ist.
Seit das Hauptquartier geschlossen wird, gibt der Oberkommandierende die Schlüssel dem Bürgermeister von Rens zurück mit den Worten, dies sind die Schlüssel zur Freiheit der Welt. Der Anblick der Schlüssel hat mich sehr berührt, auch wenn sie heute nur noch Schlüssel in einem kleinen Museum, in einem Gymnasium sind und es die Türen, die sie geöffnet haben, längst nicht mehr gibt. Von meiner Kindheit an habe ich 80 Jahre in dem Frieden gelebt, den die Nacht in dieser Schule uns allen gebracht hat. Heute herrscht im vierten Jahr wieder Krieg hier in Europa, es ist auch ein Krieg gegen Europa. 80 Jahre nach der Befreiung unseres Kontinents begreifen wir Europäer wieder, dass Frieden nicht selbstverständlich ist. Es liegt jetzt an uns, die Schlüssel zur Freiheit selbst in die Hand zu nehmen.
Was soll ich jetzt damit machen? Also soll ich jetzt sagen, wir brauchen jetzt die totale Kapitulation Russlands? Also das ist ja die, also ich meine, warum ich das vorführe ist, dass die deutschen Kulturschaffenden, um diesen schönen Begriff, schönen hübsch hässlichen Begriff mal zu verwenden, eigentlich nur als einzige Referenz, wenn sie irgendetwas außenpolitisch beurteilen müssen, den Zweiten Weltkrieg heranziehen. Und ich glaube, dass genau dies dazu führt, dass man unglaublich beklatscht, wenn so Maximalforderungen gestellt werden und da bekommt N. Applebaum einen Preis und Karl Schlögel nochmal einen Preis und danach wieder N. Applebaum und dann vielleicht noch Carlo Massalla. Und dann sind die Schriftsteller auf irgendwelchen Podien, die sagen, wir müssen sie den Luftraum schließen, über der Ukraine und all diese Dinge, weil sie natürlich in diesem Modus sind Kapitulation oder nichts. Und das mag auf den zweiten Weltkrieg zutreffen, aber diese Analogie, die dann hergestellt wird und die ja hier suggeriert wird, weshalb ja auch dieser Film auf dem YouTube-Kanal des Auswärtigen Amtes erscheint, ist eben eine, die uns intellektuell unterfordert und auch strategisch nicht weiterbringt und auch mit der Realität nichts zu tun hat. Und das finde ich so symptomatisch für die deutsche Kulturbranche, dass sie das eine oder das andere kennt und wenn es sich dann doch nicht so eingelöst hat, dann wird man darüber hinweggehen und wird sich auf das nächste draufsetzen. Und dieser Maximalanspruch, du hattest mal irgendwann gesagt, erst hatten wir Siro-Covid, jetzt machen wir Siro-Putin. Das ist etwas, was wir da immer wieder erleben können. Und damit wird man mit Preisen ausgezeichnet und so und ist überall gerne gesehen. Ich glaube nur einfach, dass es intellektuell wahnsinnig unredlich ist, das so zu machen. Weil wenn ich daraus eine Schlussfolgerung ziehe, dann muss ich tatsächlich, wie Stefanie Barbst von der NATO sagen, wir haben 1,9 Millionen Soldaten, wir haben auch Atommächte. Also aufgehend Moskau. Und das kann man nicht wollen. Also man muss akzeptieren, dass man in einer anderen Situation ist, als es am Ende des Zweiten Weltkrieges zum Beispiel war.
Also die Schule war jetzt mehrfach Thema, auch im Heuteschnal vor drei Wochen oder so, als ich das gesehen hatte. Dass er das nochmal sich so aufarbeitet, dass er da auch in eine Vitrine schaut. Das ist ja alles noch vor Ort und die Schule ist auch im Betrieb. Ist ja eigentlich ganz interessant, dass es so ein lebendiger Ort ist, dass er in so eine Vitrine schaut, wo dann nochmal die Erinnerungen, so liefen sie damals rein, so spiegelt er das Glas wieder und dann guckt er erschrocken und so. Würde ich alles mal jetzt verbuchen. Wir haben jetzt nur diese drei Minuten gesehen. Ich weiß nicht, wie es sonst weitergeht.
Das ist der gesamte Film.
Ah ja, okay. Gut, also da würde ich sagen, Wim Menders ist hier entschuldigt. Denn der Hinweis darauf, dass es eine Selbstverständlichkeit war, über die man jetzt nochmal näher nachdenken muss, das würde ich sagen, stimmt, aber betrifft relativ wenig die Ukraine, sondern mehr so das deutsch-bräunische Verhältnis zum Beispiel. Denn das, was da gerade abläuft, es würde mich nicht wundern. Und wir kommen ja heute auch, das ist ja in diesem KI-Ding, ist eine Szenerie, also es wird uns grundsätzlich schon mal Ilja Sudskever als die eigentliche Masterfigur hingestellt. Und der scheint wohl mit fünf Jahren einfach so einen Augenaufschlag gehabt zu haben, wo es heißt, in seiner Erinnerung war fünf Jahre lang so, keine Ahnung. Und dann plötzlich hat er gemerkt, ach so, ich bin es, ich bin ein Mensch, wie auch immer. Er ist wie so ein Host in Westworld erwacht. So. Und Wim Wenders beschreibt das ja auch. 80 Jahre lang hat er sich vor sich hingelebt und es war so Friedensdividende, was wir ja immer hören. Und dann plötzlich jetzt, ach so, wir werden dran erinnert, dass nur Ukraine ist, und jetzt sage ich wieder was, was in drei Jahren in irgendwelchen Texten drin steht usw., ist halt vergossene Milch. Da hat man vorher nicht genug aufgepasst. Deswegen ist das jetzt so, wie es ist. Und es ist da auch nicht revidierbar oder wie auch immer. Das ist bei Deutschland, Polen anders. Und ich werde zum Beispiel selbst als jemand, der Frankfurt, am einen immer höh, es gibt noch ein zweites Frankfurt. Was ist das für ein Quatsch? Ich würde sagen, diese Region im Osten sollte man sich jetzt nochmal genau anschauen. Unter diesem, Hä, haben wir nicht immer gesagt, da im Osten wählen alle AfD und sie sind zu 50 Prozent eh verloren? Nein, die klären uns gerade darüber auf, wie scheiße ein Alltag ist, wenn ein deutscher Innenminister, um irgendwelche Leute ihn wo auch immer zu beeindrucken, die nichts damit zu tun haben, sagt, wir machen jetzt an der Ostfront, wir stellen wieder Panzer auf. Und dann sagen die Polen aber, wenn ihr das macht, machen wir das auch. Und dann gibt es kurz Verstimmung und dann ist das aber die neue Normalität. Und dann pendeln plötzlich irgendwelche Menschen in diesem Grenzgebiet hin und her, weil die deutsche Polizei sagt, nee, nicht bei uns, geh mal da rüber. Und dann ist aber da drüben gar nicht die polnische Polizei, sondern so eine Bürgerwehr, die sagt, nee, geh mal wieder rüber. Und dann sagen die Deutschen, hey, wieso schickten die uns den rüber? Und dann sagen die Polen, nee, das waren nicht wir, das war unsere Bevölkerung im Sinne von. Hier hat man es ja auch mit einem Friedensvertrag zu tun, bei dem alle sicher waren, wenn die Deutschen an diesem geheimsten Ort der Welt, und man weiß gar nicht, wann fand das genau statt, es gab nur danach die Verkündung, wenn die sagen, Deutschland kämpft jetzt nicht mehr, dann atmen alle Deutschen auf und sagen, Gott sei Dank, der Krieg ist vorbei. In Polen oder auch in der Ukraine ist das ja gerade ein bisschen anders. Also wenn angenommen, es käme jetzt zu diesem, heute ist März mit von der Leyen bei Trump und kriegt dann die Verkündung, was er mit Putin besprochen hat. Und es käme dann ganz imaginiert jetzt mal zu einem Friedensvertrag, der beinhaltet ja so ein paar Regionen in Russland oder in der Ukraine gehören jetzt Russland oder wie auch immer. Und es wird unterschriftlich besiegelt. Würden sich alle Ukrainer und alle Russen daran halten? Oder gäbe es da Scharmützel und so weiter, wo dann die Regierungschefs danebenstehen und sagen, sorry, glaub mir, damit habe ich gerade nichts zu tun. Also wären wir schon für Joschyn oder wie er hieß und so, die da alle auf eigene Faust irgendwas machen.
Deshalb ja dieser große Streit um die Sicherheitsgarantien. Wer muss denn da was gerade absichern und aufpassen, dass da nicht wieder was losgeht?
Also es gibt extrem viele Themen, die gerade so zu besprechen sind, wie er das macht. Mit so einem Verweis auf, es kann ganz schön schiefgehen. Nur den Namen Zelensky will ich da gar nicht hören in dieser Diskussion. Sondern ich will hören, was macht die polnische Bevölkerung am deutschen Grenzgebiet, die seit drei Jahren in dem Wahlkampf gehört hat, dass die Deutschen wieder die Polen übernehmen wollen und so weiter. Die müsst ihr jetzt selber werden, denn wahrscheinlich kriegen wir schon wieder so eine Kolumbische Urbane-Regierung und so weiter. Und dann hilft uns niemand mehr. Ihr müsst es selber machen. So, solche Sachen.
Ja, so Gründungen von Bürgerwehren etc., was da mit dann hergeht.
Nur da sehe ich schon einen großen Auftrag für die sogenannte Kulturschaffenden.
Ich sehe nicht, dass unsere Günster und Intellektuelle das machen, sondern sie springen gerne auf fahrende Züge auf und machen sich dann, sobald sie auf diesem Zug sind, auf, nach vorn und werden zum Lokomotivführer und sagen, jetzt aber richtig, jetzt aber Kapitulation, jetzt aber Zero-Covid, jetzt aber dies oder das.
Aber den Appell an meinen Bizeps habe ich jetzt bei Wim Menders nicht rausgehört.
Immerhin noch nicht, aber es hat halt genau dieses Geraune, das dann immer so da ist. Und ich habe es ja jetzt auch gesehen, ich meine Udo Lindenberg, der also offenbar zwischen all dem Eierlikör und so nochmal jetzt gedacht hat, ich muss mich nochmal äußern, sagt dann, dass er jetzt eigentlich immer für Pazifismus war, weil jetzt ging das halt nicht mehr. Und dann denkt man so, ja du im Atlantik-Hotel, du hast doch mit nichts irgendwas zu tun. Was musst du jetzt dich nochmal dazu in dieser Weise äußern? Das ist genau so und dasselbe Niveau wie Heino, der bei News erzählt hat, ja ich würde kämpfen. Also Jahren 86, ja egal. Also das ist alles so irrsinnig. Aber so sinnbildlich für unsere deutsche Kulturlandschaft, dass ich am liebsten, wir reden ja auch gleich so, braucht man ein KI-Moratorium und sowas, ich würde echt gerne mal ein intellektuellen Moratorium haben, dass einfach die deutsche Kulturbranche einfach mal drei Jahre schweigt, versucht mal ein anständiges Buch zu schreiben oder einen guten Film zu machen.
Ja, ich meine, das Moratorium wird ja eh schon vom Publikum veranstaltet. Es lässt sich ja jetzt niemand von Campino oder Verdinke treiben oder sowas.
Aber dass sie noch so permanent ideal reproduziert werden, also ist es grauenhundert. Wenn man nicht mehr weiter weiß, dann wird noch Wolf Biermann oder Hertha Müller interviewt. Es ist alles furchtbar, aber wir wollen uns ja mit den ganz großen Fragen auseinandersetzen und nicht mit diesen Dickeligkeiten aus den deutschen Kulturbetrieben. So stelle ich das Labubu mal weg und greife zu den Büchern. Und zwar haben wir viel gelesen, über 1000 Seiten. Einmal von Keech Hegge, Sam Altman, Open AI, Künstliche Intelligenz und der Wettlauf um unsere Zukunft. Eine Biografie, die bis in die Kindheitstage von Sam Altman zurückgeht. Und dann haben wir des Weiteren gelesen von Karen Howe, Empire of AI, Dreams and Nightmares in Sam Altman's Open AI. Ein Buch, das nicht nur die Unternehmensgeschichte erzählt und viel über die Intrigen, die dort stattfinden, zwischen Zuzkever, Brockman, Amodei, Altman, sondern es ist auch ein Buch, das sich fragt, haben wir es hier mit einem neuen Kolonialismus zu tun, der sowohl die analoge Welt in Beschlag nimmt, als auch die digitale. Eine Autorin, die sich auch hinaus wagt, die sich ansieht, wie arbeiten eigentlich Clickworker, was haben sie zu tun, wo ist eigentlich hier der große Fortschritt bei denen. Die verdienen dann mal kurz 1,60 Dollar die Stunde, bis dann das auch noch runtergeht auf 90 Cent. Und dann müssen sie sehen, wie sie überleben, während sie den ganzen Tag irgendwelche harten Videos, Bilder sich ansehen müssen, um die KI zu trainieren.
Genau, und ohne die geht es halt gar nicht so.
Ja, also erschütternd zu lesen. Und dann habe ich noch des Weiteren mitgebracht, einen sensationellen Roman, Die Holländerinnen von Dorothee Elmega. Darüber werde ich nachher mehr erzählen. Ich habe dann, weil ich es schon mal vor Monaten angekündigt hatte, endlich das Unabomber-Manifest noch einmal gelesen. Und ich bin so erstaunt, diese ganzen rechten Diskurse, alles, was wir jetzt so gerade von Nios, Tichys Einblick, Joe Rogan, Leuten, die da sitzen bei Joe Rogan und irgendwie nochmal sagen, der Leftism ist das Problem, JD Vans, Ulf Poschert, ist alles in dem Manifest schon drin. Es ist wirklich so erstaunlich. Naja, das werde ich besprechen. Außerdem ein Artikel, wer kämpft noch in der Ukraine außer Ukrainer, nämlich Kolumbianische Söldner. Dann habe ich tatsächlich gesagt, ich gehe mal zu Tichys Einblick. Ich will mal wissen, was denkt eigentlich so dieser reaktionäre Arm des Kapitals über Friedrich Merz? Nichts Gutes. Und ich glaube, da sieht man schon, wie eine klare Brücke zur AfD gebaut wird. Und dann gibt es noch Musik, Brahms, Streichquartette.
Sehr gut. Ich rolle mal von hinten auf. Hast du dir schon mal über deine mentale Privatsphäre Gedanken gemacht?
Was kann ich darunter verstehen?
Du hast ja eine innere Stimme, die über Sachen nachdenkt, auch wenn du sie nicht aussprichst. Und die lässt sich anzapfen. Es gibt in den New York Times einen Text über die neuen Studien, wie man die inner voice jetzt schützen kann. Noch braucht man dafür Implantator und so, aber wir wissen ja, in welche Richtung der Fortschritt läuft. Darüber Aufklärung. Außerdem, es ist kein Zufall, dass Russland ukrainische Kinder entführt. Isolde Rudorfer hat nochmal die demografischen Eckdaten des Ukraine-Kriegs durchgegangen. Und weil es im Grunde mein Lieblingsthema ist, Wohnungstausch. Die Zeit hat mal eine Bilanz gezogen von einer sehr jungen Autorin, Karlotte Brue, die sich dieses Drama angeschaut hat. Und um herzuleiten auf diese zwei KI-Bücher, möchte ich gerne ein Thema kurz beschreiben. Ich habe mir gestern wieder didaktisch überlegt, mache ich es jetzt, der Groschen soll von alleine fallen, während ich darüber rede oder sage ich es ganz explizit. Und ich habe mich dafür entschieden, es ganz explizit zu sagen. In diesen beiden Büchern wird von Unsummen von Geldern gesprochen. So viel Geld wurde noch nie mobilisiert für nichts. Also auch der amerikanische Eisenbahnbau oder was auch immer. So. Und es gibt aber keine richtige Aufklärung darüber. Vielleicht, weil die Bücher ein bisschen zu früh waren oder so. Denn es gibt mittlerweile zwei Podcasts. Wir werden auf beide noch zurückkommen. Einmal von Esra Klein in einem Gespräch und dann im Big Technology Podcast mit einem Professor im Gespräch, bei dem die These aufgestellt wird. Diese KI-Unternehmen bauen KI's als Services, die sie dir pro Monat lizensieren, damit du sie verwenden darfst, die sich bei 20 oder 200 Euro nicht rentieren, sondern ab 2000 Dollar vielleicht im Monat. 2000 Dollar sind aber schon Einstiegsgehälter für Belegschaften. Was bedeutet, die ganze Anstrengung, die da drin steckt, wenn sie aufgeht, rentiert sich im Grunde nur, wenn damit einfach der Arbeitsmarkt ausgetauscht wird. Also Menschen raus, Maschinen rein. Und zwar wirklich im 1 zu 1 Verhältnis. Also nicht mehr so mit ach hier die Assistenz usw. usf., sondern es gibt ja schon diese Idee zu sagen, man schafft es, ein Unternehmen auf 1 Milliarde, also so Unicorn-Niveau zu hebeln, aber nur mit einer Person, die den Rest einfach zusammenpromptet. Und im Zuge dessen möchte ich jetzt kurz auf den August in Amerika eingehen, denn es gab von Donald Trump am 4. August eine Siegeserklärung auf Truth Social zum Thema Promise made, promises kept, negative net migration for the first time in 50 years. Also das erste Mal hat Amerika eine negative, also eine Auswanderungsbilanz vorzuweisen, die dann in einer Pressemitteilung des Weißen Hauses auch nochmal abgefeiert wurde, mit Verweis auf According to CNN. Ja, also man kommt gleich auf die Quellen, die man sonst nicht so mag, die jetzt Trump beglückwünschen dafür, eine negative Migrationsbilanz vorzuweisen. Und ich will mal kurz umreißen, was das bedeutet. Also Amerika hatte als John F. Kennedy die Mondrede hielt, also die Ankündigung, wir fliegen innerhalb eines Jahrzehnts auf den Mond, 186 Millionen Einwohner. Wir sind also hier nicht wie in Deutschland. Man kommt aus dem Krieg und eigentlich strömen alle zurück und so weiter. Es gibt so Flüchtlingsmigration und wir waren damals 75 Millionen, heute im Alter 80, so. Sondern nein, Amerika war damals zu JFKs Zeiten 186 und als sie tatsächlich auf den Mond gelandet sind, waren es schon 202 Millionen. Und zwar gerundet sogar 203 Millionen. Also innerhalb von sieben Jahren ist Amerika von 186 Millionen auf 202 Millionen gewachsen. Heute 2025 342 Millionen. Also alle demografischen Ideen von Putin mit, vor 100 Jahren hieß es, das große russische Reich, 150 Millionen, wird 500 Millionen Einwohner haben, und heute sind es 134 Millionen. In Amerika ist das die Realität. Sie haben sich verdoppelt, seit sie auf den Mond geflogen sind und JFK diese Ansage machte. Und es gab dazu auch ein Immigration und Nationality Act of 1965, der nämlich sagte, ab jetzt keine grotenbasierte Einwanderung mehr, sondern die Welt ist willkommen. Jeder, der möchte, darf kommen. Und Kinder, die hier geboren werden, sind automatisch Amerikaner. Alles das, was Trump jetzt sozusagen nicht möchte. Außerdem, mit der Migration hat sich natürlich Amerika weltweit auch als Softpower und Hoffnungsland etabliert. Also es gab die Flüchtlingsströme Brain Drain aus dem Osten, Ungarn, Vietnam, Kuba. Jedes Mal, wenn da irgendwas los war, strömten die Leute nach Amerika, weil sie wussten, da ist es safe. Oder das ist das Land, das uns ultimativ beschützt. Also warum hier auf Kuba irgendwie hoffen, sondern dann einfach wissen, in New York werden wir auf jeden Fall beschützt. Und damit hat man sich natürlich diese wirtschaftliche Dominanz geschaffen, weil man zum einen, und das ist ja heute auch wieder, wer flüchtet. Na derjenige, der es kann und sich was davon verspricht. Also man kriegt schon so die Besten der Besten. Also da ist so eine gewisse Auswahl drunter. Plus, die verankern ja dann wieder mit Familien in der Welt Amerika als, ich erkläre euch mal, wie die Welt funktioniert, indem ich euch von Amerika erzähle, überall in der Welt. Also diese ganze Soft-Power-Etablierung. Dann allerdings Corona-Tief. Amerika hatte 2021 nur noch 674.000 Einwanderer. Was bedeutet, die Bevölkerung wuchs nur um 0,16 Prozent, historisch niedrig. Dann allerdings nicht Trump, sondern Joe Biden. Was hieß, große Investitionsoffensiven, bitte bringt euer Geld hierher, kommt gleich mit und so. 1,3 Millionen Einwanderer. 2024, da kann man dann auch mal sehen, welche Bauchlandung Amerika gerade hinlegt, 2,8 Millionen Einwanderer. Höchstwert. Und jetzt 2025 netto negativ. Also das kann man sich einfach gar nicht vorstellen, was da gerade in Bewegung ist und so. Und jetzt zu den ökonomischen Zahlen. Dann ist die Frage, was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn diese Art von Migration auf die Amerika seit 50, 60 Jahren immer setzte, einfach abbricht? Es gibt eine Prognose des Congressional Budget Office, also das ist sozusagen bipartisan, der Kongress selbst hat da seine Beiräte. Die Prognose 2024 auf dieser Basis von 2,8 Millionen Einwanderern oder Nettowachstum, also es war Brutto noch viel mehr Einwanderung, Nettowachstum 2,8 Millionen, war, dass Amerika innerhalb der nächsten zehn Jahre, also von 2024 bis 34, um 8,9 Billionen Dollar wächst. Das ist zweimal Deutschland, zweimal die drittgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt, weil Wachstumsprognose für das nächste Jahrzehnt in Amerika eingeplant. Und jetzt sagt Trump einfach, ne, ist nicht. Also schneide diese Entwicklung einfach ab. Goldman Sachs und so, alle riesige Analysen dazu. Es gibt jetzt Studien zum Thema Warnung, Prognose. Was heißt eigentlich Donald Trump im Oval Office? Es könnte sein 2025, dass Amerika 525.000 Menschen in der Bevölkerung verliert, was sich äquivalent laut American Enterprise Institute auf bis zu 0,4 Prozent auswirkt. Und das ist sozusagen der Initiale. Danach verstetigt sich diese Entwicklung und hat so eine eigene Dynamik. Alle warnen die Federal Reserve Bank aus Dallas, das ist also Texas, hat eine der schlimmsten Warnungen ausgesprochen. Das Economic Policy Institute warnen einfach davor, dass man jetzt 1 bis 2 Millionen Menschen durch Eis einfach abschiebt. Plus darauf kommt ja noch diejenigen, die man dadurch vergrämmt, die also gar nicht überlegen, dahin zu ziehen oder sich dann von dort auf den Weg machen. Also es sind wirklich schlimme, schlimme, schlimme Zahlen. Man reagiert ein bisschen darauf hier in Europa. Also es gibt von Macron so ein Anwerbeprojekt, wo irgendwie 100 bis 500 Millionen Euro bereitgestellt werden. Von allein ist da auch mit eingestiegen. Es gibt auch deutsche Programme, 1000 Köpfe plus Programme, also dass man so ein Brain Drain aus Amerika jetzt holt. Und am verrücktesten fand ich folgende Zahlen. Ich habe mir mal, da es ja nicht nur diese Migrationswelle gibt, sondern auch noch den Kampf gegen die Intelligenz in den Universitäten und so. Also, Harvard hat eine oder alle Universitäten haben einen Anteil ausländischer Lehrkräfte von 22 Prozent, in Harvard sind es 43 oder irgendwie so in diesem Maßstab. Kennziffern, promovierte Wissenschaftler, der Computer- und Mathematikwissenschaftler sind zu 58 Prozent nicht in Amerika geboren, sondern das ist importierte Kompetenz. Ingenieure, 56 Prozent. Alle Wissenschaftler und Ingenieure mit Doktortitel in den USA sind zu 43 Prozent nicht dort geboren. Also, das sind diese, in den letzten 60 Jahren kamen sie einfach. So, das ist das Alter, in dem man nach Amerika zieht. MINT-Arbeitskräfte, 29 Prozent kommen, von den Ausländern sind aus Indien, 11 aus China. China hatte ja im Ressourcenstreit um die seltenen Erden und so weiter Handelsstreit, Zölle und so, war der Zugang zu amerikanischen Unis Platz 1 auf der Forderungsliste Chinas. Weil sie einfach wissen, die gehen dahin, kommen dann wieder zurück. Und bislang hat man in China noch nicht dieses offene, wir sind die Forschungseinrichtung der Welt, bei uns kann man einfach frei forschen und so, sondern nein, da läuft ja alles unter chinesischer Bürokratie, in Anführungszeichen, also da hält der Staat so die Hand drauf. Weshalb man sagt, okay, für diesen kurzen Moment der Ausbildung gehen alle nach Amerika, kommen dann nach China zurück. Die Inder sind bislang einfach alle geblieben. Also die sind einfach rüber und haben dann gesehen, hier ist ja viel cooler als zu Hause, also bleibe ich. Jetzt bietet sich aber diese Möglichkeit gar nicht mehr, denn die Ansage an Harvard ist ja derzeit keine ausländischen Studierenden.
Ja, ich sag mal, wenn China und Indien von ihrem autoritären Gehabe etwas wegkämen und mehr freie Forschung ermöglichen würden, also wirklich zu sagen, hier kann Freige Forschung machen, was er will, was glaubst du, was das Leute anziehen würde und wie problematisch die Situation dann erst für die US-Unis würde?
Ja, also das chinesische Silicon Valley heißt Wuhan. Wir kennen es natürlich jetzt nur wegen diesem Virus und so, aber in Wuhan gibt es 4.000 Unternehmen, die als erfolgsvoll sprechen für diese 15-Schlüssel-Technologien und so gelten. Und die Leute leiden dort unter Bürokratie. Also die kommen da hin und wissen einfach, oh nee, jetzt muss ich mich hier ewig und so weiter. Wir lesen das ja in dem KI-Buch auch, dass sie so Meta, willst du uns in Meta verwandeln? Das ist so das Schimpfwort für Bürokratie. Wie es bei Google aussieht, wissen wir. Die waren ja auch davor, wenn GPT-4 zu klug wird, wecken wir Google. Dann vergessen die nämlich ihre Bürokratie und werfen da alles rein und so. Also Bürokratie ist hier ein echtes Problem. Und in China ganz besonders. Das heißt, in China, die haben zwar auch demografische Probleme, aber die können halt noch Demografie abbauen und damit Potenziale entfesseln, die in Amerika schon entfesselt sind. Aber jetzt wird in Amerika eben die ganze Infrastruktur einfach abgebaut.
Der Wunsch der Republikaner ist ja, dass jetzt echte Amerikaner, Anführungszeichen, mehr Kinder bekommen.
Genau.
Was ja nicht passiert.
So, das passiert nicht. Also 1,6 Kinder pro Frau, historisches Tief, auch in Amerika. Was bedeutet, Amerika verspielt gerade 8,9 Billionen Dollar BIP-Wachstum in den nächsten zehn Jahren. Und meine Vermutung ist, irgendwer hat den Floh ins Ohr gesetzt, dass die KI das ausgleicht. Und deswegen sind die Investitionen so hoch. Man muss sich das vorstellen.
Und die sitzen ja einem Problem auf, ich werde das nachher erläutern, weil das ja nicht sein kann. Also hier müssen wir jetzt zurück zum Marx, denn das geht nicht. Also das BIP kann nicht gesteigert werden ohne Arbeitskräfte auf Dauer.
Also ja, das ist ein neues Paradigma, dass die Maschine so mitdenkt und eigene Entscheidungen treffen kann. Aber am Ende braucht, und es ist ja auch so eine Marxlosung, du brauchst auch Konsumenten.
Zum Beispiel.
Es reicht nicht nur, Sachen herzustellen.
Der Wert entsteht durch Arbeiter.
Arbeit und Verbrauch. Also der Mensch macht halt so Sachen.
Und zu glauben, man kann das alles so machen, deswegen denken die auch alle, das werden wir auch bei Sam Altman nochmal hören, an bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen, die Maschinen erwirtschaften ist. Mit irgendeiner Steuer ziehen wir dann Geld ab und das zahlen wir allen aus. Das ist eine Nonsensökonomie. Das funktioniert überhaupt nicht. Und das jetzt nicht, weil ich generell skeptisch gegenüber dem Bürgergeld, gegen bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen bin, sondern das kann nicht gehen und das müssen wir gleich nochmal herausarbeiten. Und ich glaube aber auch, diesen Flo hat man denen ins Ohr gesetzt.
Ja, die glauben daran. Also man muss sich vor allem einig kennen.
Du sagst jetzt schon zweimal Glauben und ich habe es auch schon gesagt, wir haben es hier mit zwei Büchern zu tun, die erzählen uns eigentlich was von der Religion. Also wir lesen jetzt gleich zwei Bücher über Religion.
Und zwar die indische. Das sind alles diese Brahmen, die Hinduisten.
Es ist eine neue Religion, die sich hier herausgebildet hat, die offenbar sehr wirkmächtig ist und auch ökonomische Rationalität einfach beiseite schiebt, wenn es mit dem Glauben nicht zusammengeht.
Also ich habe jetzt die Zahlen nur bei Scott Galloway gehört, weil er sie wiederholt hatte, aber sie scheint zu stimmen. In Amerika überragen dieses Jahr die Investments in KI das komplette Consumer Spending. Also alle Privatausgaben werden gerade in den Schatten gestellt davon. Und finde ich interessant, dass es überhaupt geht so, dass der Mensch nicht mehr das Zentrum der Wirtschaft ist, sondern jetzt einfach so eine Idee, einfach die so parallel gebaut wird. Und ich will nochmal darauf hinweisen, ich habe einfach nur gefordert in meiner Kinderwüste, dass wir das deutsche BIP von 4 auf 5 Billionen vergrößern und eine den Familien geben. Es geht also offenbar, einfach der Consumer Seite zu nehmen und zu sagen, wir bauen mal was Größeres daneben. Das könnte man also, da die Amerikaner jetzt voll in, wir investieren in Maschine, vielleicht wäre es eine deutsche Idee, wir gehen in die Menschen, wir investieren jetzt in Menschen. Wir bauen jetzt keine Datensender irgendwo hin, sondern einfach in die Schule. Und dann gucken wir mal in zehn Jahren, wie sich das rechnet im Systemstreit Europa gegen Amerika. Weil ich glaube, das geht nicht auf.
Ja, und da jetzt versuchen mitzustinken, funktioniert eh nicht und das wird nicht aufgehen. Also ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt gleich mal diese Religion religionskritisch unterziehen. Also hier ist wirklich Ideologiekritik gefragt, also im Sinne von, Hä, was meinen eigentlich die Katholiken damit, warum sollen jetzt Homosexuelle so behandelt werden und warum kein Sex von der Ehe und warum sind Frauen so und so? Und das haben wir alles erarbeitet uns, dass wir das kritisch betrachten und dass wir da quasi in der Moderne angekommen sind und schrittweise auch der Katholizismus dann dazu bereit war. Das machen wir mit anderen Religionen auch mehr oder weniger. Und jetzt hier haben wir es mit einer neuen Religion zu tun. Die müssen wir jetzt auch schon mal gleich wie in Mendner Kritik unterziehen. Und das geht vor allem über die Ökonomie. Dann kann man sagen, ja, das sind komische Fantastereien. Und dahin zukommt noch dieses eigenartige Verständnis von Intelligenz und Bewusstsein, was man diesen Maschinen zuschreibt. Merkwürdig. Also es haben gerade sehr viele Leute, die merkwürdiges Denken sehr viel macht.
Das ist Prinzip Hoffnung. Das ist ja das grüne Luludens.
Ja, also das Labubu, Stefan und ich gehen jetzt in den Salon. Und wir sprechen über die genannten Bücher jetzt erst mal ganz ausführlich über OpenAI.
Ich habe 60 Seiten Notizen mit sehr vielen Pointen.
Ach du lieber Gott. Ja, also ich habe etwas weniger Notizen, aber auch ein paar Pointen. Wir freuen uns, wenn wir uns gleich im Salon wiedersehen. Bis dahin.
Bis gleich. Hallo Wolfgang, hallo Stefan. Hast du Angst vor dem Doomsday?
Ich habe mehr Angst vor denen, die Angst haben vor dem Doomsday.
Okay, was hat es damit auf sich? Du bist also, es gibt Doomer und Boomer.
Ja.
Die einen wollen es, ist eigentlich, wenn man es auflöst, ein bisschen schwierig. Die einen wollen boomen, also die Technik schnell entwickeln und die sind am Ende aber doch nicht als Achse der Terroristen so sehr zu unterscheiden von denen, die das verhindern wollen.
Ganz interessante, also es wird immer wieder nahegelegt, dass man unterscheiden kann bei diesen KI-Entwicklern, den Unternehmen und Investoren zwischen denen, die sagen, die KI wird so übermächtig werden, dass sie möglicherweise die Menschheit in Büroklammern verwandelt oder was auch immer. Und da müssen wir also äußerst vorsichtig sein. Das heißt, wir brauchen Regularien, Sicherheitsteams und und und. Bedeutet aber nicht, dass die nicht entwickeln wollen. Also das sind nicht Unabomber jetzt, über die reden wir auch noch. Die sagen, nee, jetzt hören wir auf mit dem technischen Fortschritt, sondern die wollen auch den technischen Fortschritt. Und dann gibt es die, die sagen, ja, sowieso müssen wir jetzt ganz stark beschleunigen und und und. Und am Ende treffen sie sich beide dabei, dass sie investieren wollen, KI entwickeln wollen, sie unterschiedliche Interpretationen haben und diese Doomsday-Leute jedoch so weit gehen, dass sie sagen, ich brauche jetzt mal einen Bunker wie Sam Altman und ich brauche Waffen wie Sam Altman und habe Gasmasken aus dem israelischen Militär und habe für Habiot-Tabletten, bin also auf alles vorbereitet. Und ich sage, ich habe Angst vor denen, die Angst haben. Deshalb, weil für mich, nachdem ich jetzt diese beiden Bücher gelesen habe, eigentlich klar ist, der Doomsday ist ja, wenn man so will, schon da. Nämlich in Form dieser Menschen, die jetzt eine solche Machtfülle haben, die sie ja erbarmungslos ausnutzen, um immer mehr Land aufzunehmen, sich einzuverleiben. Und mit Land meine ich auch das so im buchstäblichen und im übertragenen Sinne, dass man eigentlich sagen muss, ja, die Gefahr ist ja längst da. Ich muss ja nicht darauf warten, dass eine böse KI kommt, die irgendwas von mir will, sondern das, was jetzt gerade entwickelt wird, wird ja schon von Menschen entwickelt, mit denen ich doch, was das Wertegerüst anbelangt und so, sehr wenig teile.
Genau, am Ende ist es wieder die nicht Waffen töten Menschen, sondern Menschen töten Menschen. Und in dem Falle hier sitzen ja auch Menschen dran und machen das. Damit sprichst du ja ein Ding an, das zumindest in Empire of AI ganz oft wiederholt wird, als Mantraf hast, nämlich, dass die Technologie unausweichlich sei oder unvermeidlich, laut der, deren und die HO immer wieder drauf hinweist, ne, ne, das haben Menschen gemacht, das wäre auch vermeidbar gewesen. Die Chinesen hätten nie so viel, nur weil jemand sagt, da steckt irgendwas in der Maschine, keine Ahnung, wir können so einen Geist wecken, da hättest du dieses Geld nicht gegeben. Dem würde ich allerdings irgendwie so ein bisschen widersprechen. Ich glaube, wir haben es tatsächlich mit unvermeidlicher Technologie zu tun, so als technische Kapazität, die man danach noch irgendwie regeln kann. Und es ist ja interessant, wie viel hier immer wieder über Sicherheit gesprochen wird, dass dann solche Leute wie Schutzkäfer oder Amodai immer wieder auf Sicherheit, Sicherheit, Sicherheit, noch bevor überhaupt die Maschine soweit war, dass man sie wieder containen muss. Haben die schon immer auf Sicherheit Wert gelegt, wird aber nie so richtig ausgeführt. Das ist ja die Kritik, die ich auch teile, was hier Sicherheit eigentlich bedeutet.
Ich gebe dir vollkommen recht und ich bin da auch bei Dürrenmatt im Prinzip. Wir kennen das Stück Die Physiker und das sagt ja uns, wenn eine Idee in der Welt ist, wenn etwas entdeckt wurde, erfunden wurde, dann ist es da und dann kann man es nicht mehr zurück wiedergegeist in die Flasche stecken. Und da würde ich auch sagen, worauf man Wert legen kann, ist, dass die Entwicklung in diese oder jene Richtung gelenkt werden kann. Es ist ja ein Unterschied, ob ich Atombomben oder Atomkraftwerke baue oder für die Radiologie wichtige Produkte herstelle, um Menschen von Rheumatismus zu heilen oder so. Ja, da sind ja die verschiedenen Bahnen gegeben. Aber das, was in die Welt kommt, ist nicht einfach so aufzuhalten, sondern das ist tatsächlich ein technischer Fortschritt, der sich vollzieht, der da oder dort besser sich vollziehen kann aufgrund von Investitionen in staatlichen Strukturen oder so etwas und einem gewissen Forschergeist, das alles richtig. Aber es muss schon erkannt werden, dass die Technik an sich da ist und auch sich weiterentwickeln wird. Und ich glaube jetzt, über jede Idee nachzudenken, wie kann man das jetzt mal stoppen, dann kommt man eigentlich genau ja in so ein Doomsday-Sprechen rein, wie das ja auch ein Elon-Maske immer wieder gefordert hat mit Moratorien und so etwas, werden man zugleich immer stärker wieder rein investiert in Unternehmen, die auf keinen Fall an ein Moratorium interessiert sind. Und weil das jetzt alles ein bisschen verwirrend klingt, würde ich sagen, wir müssen, und das ist ein bisschen schwierig bei den Büchern, weil die sehr kleinteilig ist, erst mal so von ganz grob außen draufblicken und sagen, dass Consumer-Internet, die Lieferdienst-App, das Labubu, das ich mir bestellen kann irgendwo über einen Online-Shop und dann da wieder zweitverkaufen kann, Dating-Apps, Wetter-Apps, all dieser Kram, irgendwelche Handyspiele. Das hatte ja keine Relevanz in der Form, dass man sagen konnte, das ist jetzt gefährlich für die Menschheit, sondern da konnte man höchstens sagen, die Kinder spielen zu viel mit dem Handy oder so etwas. Und jetzt hat man aber ja eine neue Ära und Alex Karp hat sie ja in The Technological Republic benannt, in der es nicht mehr um Consumer Electronics und diesen ganzen Kram geht, sondern es geht jetzt darum, wo steht der Staat, wo steht der Staat im Verhältnis zur Wirtschaft, was sind die geopolitischen Herausforderungen, oder wie man das nennt, Sicherheit steht im Vordergrund. Bedeutet also, Sam Altman und die Seinen haben ganz klar begriffen, jetzt geht dieses anti-staatliche, anti-Regulierungs-Ding, das man so lange im Silicon Valley gemacht hat, weil man einfach wollte, dass die jungen Leute früh in die sozialen Medien kommen, früh an die Handys kommen und auch schon da am besten mit der Kreditkarte von der Mutter Geld ausgeben, hat man jetzt verstanden, okay, wir können das in diesem Bereich nicht machen, sondern wir müssen jetzt sehen, dass wir die Politiker auf unsere Seite ziehen oder dass wir Teil dieser Macht auch werden. Weshalb ja Sam Altmann auch wirklich damit liebäugelt, Präsident sogar zu werden.
Oder Gouverneur oder alles andere.
Oder Gouverneur oder ja, irgendwas wichtiges in der Politik. Und dass wir daran jetzt sehr deutlich sehen kann, also was hier so an Sicherheit und Regulierung und so weiter gefordert wird, ist nicht das, was jetzt ein Chaos Computer Club oder so, oder eine andere Hackervereinigung fordert, wenn sie sagt, da muss reguliert werden oder so. Hier sind also die, die es entwickeln, daran interessiert, dass sich das so reguliert zu ihren Gunsten. Und dabei kommen sie natürlich mit dem Hochwertwort Sicherheit, das überall gut ankommt, wo man es ausspricht, sehr weit. Und ich glaube, darum geht es, wenn man eigentlich hier sieht, wie sehr immer wieder diese Diskussionen da gemacht werden, wie wichtig ist uns Sicherheit und so etwas. Naja, es geht nicht darum, die Menschheit für irgendetwas zu beschützen, auch wenn das immer so gesagt wird, sondern es geht vor allem darum, wie sichern wir unsere Interessen ab.
Ja, und da wird es aber jetzt heikel und da kommen auch neue Paradegmen, denn was hier zum Beispiel auffällt, wird im Buch jetzt auch nicht so expliziert. Ich hätte es zum Beispiel als Autor so richtig zentral gestellt. Bislang dachte man immer, es passieren so Sachen in der Welt, für die jemand verantwortlich sein muss. Also gab es zum einen eine Verschwörungstheorie und dann so eine technische Frage, was ist es jetzt so? Und dann sieht man im Nachhinein wieder eine Aufklärung, dass das Manhattan-Projekt zu Atombomben führte. Also schon eine sehr verschwörerische Aktion mit 100.000 Leuten in der Wüste, die dann am Ende den Krieg entscheiden. Und das zieht sich ja bis zuletzt, dass wir im Ukraine-Krieg dann eine Pipeline gesprengt haben, das ist so aufwendig, das muss ein Staat gemacht haben. Oder irgendwelche Hacker-Aktionen. Nee, das muss Nordkorea gewesen sein. Und jetzt dreht sich das hier aber komplett um. Also Staaten können manche Sachen gar nicht machen. Dafür braucht man Privatunternehmen wie Google, wie OpenAI, wie Meta und so. Weil nur die das schaffen. Und das finde ich hier in diesem Buch besonders interessant, denn wir haben jetzt mit so einer Technologie zu tun, die zum einen sehr leicht proliferierbar ist. Und damit meine ich nicht nur, am Ende braucht man nur eine Internetanbindung, um das Modell zu verwenden. Und dann macht man seine Hausaufgaben damit. Sondern selbst das Trainieren der Modelle wird ja demnächst, da wir ja hier auch hören, es ist jetzt im Grunde ausgereizt. Also mehr Informationen zum Verarbeiten hat man gar nicht. Mal sehen, es kommen jetzt immer die Europäer mit ihr. Wir haben so Industriedaten, die voll wertvoll sind oder so. Da würde ich gerne mal wissen, was meinen die damit da? Also ist jetzt irgendwie so eine Fabrik, wirft die so viel Daten ab, dass man da so viel daraus lernen kann, wie auch immer. Also der Datenschatz ist sozusagen aufgebraucht. Es gibt diesen Comment-Crawl, es gibt diese Bücherbestände, Wikipedia, YouTube, Transkripte, genau, es ist alles ausgereizt. Die Technologie selbst scheint ja wohl auf sehr wenigen Paratikmen zu trainieren, die man dann einfach nur richtig hoch skalieren muss. Also das scheint sich jetzt auch nicht so abschirmbar von der Welt zu halten, sondern es scheint sehr viele Maschinen lesen, Maschinen lernen, wie auch immer Studiengänge jetzt zu geben, indem man die Grundlagen einfach lernt. Und jetzt geht es nur noch um Compute. Und Nvidia hat aber schon angekündigt, dass die nächsten Computer, die man da entwickelt, einfach tausendmal so stark sind wie jetzt. Also auch das wird sich irgendwann ergeben. Das heißt, wir haben es jetzt schon, wenn man hier in die Bücher einsteigt, mit so einer sozialen Landkarte zu tun, die ganz schön weiträumig ist. Die haben zwar immer noch so ein Nukleus, wird ja in beiden Büchern über dieses Abendessen. Sam Altman hat so eine Idee, lädt dann Elon Musk als Finanzier ein, Yasut Kepfer ist auch da, die beiden faszinieren sich, dann geht es irgendwie los und entgründen sich OpenAI und so. Nur jetzt, nur sieben Jahre später, haben wir ja die Situation, Google ist tatsächlich erwacht, steckt da voll drin, hat ja auch die ganze Grundlagentechnologie mit Transformer gemacht, Chaffray hinten angeworben und so weiter. Nur aus OpenAI ist ja jetzt eigenständig Entropic rausgekommen mit ihrem eigenen, schon produktiven Service, den man einfach nutzen kann, also Clot. Dann gibt es diese Firma von Mira Murati, die ja jetzt kürzlich Übernahmeangebote bekommen hat von Mark Zuckerberg, wo einzelne Ingenieure angesprochen wurden, wenn ihr zu uns kommt und beim Meta das macht, was ihr da macht, bekommt ihr einfach nur 1,5 Milliarden Dollar für den Handshake, das ihr hier arbeitet. Und die haben aber abgelehnt.
Das sind mal Löse.
Also man kann schon mit Geld nichts mehr kaufen, so in der Richtung. Und dann Ilja Zutskever, immer noch finde ich der interessanteste Typ, was ja viele finden, der eben seinen Security-Superintelligenz-Firma da macht, die ganz bewusst sagt, keine Produkte. Wir haben einfach keine Produkte. Bei uns kann man nur investieren. Und ich habe so einen gewissen Nimbus. Und die Bücher bestätigen ja das auch immer wieder. Also wenn ihr irgendwo investieren wollt, dann doch bei mir. Und das machen dann Leute auch. Nur keine Produkte. Und das ganze Investitionsgeschehen findet noch so privat statt. Keine dieser Firmen ist an irgendeiner Börse gelistet. Außer Google und Meta, aber da ist es eh feuerfrei. Bei XAI weiß keiner so richtig, ist das jetzt echte Intelligenz oder ist das einfach nur auf dem Benchmark getrimmt? Das wird ja von Elon Musk, der der größte Warner ist, jetzt komplett auf Halligalli getrimmt.
Ja, ich will das auch noch mal als ein größeres Thema bei Wohlstand für alle besprechen mit Ola. Es ist ja so, dass man ja nicht investieren kann eigentlich in all diese Entwicklungen. Man kann in diese NASDAQ investieren oder ich kann in die entsprechenden Silicon Valley Konzerne investieren, die einen IPO schon hinter sich haben. Aber das eigentliche, wo jetzt gerade das Geld reingesteckt wird und diese enormen Erfolge erzielt werden, das ist alles nicht an der Börse zu finden. Das bedeutet also, wir haben jetzt hier tatsächlich noch mal so eine besondere Konsolidierung der Macht und auch eine ökonomische Konzentration, wo überhaupt keine Partizipation mehr möglich ist. Um das jetzt deutlich zu machen, für die, die das jetzt nicht gelesen haben und vielleicht auch nicht lesen wollen, also es ist sehr kleinteilig, das sage ich gleich schon mal. Also das ist die Frage, wie weit man sich da rein begeben will. Aber vielleicht ist eine Linie noch wichtig, neben der Frage von Sicherheit und Staatlichkeit und so etwas. Es gibt einen permanenten Konflikt bei Open AI, wie sehr man kommerziell sein will. Das bedeutet also, erstmal gab es ja die Idee, man macht das als Non-Profit-Organisation. Dann hat man irgendwann gemerkt, nein, nur so will man es eigentlich nicht machen. Man will auch nochmal anderes Kapital anziehen. Dann hat man das ja gesplittet. Es gibt Non-Profit-Anteile und dann gibt es Profit-Anteile. Und dann gibt es aber auch diese Idee, sollen wir uns jetzt gerade damit beschäftigen, irgendein neues Chat-GPT rauszubringen oder irgendein anderes Programm, das Leute für 20 oder 200 Euro im Monat abonnieren? Sollen wir uns noch damit abgeben? Sind wir dann nicht noch eigentlich genau in dem Modus, wie das Internet vor zehn Jahren? Ja, man versucht, eine App rauszubringen und Leute kaufen die für fünf Euro im Monat. Oder sollten wir sagen, nein, wir gehen all in, AGI, müssen wir entwickeln und jetzt diese ganzen anderen Spirenzchen hatten wir neues Chat-GPT, gibt es irgendwie eine Optimierung da, bringen uns ab beziehungsweise bremsen uns in dem eigentlichen Weg, eine allgemeine Intelligenz hervorzubringen, die dann so übermächtig sein wird, dass natürlich die alle anderen Produkte schlagen wird und sowieso vielleicht die menschliche Arbeit überflüssig machen. Das heißt also, diese Wette auf die Zukunft, und das ist ja eigentlich, was sie dann so als die Atombombe für sich ansehen, die sie haben wollen, ja und sie fürchten sich davor, das andere sie haben, ist also, dass diese AGI entstehen kann. Die sind alle geprägt von Nick Bostrom, von Ray Kurzweil und diesen Ideen, der Singularität und all dem. Und da beginnt natürlich die Sphäre des Glaubens, also dass man tatsächlich annimmt, dass eine AGI, also ein Wesen sich mit Bewusstsein entwickeln kann, wenn man nur genügend skaliert und investiert und all das. Und hier würde ich immer sagen, nee, das kann ja gar nicht sein. Man wird noch sehr viel bessere LLMs bauen können und es werden noch Dinge möglich sein, von denen wir jetzt noch nicht glauben, dass sie möglich sind. Aber diese AGI, die am Ende für sich entscheidet, was jetzt als nächstes wirtschaftlich erfolgreich sein wird und das dann einfach für sich umsetzt und der Mensch da gar nicht mehr wichtig ist, sondern maximal noch so eine kleine beaufsichtigende Position hat. Das ist ja ein religiöser Glaube, der da ist. Und da sind manche, die folgen ganz dem. Also sagen dann, wir machen jetzt sogar ein Unternehmen, das überhaupt nicht an Profit interessiert ist, aber ihr könnt investieren. Oder man macht zum Mittelding wie OpenAI mit Sam Altman zu sagen, wir müssen auch mal sehen, dass wir ein paar schwarze Zahlen schreiben. Deswegen geben wir auch mal ein paar andere Modelle raus, die die Consumer verwenden können. Aber eigentlich sind wir natürlich auch noch darauf aus, dieses große Ziel, AGI zu erreichen.
Also ich finde, es gibt noch so eine, also neben all diesen Glaubensfragen, die völlig zurecht sind, wo man aber sagen muss, die haben 2018, 2019 die Idee gehabt, mit denen die an Leute herangetreten sind, von denen bestimmt relativ viele gesagt haben, ich glaube ihr spinnt irgendwie. Und jetzt fünf Jahre später beißen die sich natürlich alle in den Arsch, weil diese Investitionsentscheidung, die da drinsteckt, da haben sie nicht verwirklicht. Also sie haben einfach diesen Open-My-Eye-Wall, entwickelt sich von 500 Millionen zu 500 Milliarden, nicht mitgemacht. Also dieser Glaube ist eben nicht nur so ein Glaube im Jenseits, sondern es wurde sehr viel ins Diesseits geholt, von dem was als jenseitig aussah. Es gibt aber eine profanere Ebene noch, die mir komplett fehlt irgendwie in beiden Büchern. Aber ich sehe auch, dass es wahrscheinlich sehr schwer ist, denn das Peter Thiel hier Zampano hinter allem ist. Dickster Freund mit Sam Altman.
Und sowieso mit Mark Zuckerberg. Sam Altman lernt seinen Ehemann im Whirlpool von Peter Thiel kennen. Nur so Dinge.
Genau, also lauter solche Sachen. Die sind wahrscheinlich schwer aufzuklären, da Peter Thiel, nachdem er 2016 sich als Trump-Unterstützer öffentlich gezeigt hat, relativ schnell verstanden hat. Nee, nicht öffentlich. Ich mache das einfach alles hintenrum. Wir erfahren hier von irgendwelchen Abendessen und so weiter. Es gab wahrscheinlich noch tausend mehr Termine, von denen niemals ein Journalist so hört. Ja. Man sitzt im Pool, wie auch immer. Das heißt, da müssen wir uns jetzt auch so viel rein imaginieren, wie das so funktioniert in dieser ganz kleinen Gang von Leuten, die sich nicht nur freundschaftlich gegenüberstehen, sondern sich auch gegenseitig diese Abwerberangebote machen, weil am Ende ist es dann doch die eigene Firma, die davon profitieren soll und es klappt dann nicht immer. Und dass es hier viel Streiterei gab, ist ja auch klar. Nur auch Amodai war jetzt nicht freundlich gesinnt oder offen, jetzt einfach mal über die Sachen mit Sam Othman zu reden, obwohl er da im größten Streit gegangen ist. Also da gibt es schon so eine profane Verschwiegenheit, dass alle auf so ein Marktgeschehen wetten, bei dem sie große Rollen spielen, dass sie sich dann nicht gegenseitig auf dem Fuß stehen.
Ja, man kann sich das ein bisschen vorstellen, um beim Katholizismus zu bleiben wie bei der Kurie.
Genau, das ist echte Klausur, die hier so stattfindet.
Weiß man nicht, welche Intrigen sind da alle. Und dann gibt es ja dann sofort die Verschwörungstheorien, warum es Papst Benedikt damals zurückgetreten war. Es war wirklich nur die Gesundheit, da war es nicht auch an anderen Dingen und, und, und. Ja, also diese ganzen Intrigen, die ja de facto auch da sind, die haben wir jetzt hier nur mit sehr viel mächtigeren Leuten. Hier geht es nicht darum, ob irgendwo ein Bischof benannt wird oder irgendein kleiner Skandal oder auch größerer Skandal mal unter den Tisch gekehrt wird, sondern hier geht es um Billionenbeträge. Und wir sind auch in einem Bereich, bei dem wir ja erstmal einen interessanten Ansatz haben von Karen Howe zu sagen, ich nenne das Buch Empire of AI, also bin im Imperialismus-Diskurs damit drin, spreche über den Kolonialismus, der jetzt durch diese Sam Oltmans ausgeübt wird, in der Form, dass sie einfach alle Daten, ob es erlaubt ist oder nicht, sich erstmal nehmen, die crawlen, dann manchmal behaupten, ne, das waren wir gar nicht oder das haben wir wieder gelöscht und solche Dinge, ja. Also sich erstmal alles einverleiben, was die Menschheit so geschaffen hat, inklusive dann noch eine Stimme rauszubringen, die sehr danach klingt, als sei es Scarlett Johansson im Hör, und man sagt, nein, nein, das ist nicht die Stimme, die klingt nur ähnlich, ja. Also diese ganzen Urheberrechtsverletzungen oder zumindest diese Krauzone, in denen man sich bewegt, dass man also einfach eine neue Ordnung setzt und das herrschende Recht ignoriert, das ist die eine Tendenz des Kolonialismus. Die zweite ist dann eine ganz konkrete, die auch anzuknüpfen ist eben an das 19. Jahrhundert zum Beispiel. Man geht in Länder, die arm sind und sagt hier, können Leute für einen Dollar die Stunde, die dreckige Arbeit machen, nicht in Minen hier, sondern die sitzen vor dem PC, im Akkord gucken die sich, kinderpornografisches Material, alles mögliche, müssen die sich vor Augen führen und müssen dann das aussieben, damit das nicht in die KI hineingeht oder sie müssen die KI korrigieren, müssen die KI anlernen, bessere Antworten zu geben, all das. Und wir haben natürlich noch die Landnahme in der Weise, dass man unglaublich viele Rechenzentren braucht, die sehr viel Wasser verschwenden. Wo macht man das? Na ja, gerne in den Regionen, wo Energie günstig ist, aber die Leute sowieso schon Wasserprobleme haben. Das verleiht man sich weiter ein. Viele weitere Beispiele können wir jetzt nennen. Wir haben jetzt einen Kolonialismus auf mehreren Ebenen. Ich finde aber interessant, dass Karen Howe so wenig diese Verbindung macht. Ich glaube, das ist aus einem demokratischen Impetus heraus, einem basisdemokratischen Impetus, der auch von Naomi Klein ist, die ja wohl geprägt herkommt. Dass sie immer so sieht, die Konzerne sind jetzt so diese neuen Imperialisten. Das ist vergleichbar mit dem Kolonialismus, was aber so bei ihr ausgeklammert wird, fast immer, ist der Staat. Und dass ein solches Vorgehen so stattfindet, funktioniert natürlich nur, wenn man diese Absicherung der US-Weltmacht hat, dass man so agieren kann. Und sie hat immer noch, glaube ich, so diese Idee, die gute Politik müsse doch erst mal kommen, um zu verstehen, die Silicon Valley-Leute meinen es gar nicht gut und die werden die dann schon einhegen. Dabei, glaube ich, verkennt sie, dass diese Silicon Valley-Leute sehr wohl US-Interessen vertreten auf ihre Weise und sie sich ja gar nicht mehr dafür interessieren, was ist jetzt mit dem amerikanischen Konsumenten? Wird der ausgespäht oder sonst was? Völlig egal. Und wir sehen es ja dann auch an einigen Details, die man dann auch zum Beispiel bei Keech Hagge, also in ihrem Buch über Sam Altman nachlesen kann, dass dann zum Beispiel auch jemand wie Nancy Pelosi plötzlich versucht und es auch schafft, eine Regulierung der KI-Firmen zu verhindern. Dass sie also durchaus sieht, ah, okay, die machen jetzt eigentlich da gerade unsere Arbeit. Und ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen was, was da so fehlt, auf so einer, auf eine abstraktere Ebene zu kommen. Wenn wir heute über einen Imperialismus reden oder über so einen Kolonialismus, der sich da ausbreitet, da muss man erkennen, früher hatte man sehr klar den Staat als Akteur und der hatte dann noch so was wie die East Indian Company als so ein Staatsunternehmen, das dann losgeschickt wurde, um Tee zu exportieren oder so etwas. Aber heute, glaube ich, erleben wir jetzt nicht einfach nur so eine Herrschaft des neoliberalen Konzerns, der auf der Welt macht, was er will, sondern heute ist eigentlich Empire of AI eine Verbindung zwischen den privaten Unternehmen und dem Staat. Beziehungsweise der Staat muss jetzt gar nicht mit der Armee da irgendwas absichern oder so in Kenia, da mit der Clickworker arbeiten, sondern das kann der Konzern schon selbst regeln über Geld, finanziellen Druck etc. Und der Staat muss dann nur noch dafür sorgen, dass die in ihrem eigenen Land nicht einen auf den Deckel bekommen und ziemlich dereguliert arbeiten können. Oder Sam Altman sitzt gleich in Washington mit Obama oder Biden am Tisch und schlägt vor, wie man die Gesetze schreiben sollte. Und das ist, glaube ich, so eine Konstellation, die sie nicht so richtig fassen will.
Ja, also das Staatenersetzwerden von Konzernen finde ich auch einen sympathischen Gedanken, aber den treibt sich schon zu weit. Den treibt sich zu weit. Das wird zu implizit abgehandelt, denn sie beschreibt ja, sie hat in ihrer Arbeit und ihrem Nachdenken darüber nur eine Metapher gefunden, die die Natur dieser mächtigen KI-Aktüre treffend beschreibt, Imperien. Denn Imperien haben an sich, dass sie mit Ressourcen umgehen, die ihnen nicht gehören, die sie aber auch nicht kaufen, sondern die sie einfach ausbeuten. Arbeitskraft der unterwerfenden, unterworfenen Völker spielen also eine Rolle. Entmenschlichende Vorstellungen von der eigenen Überlegenheit, das ist ja da eh schon einprogrammiert, Verletzung von Souveränitäten, Diebstahl, Unterwerfung und das alles um einen Wettrüsten, Wettstreit im Sinne des Fortschritts zu machen, aber immer auf Kosten der anderen. Und da habe ich auch gedacht, ja, es ist doch völlig klar, dass eine amerikanische Regierung da Wohlwollen daneben steht und einfach nur sagt, macht mal, dass es dann vielleicht nicht mehr Verquickungen geben muss, sondern dass das schon relativ viel ausreicht. Nur in diesem Fall haben wir es ja nun wirklich klar, da sind ihre Bücher dann, also beide Bücher zu früh, aber vor wenigen Wochen wurde ja jeweils ein Mitarbeiter von Meta, Google und dann noch zwei weitere, also vier Silicon Valley Mitarbeiter als Lieutenant Colonel in der amerikanischen Armee vereidigt.
Stimmt, ja.
So, die sind jetzt also eins zu eins, die haben diese Geheimnis-Clearance und so weiter und so fort. Also das totale Verquickung, war es vielleicht sogar jemand noch von Palantir oder so, also wie man sich das halt so vorstellt. Also diese Verquickung ist sehr viel größer, als das hier in diesem Buch so beschrieben wird. Sie machte eben diese klein-klein-empirische Arbeit, die ist natürlich auch hoch anzurechnen. In der Sicht ist das auch für Geschichtsstudenten ein interessantes Buch, sag ich mal. Beide erklären ja gleich am Anfang, dass sie 300 Interviews mit 260 Personen führen, umfangreiche Datensammlungen auswerten. Sie, also die Hau geht da nochmal drauf ein, 40 aktuelle Mitarbeiter, Führungskräfte von Microsoft, Anthropic, Meta, Google, DeepMind und Scale gesprochen zu haben. DeepMind ist ehemals englisch, jetzt zu Google gehörend und Scale. Davon haben wir alle nichts gehört. Das beschreibt sie ja auch später. Das sind also die, die die Datenaufbereitung machen. Während Mark Zuckerberg immer meinte, ne ja klar noch haben wir 30.000 Clickwürge, die in Bangladesch, Kenia und Nigeria ja unsere Schrottarbeit machen. Aber bald macht das ja die KI und jetzt stellen wir fest, ne das macht gar nicht die KI, sondern die KI muss selber erst mal so aufbereitet werden, dass da nochmal 100.000 Leute so in den Keller hängen und mit allen Problemen, die da dran hängen. Also es ist wirklich crazy. Und ich finde das Buch von Hau ist wirklich gut konzipiert, weil sie ganz am Anfang dieser Szenerie beschreibt, wie Sam Altman am 17. November 23 entlassen wird. Ja. Weil das eigene Open AI Board und wir wissen einfach gar nicht, was ist denn dieses Board? Da sind jetzt so halb halb auch Führungskräfte von Open AI drin, aber das ist so unabhängig und die Murati eben auch, ja ich bin die Vorgesetze von Brockman, aber ich kann ihm gar keine Evaluierung schreiben, weil der ist ja gleichzeitig Boardmember. Also die wissen selber gar nicht, wie das richtig funktioniert. Aber Sam Ortman wird entlassen und sie beschreibt es so deskriptiv einfach, wie es passiert und weckt damit die Hoffnung, dass es am Ende des Buches irgendwie Sinn ergibt, dass wir es verstehen. Und ich denke mir so, ja, am Ende versteht man es auch irgendwie ganz gut. Ihm ist nichts Konkretes, als Lüge vorzuweisen, nachzuweisen, aber so im Gesamtgefüge versteht man schon, warum es passierte. Und da steckt ja eine witzige Pointe drin, denn in der Gründerzeit als Open AI sich gerade fast, also versucht eine Verfassung für dieses, wir sind offen, aber brauchen auch Ressourcen, wie machen wir das denn und so, gibt es diesen Moment als Ilja Sutzkever, Elon Musk sagt, ja, ja, wir hätten dich schon gerne an Bord, aber wenn du mit deinem Geld diese Forderung mitbringst, wie das organisiert ist, haben wir Angst davor, dass du dich nur, weil du es willst, zum Diktator von Open AI machen kannst. Und daraufhin entscheidet sich auch Sutzkever gegen Elon Musk. Also die machen Open AI gegen Elon Musk und Sam Altman verspricht dann, ja, ich kriege das schon hin, mit meinen Zauberkünsten des Fundraisings das auszugleichen.
Und Sam Altman ist ja ein Fan von Elon Musk.
Genau, ein Fan von Elon Musk. Aber sie entscheiden sich lieber für eine Nicht-Diktatur und verzichten sogar auf das Geld. Und am Ende ist aber Sam Altman dieser Diktator, vor dem sie sich selber immer gewarnt haben. Und kommt einfach nach fünf Tagen wieder zurück.
Er hat eine andere Strategie, wie er vorgeht. Das wird dann immer so beschrieben. Es ist gespenstisch, wenn man das so liest, dass er mit allen Lagern scheinbar gut kann. Also mit den Boomen und Doomern, mit denen, die zu mehr Kommerz plädieren. Die anderen, die sagen, nein, wir müssen nur forschen. Er stellt sich mit allen interessiert und gut, ist sehr aufmerksam, hört gut zu, muss sehr freundlich sein, wird nicht laut. Dann wird er aber immer wieder der Lüge überführt. Aber er gesteht das natürlich nicht ein, sondern sagt, da habe ich mich missverständlich ausgedrückt. Ich wollte doch nur helfen. Dinge, die ganz klar sind, dass hier hinter dem Rücken was gelaufen ist. Und er sagt einfach, da habe ich mich wohl missverständlich ausgedrückt. Das tut mir sehr leid. Also es ist so eine neue Führungskultur. Wir haben also hier nicht den Boss, der schreit und sagt, hört mir zu oder so.
Und was so neu ist, ist halt die Frage. Ich würde eben sagen...
Es sind diese subtilen Techniken, die er macht, die mit einem sehr therapeutischen Sprechen einhergehen. Also eigentlich ist das so das Interessante bei ihm. Eigentlich verhält er sich so, wie man sagen würde, ach toll, das ist nicht toxisch. Aber genau dadurch, dass er so unglaublich zuvor kommt, ist und eigentlich jedem auch so ein bisschen nach dem Mund redet und so, ist es eine besonders gefährliche Mischung.
Wir können es ja mal beschreiben. Im großen Bild ist es ungefähr so, umso größer die Konferenz ist, in der alle teilnehmen, umso weniger sagt Sam Altman, umso mehr Nachgespräche im 1 zu 1 hat er. Um irgendwie die ganzen Wünsche, die im Raum waren, aufzugreifen und dann alle miteinander gegeneinander auszuspielen, jedem sagen, ich will doch nur helfen und hier und da, wie kann ich helfen? Blablabla und am Ende stellen alle fest, Mr. Atme hat mir jetzt wieder das versprochen und dem das, das geht ja am Ende gar nicht auf. Es nützt alles nur Sam Altman. So, gleichzeitig sagt Open AI, okay, wir brauchen hier nicht Investitionen, sondern so ein Umfeld von Nutzern, Usern. Also wir gründen so ein Fund, in dem einfach kleine Firmen, die sagen, ah, wir können was aus eurem Produkt machen, aus diesem ganzen GPT-Zeug, dann fördern wir das. Und dann stellt sich Jahre später raus, dass dieser Fund einfach unter Open AI gelabelt ist, aber komplett Sam Altman gehört. So, dass alle Renditen einfach zu ihm fließen. Und man auch gar nicht genau weiß, welche Firma kriegt jetzt eigentlich wie viel Geld davon. Und so, ja, das macht alles der Sam Altman. Das ist so sein Vorstandszuständigkeitsbereich, wie auch immer. So, und dann gibt es diese interessante Situation, dass den, und da würde ich sagen, das ist jetzt nicht so neu, gerade die neu gegründeten Organisationen. Also wenn man in so bestehende Hierarchien reinkommt, muss man tausend Reiseanträge für drei Fahrten machen, aber wenn nicht, dann ist halt alles auf Zuhuf. So, also für diese gründungsgeführten Unternehmen scheint das wohl so gang und gäbe zu sein, wie auch immer. Und dann gibt es, als dann Sam Altman gefeuert wird aufgrund dieser Verquickungen, ein Videotelefonat von Ilja Sutzkever und Murati mit der ganzen Belegschaft. Und die Belegschaft will wissen, was ist denn jetzt hier? Sam Altman hat die letzten Jahre immer unsere Produkte vorgestellt und war in allen Videos präsent. Er ist das Gesicht unserer Firma. Wie sollen wir denn jetzt ohne ihn weitermachen? Also genau diese Gründer geführten Sachen, die halt dann plötzlich nicht mehr aufgehen. Aber es ist nur so eine Angst, so eine Vorstellung, die die halt haben, dass es wir sind noch nicht Siemens. Wir können nicht einfach den CEO austauschen. So, ne? Und dann sagt Sutzkever, wir haben hier alle Zutaten, die wir brauchen. Den Computer, die Forschung, die Durchbrüche sind erstaunlich. Und dann versucht er die Belegschaft mit folgendem Nerd-Gedanken zu überreden, dass alles gut wird. Wenn sie sich unsicher fühlen, wenn sie Angst haben, denken sie an diese Dinge, stellen sie sich die Größe des Clusters, und er meinte den Computercluster, vor ihrem inneren Auge vor, stellen sich einfach all diese GPUs vor, die zusammenarbeiten. Für Sutzka war natürlich ein nachvollziehbarer Gedanke. Der war einfach scaling war so. Ich brauche einfach nur viele Computer. Und wenn ich da drüben sehe, auf der Heide steht so eine Fabrik, und da stehen sie alle drin, so eine große Lagerhalle. Und die arbeiten da, bin ich zufrieden. Nur normale Menschen denken so nicht, sondern die wollen einfach die Koryphäe Sam Altman. Also gehen 700 von 770 Leuten einfach auf die Straße und sagen, ohne Sam Altman machen wir hier nicht weiter. Insbesondere, weil wir Abwerberangebote von Microsoft gekriegt haben und so. Also geht diese ganze Sozkever-Idee von, ich sag dir einfach, wie groß der Computer ist, den wir haben, und damit schaffen wir es schon, geht also nicht auf. Und da sieht man schon, wie das...
Er spielt die Intrige, wird aber dann auch öffentlich bekunden, dass er sich dann selber noch mit auf die Liste ruft. Und er unterschreibt dann auch, dass Sam Altman wieder zurückkommen muss.
Genau. Also ging alles so gar nicht auf. Und hier sieht man schon, wenn sich unter Ingenieuren ein Ingenieur noch dazu mischt, der einfach eine soziale Kompetenz hat, dann kann der alle übernehmen. Dann sind die Ingenieure einfach unter sich. Und da ja Sam Altman sehr als Überflieger, der sich in allen großen Ivy Leagues beworben hat und alle Stipendien bekam und sich das immer aussuchen konnte und so. Da kam er halt mit seinen Social Skills da zu Rande unter all diesen Super-Nerds wie Soodzkepper.
Und er ist ein absoluter Machtmensch. Hier wird sein Mentor Paul Graham zitiert. Der sagt, You could parachute him into an island full of cannibals and come back in five years, he'd be the king. Sam is extremely good at becoming powerful. Das ist die Geschichte, die uns beide Bücher erzählen, auf unterschiedliche Weise. Bei Oltmann ist es ja so, dass er 1985 geboren, von Anfang an ja ganz große Ambitionen hat, aber weiß, er muss jetzt erstmal so ein bisschen Geld verdienen. Also er hat dann so eine Tracking-App, die er errichtet, die auch sich gut verkaufen lässt, also mit der man Standorte teilen kann. Loopt heißt das Unternehmen, das ist so Coupon ähnlich. Man hat da so eine Idee davon, dass man also mit der Privatsphäre sowieso nicht mehr weit kommt. Leute werden bereit sein, ihre Standorte zu teilen. Aber das ist für ihn eigentlich nur so der Weg, um das Eigentliche zu tun. Also wir haben es hier eben mit einem anderen Charakter zu tun, als wir das bei so anderen Gründern haben, die sagen, ich will reich werden und will vielleicht eine schöne App oder eine zweite noch rausbringen. Sondern ihm geht es tatsächlich darum, eine Mission zu erfüllen. Es wird tatsächlich als Idee angenommen, man gründet eine Firma und oder eine Religion. Und darum geht es ihm eigentlich. Das wird sehr deutlich. Er ist dann derjenige, der auch irgendwann sieht, dass man mit Ketamine-Einnahme sich entsprechend optimieren kann. Das scheint ja im Silicon Valley unglaublich verbreitet zu sein, dieser Wahn, der aber jetzt wohl auch hier rüber schwappt. Wie ich es so vernehme. Und damit glaubt man dann sowieso, sich optimieren zu können. Und er ist dann aber auch jemand, der sagt, ich muss Geld verdienen. Und er hat dann schon mit Mitte 20 fast ausgesorgt, kann man sagen, oder hat dann ausgesorgt. Macht dann Investitionen, hat am Ende ein Netzwerk aus 400 Unternehmen, ist diese 400 Unternehmen investiert. Und das auch mit kleinen Beträgen zum Teil. 15.000, 25.000 kostet dann so ein Investitionsticket. Er baut dann Netzwerke mit diesen Unternehmen auf. Er verbindet sich dann auch mit schwulen KI-Entwicklern. Also auch da gibt es nochmal so ein Netzwerk. Und er merkt auch, er muss sich transformieren in den freundlichen Mann, der niemals Nein sagt. Das ist das Entscheidende. Also er merkt schon, er muss eine Führungsstärke bekommen, dadurch, dass man nicht herrisch auftritt, sondern dass man eigentlich der ist, der allen zuhört. Und dann geht es eben darum, die ja in Kontakt zu treten mit den wirklich wichtigen. Elon Musk haben wir schon genannt. Aber von Anfang an ist da auch eine Faszination zu Peter Thiel da. Er besucht auch diese berühmte Vorlesung von Peter Thiel, in der Peter Thiel empfiehlt, 10-fach wachsen. 10-fach wachsen, alles muss zum Monopol hin tendieren. Und die beiden verstehen sich wahnsinnig gut, wenngleich man sagen muss, politisch kommen sie aus so unterschiedlichen Richtungen. Also Altman ist der, der sich einsetzt für die Ehe für alle, gegen Homophobie gewisse Aktionen macht. Aber jetzt ist Peter Thiel auch schwul, aber er ist ja derjenige, der quasi dieses politisch Unkorrekte liebt. Und wenn das...
Contrarian.
Contrarian, genau. Das ist ja die Bezeichnung. Und auch ist Altman dann jemand, der in den Demokraten eigentlich die Hoffnung sieht. Wir werden da vielleicht noch gleich näher drauf eingehen, während das ja dann bei Peter Thiel so ist, dass er zu dem Trump-Lager dann geht. Was man sagen kann, ist, dass Open AI zunächst mal das Anti-Google sein will. Also sowohl in Form von Organisation, dass man nicht so ein Bürokratie-Monster wird, als auch dahin, dass man sagt, wir sind crowdfunded, wir sind offen, wir sind nicht nur auf den Kommerz aus. Wir wollen tatsächlich hier etwas schaffen, das AGI ermöglicht. Also wir sind ganz die Diener der Forschung. Aber das ist natürlich von Anfang an ein Versprechen oder man könnte auch sagen eine Behauptung.
Also dieses Buch erklärt ja sehr vieles über die Spleens der Leute, die da zu tun haben. Und es gab 2012 eine Begegnung zwischen Elon Musk, damals schon Tesla, Zampano und so weiter. Und wir wissen auch damals, das ist nicht der Elon Musk von heute, sondern der war noch sehr auf, ich mache hier Klimawandel, Bekämpfung, die Ressourcen sollen im Boden bleiben. Wir fahren jetzt mit Batterie und so weiter und so fort. So und er trifft Demis Hazabis, der damals Deep Mind schon als CEO geführt hat in London, als Google auch gerade darauf aufmerksam wurde. Und die beiden führen ein Gespräch bei Mittagessen, bei dem sie darum wettstreiten, wer jetzt die größte Gefahr abwendet. Und Elon Musk sagt, meine Gefahrenabwehr besteht darin, dass ich zum Mars fliegen will. Da ist die Menschheit sicher vor allem, was auf der Erde passiert. Und dann sagt ihm Hasabis, ja, aber was ist, wenn dich meine Superintelligenz da einfach begleitet? Denn du fliegst ja offenbar mit Computern dahin und die kann sich ja da verstecken und so weiter. Und daraufhin scheint Elon Musk so ins Grübeln gekommen zu sein.
Er sieht dann ja auch in Hasabis den Superschurken.
Genau, er sieht dann so diese Gefahr und sagt, ich investiere mal 5 Millionen in Deep Mind, nur um da Zugang zu haben, um zu wissen, was passiert. Und genau unter dieser Idee gründet er auch Open AI mit. Und das er nämlich ganz besorgt von dieser größten existenziellen Bedrohung, für die nicht mal eine Flucht auf den Mars eine Antwort ist, um da einfach dagegen zu halten. Und er sagt dann, der Klimawandel ist schlimm, aber er wird nicht alle Menschen töten. Die KI könnte die Menschheit auslöschen. So, das ist eine große Gefahr. Und zweitens, er möchte nicht, dass die KI von Larry Page, dem Google-Gründer, kontrolliert wird, sagt er ganz deutlich.
Das ist auch der Böse. Und Larry Page wirft Elon Musk vor. Musk würde Speziesismus betreiben. Denn Musk sagt ja, der Mensch steht im Mittelpunkt und wir müssen den Menschen schützen. Entweder auf dem Mars oder hier vor der KI, was auch immer. Und Larry Page ist der Ansicht, wir müssen eine Intelligenz entwickeln. Wenn die dann sich den Menschen unterordnet, dann ist das einfach so. Da können wir nichts machen. Das wäre Speziesismus, wenn man dort eine Hierarchie aufmacht und die Menschen an die Spitze setzt. Musk liest Nick Bostrom. Also ich finde, was hier auch nochmal so erstaunlich ist, du hast ja auch immer mal wieder betont, das Neue kommt in die Welt durch Bücher oder Technik. Und hier sehen wir wirklich diese Verbindung davon. Die lesen diese dort krasierenden Philosophen mit ihren Ansichten zu KI und Ethik. Also auch Peter Singer oder so spielt dann eine Rolle. Und daraus leiten sie dann ihre Prämissen ab, unter denen sie Unternehmen gründen. Und Bostum ist der, der in seinen Werken davor warnt, dass so etwas wie eine AGI sich entwickeln kann, die sich den Menschen untertanen macht. Und da ist dann dieses berühmte Beispiel, dass Bostum auch nur woanders sich wie ihn hat.
Genau, das ist nämlich ein ganz neuer Punkt, der wüsste ich vorher auch gar nicht.
Ich dachte auch immer, das sei seine Idee. Also er sagt, wie könnte AGI aussehen? AGI könnte so aussehen, dass da also eine KI zu Bewusstsein gelangt und auf die Idee kommt, sie halte es für vernünftig, die Welt in Büroklammern zu verwandeln. Und dann könnte das dazu führen, dass eben alles in Büroklammern verwandelt wird. Auch der Mensch, dass die KI einfach sich alles einverleibt. Das ist so dieses eine Beispiel, das Bostum aber woanders hergenommen hat und dann aber so für sich vor allem in Anstock bringt. Das ist etwas, was die alle lesen. Also auch Altman liest Bostum. Und das führt dazu, dass sie diese Philosophie plötzlich als die Wahrheit ansehen, der sie jetzt verpflichtet sind. Und auf dieser Wahrheit gründen sie dann ihre Unternehmen auf und sagen, wir müssen sehen, dass wir diese AGI als erstes entwickeln oder dass wir die AGI entwickeln, aber entsprechend containen können.
Nick Bostum ist vor allem für dieses Paperclip-Ding berühmt. Was ist, wenn man der Maschine sagt, mach mal jetzt eine totale Sinnlos-Aufgabe und dann übertreibt sie es komplett, weil sie ja keinen Kontext hat und so. Und diese Idee kommt von einem Typ namens Eliza Elise, wie auch immer, Judd Kowski, der mit Peter Thiel auch viel zu tun hatte. Und dann aber, also auch so eine Koryphäe, der wäre wahrscheinlich so mit Sam Ortman und er wird er sich gut verstanden, wenn er nicht vorher schon sich selbst verbrannt hätte auf diesem Gebiet. Denn er war am Ende der Meinung, man kann bloß nur noch zum Burning Man fahren gehen, sich jede Menge Drogen reinschmeißen und darauf warten, dass die KI kommt, die uns alle umbringt. Wir werden eh alle sterben und so weiter und so fort. Also es gibt im Silicon Valley mittlerweile auch so eine Generation von Leuten, die sich abgemeldet haben aus dem Szenario, und zwar weil sie es verstehen. Also die nicht wie Elias Hutz-Käfer, ein 17-Jähriger, ins Büro von Jeffrey Hinton gehen und sagen, Herr Professor, ich habe Ihr Paper nicht ganz verstanden. Und der Professor sagt, ja, das versteht niemand. Und er sagt, nee, ich meine ganz konkret, also warum haben Sie das nicht so und so gemacht? Und der Professor plötzlich sagt, ach so, ja, stimmt, sehr gute Idee, lass uns mal hier gemeinsam und so. Und dann machen die da einen großen Aufmarsch nach dem anderen bei diesen ganzen Wettbewerben, wo man hier ImageNet und so weiter höhere, bessere Technik vorstellt. Und dieses Paperclips-Szenario kommt von diesem Jutkowski. Also das, worauf sich alle beziehen, ist nicht von irgendwelchen Philosophen, die mal so, ah ja, wir wollen ja auch mal mitspielen, wir haben ja uns auch ein bisschen lustig gemacht über Bostrom und die Gang, sondern das sind eigentlich diese Ideen von diesen Technikern, die nicht genau wissen, was spricht dagegen, dass genau das passiert. Wenn man sowieso nicht weiß, was in so einem riesigen Datensender das einfach das ganze Wasser verbraucht und so weiter und am Ende, ja, was hat es denn jetzt eigentlich gemacht die ganze Zeit? So ja, man weiß es einfach gar nicht. Diese Blackbox-Idee. Und das fand ich schon einen sehr aufklärerischen Gedanken, denn der nimmt auch Nick Bostrom mal wieder ein bisschen aus dem Spiel, also so philosophische Einschläge, Gedanken, die sich alle Welt so macht zum Thema und sagt, nee, nee, das ist schon deren, also der Techniker-Seite des echte Gefahrensszenarios, dass die so sehen. Und Geoffrey Hinton macht ja auch diesen Spruch. Er bekommt also den Physik-Nobelpreis und sagt dann später, am stolzesten bin ich darauf, dass einer meiner Studenten Sam Altman gefeuert hat.
Ja.
Weil die sehen, wie das in die falsche Richtung läuft und so, auf vielen Ebenen.
Aber würdest du sagen, das ist ja das, was man sich die ganze Zeit fragt, dass das Problem an dem Unternehmen Sam Altman ist oder so etwas. Also wir sehen ja jetzt bei all diesen Figuren, die uns hier auftauchen, haben wir doch keine Figur, bei der wir sagen würden, da fühlen wir uns aber ganz wohl, wenn die die Macht hat. Also ich finde, finde ja, dass das einfach eine Herangehensweise ist, dieses Biografische. Das ist ja sehr limitiert darauf. Also ich kann jetzt darüber nachdenken, ob jetzt Altman der richtige Mann ist und dann werde ich das sehr schnell mit Nein beantworten können. Wenn ich aber diese ganzen anderen Figuren da sehe, was die so vorhaben, denken und planen und woran sie glauben vor allem, dann ist das ja auch nichts, woran man sich halten will. Oder ich will es mal anders ausdrücken, was ich erstaunlich finde, bei allen, die hier auftauchen in den beiden Büchern, haben wir ja nie jemanden, der nüchtern auf die Dinge blickt und sagt, ja, wir entwickeln solche LLMs und wir werden da noch sehr viel weiterkommen. Wir werden außerdem es schaffen, mit KI Krankheiten zu beseitigen, zumindest sehr viele, denn das ist ja so und so mit der DNA. Also, die einfach so eine diskriptive Art haben, das zu beschreiben, ohne, dass dann noch mal so eine metaphysische Komponente hinzukommt. Die alle sind ja davon schon überzeugt, dass eine übermächtige KI entstehen kann, die den Menschen überflügelt in der Weise, dass sie also das menschliche Denken übertrumpft und den Menschen sich untertan macht und und und. Also diese Idee haben die ja alle. Und das ist ja erstaunlich, dass man nicht Leute antrifft, die sagen, naja, das ist Quatsch, Singularitätsdenken und all das. Es geht ja jetzt einfach mal darum, ein gutes Programm zu machen, mit dem man dies und das machen kann. Also die sind ja alle von einer Religion beseelt. Und das macht das ja eigentlich so erschreckend.
Also ich sag mal so.
Also daran glauben wir ja nicht.
Ja, ich habe ja schon ein paar mal in diesem Podcast gesagt, dass ich vor allem Clot benutze.
Ja.
Und jetzt neuerdings auch sehr, von Anthropic ist das genau, von Anthropic. Und jetzt auch sehr viel Gemini von Google.
Und ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, wie Google bei einer Google IO. Technik-Präsentation so ein System vorstellte, wo es hieß, und das könnt ihr in der Schule verwenden. Da können die Schüler in einem Dialog, zum Beispiel mit historischen Figuren oder Planeten reden. Und dann hatten die auf der Bühne so ein, wie wäre es, wenn man mit dem Saturn redet und der Saturn dann so sagt, oh ja, hier meine Ringe oder was auch immer und so, ne? Und das war ja Technologie, bei der wir alle so dasteinfragten, was soll das, also ist das irgendwie, und dann so Diskussionen, brauchen wir diese Bildschirme oder diese Lautsprecher so im Klassenraum oder haben wir denn nicht Lehrer für? Was ja bedeutet, diese Technologie wurde die letzten Jahre entwickelt, und zwar anders, wie Sam Altman, die bei OpenAI entwickelt, der nämlich einfach sagte, wir schicken das erstmal auf die Menschheit los, hier habt ihr ein Chatbot, also 3.0, die Leute sind beeindruckt, 4.0, die Leute sind noch mehr beeindruckt, jetzt 5.0, und immer heißt es ja zuerst was ein Schüler, dann Student, jetzt ein Promovierender und so weiter und so fort. So, bei Entropic läuft das ja ganz anders, also die sagen ja zum Beispiel intern, wir machen ganz viel Forschung und haben dann auf der Webseite alle unsere Forschungsarbeiten, wir machen diese Forensik, auch wenn sich die Leute total lustig machen, weil wir so Studien geführt haben, wo es dann hieß, wir haben gesehen, wie sich die Maschine verhält, wenn sie in existenzielle Gefahr gerät, dann bedroht und besticht sie auf einmal ihren Nutzer. Und lauter solche Sachen. Also wo immer so eine menschliche Attitüde mit reinkommt, die wir dann als gefährlich labeln. Solche Forschungen, öffentlich gibt es bei Open AI nicht, sondern die machen das wie Facebook, da kommt dann so Jahre später mal, ach so, ihr habt es gewusst, was das mit den Ernährungsverhalten der jungen Mädels macht und so weiter und so fort. Und dann kommt irgendwie Jonathan Hyde und schreibt in dem Buch, ja ja, also immer wenn ein Selfie gelöscht wurde, haben wir denen noch mehr Marketing, was weiß ich, Make-up und so gegeben. Also man kann es böse machen und ich halte Open AI für so eine böse Firma. Nur bei Google würde ich eben sagen, dieses Transformer-Modell ist schon sehr alt. Dass sie dieses Paradigma, was ja lange gefehlt hat in der Kette, bei dem Schutzkäfer dann auch meinte, das ist dieses Feynman-Paradigma. Man weiß, wo man steht und wo man hin will und dann baut man alle Einzelteile hin. Und wenn noch eins fehlt, wartet man halt auf den göttlichen Funken und dann irgendwer schreibt ein Paper und er sagt ja dann, das Transformer-Paper von Google war zum Beispiel eins, das so eine technische Lücke gefüllt hat. So, Google hat diesen einen Lamoi oder wie er hieß, direkt gekündigt, als öffentlich wurde, er hätte mit einer KI, also mit der Google-eignen KI gesprochen und hätte ihr Bewusstsein unterstellt. Da haben die einen kurzen Prozess gemacht, da haben wir einfach rausgeschmissen. So, das läuft bei OpenAI alles ganz anders.
Da würde man wahrscheinlich sagen, ah wunderbar, du bist unser neuer Google.
Komm mal her, mach du mal bei uns und so. Also in deren Sicht, so sehr ich schon glaube, das ist alles unvermeidbar, ist der Weg dahin schon gestaltbar. Und OpenAI geht halt anders damit rum als Google oder Aber Google hat ja auch jemanden wie Ray Kurzweil beschäftigt.
Und Ray Kurzweil ist nun auch jemand, der glaubt, dass die Singularität kommt und weiß ich nicht.
Aber der hat ja da auch nur ein paar Vorträge und Armveranstaltungen gehalten. Das war ja nicht, diese University Singularity University.
Wir haben es ja damit Ingenieuren letztendlich zu tun. Und das finde ich aber interessant, dass die alle diese, fast alle, also es mag dann Ausnahmen geben, aber zumindest die Gestalten, die hier in den Büchern auftauchen, sind das fast alles Leute, die offenbar nicht das Profanen aushalten können, sondern sie brauchen so eine Sakralisierung und brauchen irgendeine Suche nach Gott. Und die wird dann gelöst über, ich glaube, da gibt es AGI, wir müssen diese Intelligenz entfalten, wir haben da die und die Mission. Also es geht ja auch eine Nummer drunter. Also ich kann ja auch sagen, ich finde es gut, wenn Menschen sich bewegen, dann lasse ich Autos bauen und dann hat man Individualverkehr. Aber damit muss ich ja nicht gleich irgendeine große Philosophie anberaubend. Das findet aber hier die ganze Zeit ja statt. Das ist ja auffällig.
Eben in einem Buch über Open AI. Also Google hat dieses Transformer Paper geschrieben, also die Grundlagenarbeit gemacht, zusammen mit dem Chef dahinten, den sie auch angestellt haben, aber er blieb ja gleichzeitig Professor da in Kanada, wo er war. Dann haben sie diesen TensorFlow-Chip hergestellt, der also ganz klar, es gibt eine GPU und eine CPU und das ist Computergeschichte. Und jetzt machen wir eine TPU für Künstliche Intelligenz. So, also Google hat ganz schön viele Sachen in diese Richtung gemacht. Nur sie haben niemals ein Chatbot losgejagt, bei dem heute alle sagen, ja, das nutzen die Leute vor allem für AI-Companion, weil sie keine Freunde mehr haben, machen da Therapie und der Gitzescheid. Also da hat Google immer aufgepasst, dass das nicht passiert. Und Entropic macht eben auch diese ganze Forensik, um überhaupt mal zu verstehen, was da passiert und veröffentlichen das auch und achten immer drauf, dass sie da präsent sind und dass nirgendwo eine KI-Konferenz ohne Entropic-Beteiligung stattfindet und so. Und dass sie da Kontakt halten. Und oben AI eben nicht. Also die sind, was das angeht, wirklich böse auf der einen Seite und haben halt die ganze Zeit so Ideologien im Gepäck. Also das ist ja auch schon, wie er da diesen Pädatilgedanken mitnimmt. Aber auch diese ganze Idee von Amerika braucht Wirtschaftswachstum und auch so ein Weg zur Happiness. Das kann ja nicht sein, dass die Menschen größtenteils immer ziemlich glücklich waren. Und jetzt sind sie es nicht mehr. Und jetzt verbindet plötzlich Sam Altman so eine Warum sind alle so unglücklich mit einer Ich hab doch hier eine Lösung.
Das sagt übrigens der Unabomber auch. Früher waren die glücklicher und warum sind sie jetzt nicht mehr glücklich? Und der hat dann eine andere Lösung.
Genau, der sagt wegen der Technik und Sam Altman sagt zu wenig Technik.
Ja, und das Erstaunliche ist ja auch, wie sie sich das immer wieder neu zurechtlegen. Und ich glaube, dass man muss diesen Nimbus jetzt auch mal brechen, wenn man darüber redet. Und das gelingt dem Buch ja auch wirklich gut, dass dann gesagt wird Klimawandel ist für uns ein großes Problem. Dann spricht sie mit Brockman von OpenAI und sagt ja, diese Datencenter, die sind ja unglaublich klimaschädlich und verbrauchen wahnsinnig viel Wasser. Wie ist denn das jetzt damit? Wie gehen wir da weiter? Und dann fängt er einfach an, statt jetzt zu beantworten, wie sie das lösen wollen, dass sie so eine Klimasünde betreiben. This is one thing that's really important. What is the purpose of technology? Why is it here? Why do we build it? We have been building technologies for thousands of years now, right? We do it because they serve people. Und dann fängt er da an und führt irgendwas aus, um natürlich nicht zu beantworten, dass was er eigentlich sagen müsste, wir wollen Wachstum, uns ist das scheißegal, ob wir jetzt irgendein Schwellenland damit überfordern, und die nichts mehr zu trinken haben. Wir machen einfach weiter.
Und die Antwort für den Klimawandel steckt ja in der Maschine. Ja, genau.
Und am Ende geht es darum, dass wenn die KI klug genug ist, also AGI ist, dann weiß sie ja viel mehr als wir, dann ist sie viel klüger und kann dann ja auch, weil wir sind ja doch am Ende sehr beschränkt, den Klimawandel schon lösen. Da werden ja die Probleme, die dann da sind, dann ist alles gelöst. Also wenn AGI da ist, müssen wir über Hunger, Klimawandel und so weiter nicht mehr reden.
Also dieser ganze effektive Altruismus, der dann zum Leben erweckt wird, um das zu rechtfertigen, hat ja diese religiöse, also im Christentum ist es ganz präsent, in den anderen sicherlich auch, dass man sich so peinigt, dass man die Erlösung im Jenseits nach, aber erstmal muss man durch das Yammertal, wir müssen die Welt jetzt einmal abfackeln, aber durch das Abfackeln haben wir plötzlich Technologie, durch die sie wieder aufbauen können, dass wir sie nie hätten abfackeln müssen, wird dann einfach ausgeblendet. Man muss jetzt einmal durch das Leiden durch.
Werden die natürlich immer größere Besitztümer anhäufen und lauter Exit-Strategien haben, Häuser in Neuseeland und sonst was, Hawaii, wo sie sich schützen können vor irgendwelchen Bedrohungen.
Das begegnet einem immer wieder, das ist ja bei Trump auch. Wir müssen jetzt einmal mit dieser, wie Höcker das auch sagte, Grausamkeit vorgehen, damit wir danach wieder die Empathie im Volk neu zünden können. Also man muss erstmal einmal gegen alle vorgehen.
Bedeutet auch, Presse ist nur dann erwünscht, wenn sie überaus positiv berichtet. Karen Howe schreibt, dass sie einen kritischen Artikel über OpenAI verfasst, nachdem sie da mit Brockman und so gesprochen hat. Danach spricht drei Jahre lang keiner mehr aus dem Führungsteam mit ihr.
Genau, also da hat sie offenbar den Horizont einfach nicht.
Sie bremst AGI mit ihren Artikeln. Darum können wir nicht mehr reden.
Ja, also hier habe ich mir, ich bin jetzt gerade auf Seite 17 von meinen Seiten, wo Masks Wunsch nach totaler Kontrolle, das ist ja auch wieder so ein, Masks will auch immer die ganze Welt retten damals, ne? Ja. Aber das geht natürlich nur, indem er es komplett dominiert. So, weil einfach die Welt für alle retten macht ja keinen Sinn. Die Leute müssen einmal richtig geführt werden. Jetzt habe ich hier gerade dieses Zitat wie Sutzkever und Altman ihm dann schreiben, du befürchtest, dass Demis mit Google eine AGI-Diktatur errichten könnte. Das tun wir auch, daher ist es keine gute Idee, eine Struktur zu schaffen, in der du zum Diktator werden könntest, wenn du dich dafür entscheidest. Also wir haben überall diese überweltlichen, jenseitigen Paradoxien drin, die dann immer wieder zu sehr viel Streit führen, auch intern.
Auch die Forschungsstreitigkeiten, denn am Ende zeigt sich immer wieder, und das ist ja auch gut, dass sie auf Forschung und sowas dann eingeht, naja, die Forschung ist sich nicht einig darüber, was eigentlich Intelligenz meint. Also die reden von Intelligenz, mal so, mal so, mal so. Und das sorgt natürlich auch permanent dafür, dass aneinander vorbei geredet wird.
Genau. Elon Musk, können wir ihm jetzt nachträglich unterstellen, sie macht das gar nicht so dick, sagt, naja klar, Intelligenz, was, whatever, so, ich brauche einen Autopiloten. Also er hat sozusagen einen konkreten Anwendungsfall. Wir wissen heute, dieser Autopilot ist immer noch Wunschtraum, zehn Jahre später. Bis heute ist es nicht in Erfüllung gegangen.
Also ich kann es nicht sein, dass wir so in ein paar Jahren wirklich ein ganz großes Erwachen erleben. Also wir hatten ja mal so eine Dotcom-Place und so und da hat man dann darüber gelacht, im Nachhinein, dass Leute, sobald eine Homepage gebaut war, schon dachten, ach, das ist schon das Unternehmen wunderbar, ich investiere oder so. Und dass wir jetzt ja Versprechungen haben, die überhaupt nicht eingehalten werden. Also wenn das ein normaler Konzern machen würde, also wenn VW oder Mercedes so handeln würde, dann wären die ja weg vom Fenster. Also da sind ja wesentlich kleinere Vergehen hart bestraft worden, wenn da die Unternehmen irgendwas gesagt haben, von wegen unser Auto ist klimafreundlich oder so und dann hat man herausgefunden, nee, da sind doch eigentlich die Rußpartikel und so weiter da. Da hat man wirklich mit drakonischen Maßnahmen zu Recht müllig hier hinzufügen, reagiert. Und hier haben wir Leute, die verkünden laufend das Blaue vom Himmel und nicht irgendwann, sondern die sagen ja nächstes Jahr. Und dann wird das aber nicht bestraft von den Aktionären beziehungsweise von den Investoren. Vieles ist ja dann Private Equity, sondern es geht immer weiter. Also das finde ich interessant, wie lange kann man das eigentlich treiben, dass man solche Versprechungen macht, die auch nicht annähernd eingelöst werden?
Also wir wissen ja, wie schon angemerkt, nicht darüber, welche Versprechen man sich intern so gibt. Also welche PowerPoint-Folien mit, hier werden ganze Belegschaften ausgetauscht und so weiter. Das wird die Rendite bringen. Aber es gibt zu deiner Frage ein sehr interessantes Zitate ganz am Ende im Buch von Hegge, wie heißt sie? Kitsch Hegge über Sam Altman, in der nämlich Sutzkever spricht. Und Sutzkever, wie wir jetzt gehört haben, ist ja derjenige, der sich am meisten über diese, was ist eigentlich Intelligenz, was ist das Versprechen, was ist am Ende der Nutzen von dem ganzen Kram. Und er sagt, die Tatsache, dass die auf neuronalen Netzwerken basierende KI unverständlich ist, stellt ein Schlüsselmerkmal für ihren Erfolg dar. Wir verwenden eine nicht nachvollziehbare Lösung für ein nicht nachvollziehbares Problem. Insoweit stimmt das. Wir können uns noch nicht in so eine Welt reindenken. Wir haben das schon ein paar Mal so im Film gehabt. Wall-E zum Beispiel. Oder auch in Anklängen so, also auf jeden Fall mit Hell 8000 oder wie er heißt. Hier, ich kann das nicht machen, Dave und so. Also bei Kubrick, genau. Aber auch ein bisschen bei Nolan in Interstellar. Da ist ja auch so ein Roboter dabei, der plötzlich so sicher verhält. Und emotional vorgeht. Wir Menschen sagen, wir sind intelligent. Und gleichzeitig wissen wir, wir sind underschaubar. Wir haben vielleicht so eine Approximationshoffnung, wenn die Diagnose stimmt, dass wir eine passende Therapie finden. Aber so richtig passgenau. Deswegen muss ja auch der Diagnose-Katalog immer wieder geupdatet werden. Neue Forschungen, was für neue Krankheiten gibt es denn so und so weiter. Also wir schaffen es gerade so mit Therapien, so ein bisschen das Alignment über Wasser zu halten. Dass wir nicht alle komplett durchdrehen. So. Und wir können uns noch nicht ganz vorstellen, dass das künftig für Maschinen auch gilt. Unsere Welt ist aber jetzt so aufgebaut, dass wir Maschinen nur da benutzen, wo sie uns einen konkreten, echten Mehrwert bringt. Und wir haben das auch sozial so codiert, dass wir sagen Profit. Es muss profitrechtlich sein. Also wenn die Lösung für ein Problem nicht effektiver ist, Nutzen bringt Geld spart, dann verwenden wir sie einfach nicht. Denn überall, wo wir es so ein bisschen Larifari machen, nennen wir das eigentlich Privatleben. Und dann schlagen wir uns so mit Freundschaften rum, die zu nichts führen müssen, außer nur schöne Momente. Ob die Momente wirklich schön waren, wird erst mal nachgefragt. Kommt aus dem Urlaub zurück. Wie war es? Es ist eben nicht selbstverständlich, dass es im Urlaub schön war, nur weil es so war. Aber keiner würde jetzt bei einer Maschine, die seit zehn Jahren Autos herstellt, fragen, ja, und hat sie heute auch wieder Profit gebracht? Nee, es ist der Sinn, dass sie das macht. Wir haben also auf der einen Seite eine Technologie, die jetzt plötzlich Lösungen bereit bietet, wo wir nicht dran gewöhnt sind, dass die Maschine vielleicht gar keine Lösung bietet. Sondern wir versuchen AI gerade nutzbar zu machen, für Problemfelder, in denen wir ansonsten auf ganz spezifische Software zurückgreifen oder sonstiges. Jetzt versuchen wir das so in einem allgemeinen Dunstkreis des Promptens irgendwie zu machen.
Nur zum Verständnis, du willst nicht sagen, dass die KI unterschaubar ist wie der Mensch?
Die KI ist genauso unterschaubar wie der Mensch. Man sieht nämlich am Anfang einfach, dass man sieht noch oder sagen die ja auch, wie die Buchstaben des Promptes in Zahlen übersetzt werden. Dann rüttelt das aber durch 100 Ebenen durch und am Ende werden wieder Zahlen, die sichtbar sind, in Buchstaben übersetzt und das ist dann die Antwort.
Aber das klingt jetzt so ein bisschen nach Magie.
Es ist ja auch Magie. Es ist keine Trivialmaschine.
Nein, es ist eine Trivialmaschine.
Es ist eben keine Trivialmaschine. Das ist ja der Punkt. Deswegen ja diese ganze Forensik. Du hast diese riesigen Modelle, die irgendwas machen und du kannst es nicht vorhersagen, was das Ergebnis sein wird.
Gut, weil das liegt aber an der Komplexität. Bei den Menschen gibt es ja die Sache des Bewusstseins.
Das liegt immer an der Komplexität.
Nein, aber bei Menschen gibt es ja das Unberechenbare. Hier gibt es ja die Berechenbarkeit, die noch nicht so ausgereift ist. Deswegen muss man diese Forensik betreiben. Aber sonst denkst du ja eigentlich so, wie Sam Altman auch. Also der würde ja auch sagen, genau, dann möglicherweise sind wir irgendwann an dem Schritt, wo die KI irgendwas macht, was dann gegen uns gerichtet ist. Da wissen wir gar nicht mehr, wie uns das geschieht.
Also der Gegenentwurf zur Komplexität. Komplex heißt ja nicht, es ist kompliziert oder so.
Nein.
Also kompliziert ist was eigenes. Der Gegenentwurf von Komplex ist Komplett. Komplett ist alles, was eindeutig nachvollziehbar ist. Also vor allem diese ganze alte Physik, Gravitation hier, da, wie auch immer und so. Eins plus eins ist immer zwei. Nur, wenn du ein neuronales Netz wie im Gehirn hast, das zudem noch über 10.000, und zwar feinfühlige, noch mal mit Abstufung, also wo nicht ein Neuron verbindet sich mit einem Neuron, sondern es hat sowieso schon mal 10.000 Verbindungen und die können noch unterschiedlich stark angesprochen und gewichtet werden. Also der Energieimpuls.
Ich glaube, ich weiß, worauf du hinaus willst und ich kann das auch nachvollziehen, was du da sagst, aber wir diskutieren glaube ich jetzt auch gerade über eine Glaubensfrage.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich gehe glaube ich davon aus, ich gehe davon aus, dass der Mensch ein Bewusstsein hat und dass dieses sich fundamental von dem unterscheidet, was irgendwelche Computer herstellen können. Und du siehst eigentlich das menschliche Gehirn ähnlich einem Computer.
Also ich will...
Und damit würde ich sagen, bist du näher an dem Silicon Valley Denken dran, als ich es zum Beispiel bin.
Genau. Also ich verschaffe jetzt noch mal, so wie ich das hier verstehe, soziologische Aufklärung in einem spezifischen Fall, der uns nämlich besonders interessiert, nämlich wie sieht die Kommunikation mit der Maschine aus. Also Komplexität ist keine exklusive Eigenschaft des Gehirns.
Nein.
Sondern wir werden es ja nachher hören durch diese neuen Studien von BrainGate. Wie funktioniert das eigentlich überhaupt, zur Kommunikation zu kommen? Also wie sieht diese Vorstufe der Kognition dazu aus? So und kann man sie sehen und nachvollziehen? Das heißt, eine Kognition, davon gehst du ja auch aus, ist auf jeden Fall komplex. Also es hängt von sehr vielen Einflussfaktoren ab, wie man so denkt. Und man könnte jetzt nicht sagen, ah ja, ein Mensch ist berechenbar im Sinne von, wenn ich ihm diesen Impuls gebe, kommt am Ende fünf Minuten später das als Ertrag raus. Sondern man muss halt immer so nachsteuern und mal gucken, wie es so läuft. Und Blackbox-mäßig sind die Wege verschlungen. Am Ende kommt halt ein Ergebnis raus. So, das betrifft schon Kommunikation unter drei Leuten, bei denen du gar keine Probleme hättest, das zu transkribieren. Was wurde denn da gesagt? Also drei Leute, die also drei Dialoge miteinander führen, die sich als ein Gesamtgespräch ergeben, über fünf Minuten sind vielleicht zwei Seiten DIN A4. Völlig überschaubar und als Geschichte komplett nachvollziehbar. Aber niemand käme auf den Gedanken zu sagen, ich habe jetzt zwei Seiten, ich mache es wie Ulrich Oebermann, objektivärmeneutig, ich prognostiziere mal die nächsten zwei Seiten Gespräch, wie dies weitergeht. Das ist ja das, was die gerade versuchen, indem sie so Lückentext-Training machen, wenn die Maschine einen Zustand eingenommen hat, indem sie möglichst nah an der Antwort ist, die wir schon kennen, aber die Maschine nicht, sagen wir, stopp, behalte mal diesen Zustand bei, und jetzt schieben wir einen anderen Input rein, und dann kommt wieder ein Output rein, bei dem wir sagen, okay, der ist jetzt genauso aligned oder wie auch immer wie vorher. So, in diesem Zustand sind Maschinen jetzt, dass sie uns doppelt kontingent, wie in der Kommunikation, mit Antworten überraschen, auf die wir dann wieder reagieren, ohne dass die Maschine weiß, wie wir reagieren, oder wir wissen, wie die Maschine reagiert.
Ich hatte ja damals das Buch von Elena Esposito vorgestellt, der hier genau darauf abgezählt hat, bei der Beschreibung dieser LLMs. Da haben wir auch gar keinen Distance.
Damit unterscheidet sich so eine Blackbox KI total von allen anderen maschinellen Input-Output-Systemen. Selbst riesige Fabriken, Bayerwerke, oder so eine riesige Mühle, wo jeden Tag 10.000 Tonnen Getreide durchgejagt wird. Wir wissen genau, was da passiert. Und wenn es eine Abweichung gibt, sehen wir das sofort. Und wir wissen auch genau, Fehler kann jetzt gefunden werden.
Das ist in der Hinsicht keine triviale Maschine. Ich meinte, es ist eher bezogen auf das, was wir menschliche Intelligenz bezeichnen und was maschinelle Intelligenz sein kann.
Also nicht um Gleichstellung, noch um Vergleiche.
Genau, aber die menschliche Intelligenz, aber das tun die ja die ganze Zeit. Also die setzen das ja gleich. Die sagen ja eigentlich, das Gehirn ist wie ein Computer. Wir müssen herausfinden, wie das Gehirn genau tickt. Dann können wir das der Maschine geben und die wird es noch übertrumpfen, weil die viel mehr Rechenleistung hat, bessere GPUs und so weiter. Das setzt dann voraus, dass überhaupt so eine Herrschaft über den Menschen sein kann. Wenn ich aber sage, nein, der Mensch ist tatsächlich ein sehr besonderes Wesen und der Spezialismus wird zurecht betrieben. Der muss nicht zur Unterwerfung von Tieren und Tierleid und all dem führen. Aber es gibt diese exzentrische Position, aus der der Mensch tritt, aus sich heraustreten kann, sich selbst beobachten kann, selbst reflektiv ist, sich im übrigen ja auch im drastischen Falle das Leben selbst nehmen kann, dass das alles die Bereiche sind, bei denen die KI nicht mitkommt, notwendigerweise nicht, weil es da einen fundamentalen Unterschied gibt. Und das meinte ich, als ich eben sagte, doch, das ist eine triviale Maschine, dass die Kommunikation, beobachtet man sie jetzt so, die zwischen Maschinen oder von einer Maschine stattfindet, oder die zwischen drei Menschen, tatsächlich diese doppelte Kontingenz hat und wir nicht prognostizieren können, was da als nächstes ist. Oder man die Forensik dann im Nachhinein betreibt. Okay, das mag das sein. Aber ich glaube, dass diese Glaubensfrage an sich wichtig ist, weil damit schon eine Unberechenbarkeit im Menschen an sich reinkommt, schon bevor er kommuniziert oder so.
Also ich verstehe, und das ist ja nicht zum ersten Mal jetzt hier im Podcast, dass du auch den Menschen etwas verteidigen möchtest gegen die Maschine. So im Sinne von, nein, der ist speziell, der ist anders, der ist usw. Ja, ich würde das hier, ich habe es zumindest so gelesen, mal ausblenden. Denn ja, es gibt dieses große Projekt Google Brain, also wo sie genau diese Idee verfolgen und sagen, wenn wir es nur groß genug machen, entsprechend also die Anzahl der Neuronen und die Anzahl der Verbindungen zwischen den Neuronen, also da kommen wir auch in 1000 Jahren wahrscheinlich selbst bei diesen Skalierungen jetzt nicht hin, das mal ausgeklammert. Was die ja einfach nur sehen, ist, die Menschen glauben ihnen, wenn sie behaupten, sie hätten jetzt eine neue Form von Intelligenz. Ob die dann noch mit menschlicher vergleichbar ist oder nicht, da würde ich sagen, das kann man ja komplett ausblenden, denn der Taschenrechner wurde vor 50 Jahren erfunden und es war völlig klar, der rechnet sehr viel schneller als ein Mensch und keiner kommt auf den Gedanken zu sagen, ne ich glaube Taschenrechner ist nicht die richtige Richtung, weil ich glaube nur an menschliche Intelligenz. Weil eben jeder sieht, dass Taschenrechner funktioniert.
Das wäre verrückt, aber wenn ich die AGI-Premisse nehme und die haben ja da die Leute, dann geht es ja schon darum, dass man ein eigenständiges Wesen hat, das intelligent ist und das nicht nur jetzt der Assistent von jemanden ist, wie der Taschenrechner mein Assistent ist, weil ich im Kopf nicht so schnell bin. Aber hier bei AGI geht es ja um was anderes. Und da kommen wir schon in die Bereiche des Bewusstseins. Und davon gehen die offenbar aus. Und deswegen sage ich auch, und darum geht es schon Karen Hau auch, auch wenn sie jetzt nicht in der philosophischen Anthropologie das nochmal herleitet, geht es ja schon darum zu sagen, das ist deren Religion. Und zu so einer Religion ist ja auch, also bei einer Religion ist man ja auch sehr nahe dann an dem Kolonialismus dran. Also ich glaube, das ist auch nochmal so entscheidend. Also der Kolonialismus bedeutete ja zunächst einmal, zum Beispiel geht man in die neue Welt nach Amerika und dann müssen die zu Christen werden oder sie werden getötet oder so. Jetzt muss niemand direkt an das Ganze glauben, aber trotzdem müssen sie sich dem unterwerfen. Ich lasse mich zwei Sachen sagen zu dem, also diese eine Idee, die du hattest, vielleicht können wir darüber sprechen, mit dem die wollen eigentlich, und das ist das große Versprechen, die KI als Arbeitskraftersatz einsetzen. Das ist ja diese Idee, die sie haben. Und dann legt Altman noch den Worldcoin auf, sagt, damit werden am Ende alle das BGE ausgezahlt bekommen, etc. Ich will nur eine Anmerkung machen, bevor du das dann näher ausführen kannst und was das eigentlich bedeutet. Und mal mit Blick auf Demografie und all das. Arbeit ist natürlich etwas, was von Maschinen und Menschen verrichtet werden kann. Aber Wert schaffen kann nur die menschliche Arbeitskraft. Das ist ja das, was Marx uns gezeigt hat. Bedeutet also, ich kann natürlich jetzt eine Maschine haben, die irgendetwas produziert und die produziert und produziert. Und das ist möglicherweise auch was Nützliches. Die Frage ist nur, entsteht dadurch Wert. Und wenn ich also nicht die Arbeitskraft habe, die bezahlt wird, diese Arbeit zu verrichten und der Kapitalist nicht sich den Mehrwert einstreicht, von dem der da etwas erwirtschaftet hat, dann bin ich in dem Bereich, wo ich eigentlich durch so eine Maschine an so ein Ende des Kapitalismus eigentlich angelange.
Genau.
Und das ist ja so eine Idee, die Marx dann so ein bisschen diesem Maschinenfragment überlegt, wie das dann gehen kann. Was aber jetzt hier gedacht wird, ist ja eigentlich, man möchte den Kapitalismus aufrechterhalten, der aber dann so aussieht, dass die Menschen nicht mehr arbeiten und die Maschinen die Arbeit verrichten. Und dann zahlt man den Menschen noch irgendein Grundeinkommen aus, mit dem sie dann konsumieren können. Das kann volkswirtschaftlich natürlich nicht funktionieren. Man könnte sagen, dann gehen wir wirklich über zu einem Sozialismus und dann ist gut, dass nur noch weniger Arbeiten verrichtet werden muss und der Rest wird über KI und Robotik und so übernommen. Aber es ist nicht möglich zu sagen, dass es dann noch Kapitalismus ist, weil kein Mehrwert mehr entsteht und damit auch nicht mehr investiert wird und und und. Also das ist eigentlich, was sie da versuchen, ist die Quadratur des Kreises, nämlich den Kapitalismus aufrecht zu halten, zu Bedingungen, die gar nicht mehr kapitalistisch sein können. Zumal ich ja überhaupt nicht glaube, dass es in diese Richtung im Großen und Ganzen geht. Also du gehst doch nicht davon aus, dass jetzt in Amerika, sagen wir, 50 Millionen Arbeitsplätze geschluckt werden durch KI.
Also sagen wir mal so, wenn durch Zufall in den nächsten zehn Jahren eine Verheiratung gelingt, zwischen einem Roboter und einer KI, und der Roboter hat aber, und das ist ja das Letzte, was noch fehlte, so eine Grifffähigkeit. Das war ja die große Wunsch von Jeff Bezos, dass er in seiner Lagerhalle endlich das Licht ausmachen kann, wenn die Picker weg sind. Und die Picker stehen eben in so einem Käfig, um sie herum tonnenschwere Lasten, die die ganze Zeit hin und her gefahren werden, die dann noch den letzten Handgriff aus der Kiste in die Versandpackung machen, weil die Maschine nicht so ziegenau greifen konnte. Wir haben durch Robotik jetzt Produktivitätssprünge erlebt, bei denen man sagen muss, also das Auto hat für die Leute, die damit ihre Großeltern besuchen, auf jeden Fall einen Wert, den sie auch finanziell vergelten. Also sie gehen in den Laden und kaufen sich das Auto und sie würden es gar nicht mitbringen, wenn einfach gar kein Mensch mehr daran beteiligt ist, das Auto herzustellen oder ein Mobilitätsservice anzubieten. Also ein ICE fährt mit 30.000 PS und da sitzt einer vorne drin und steuert den und die Gleise sind so geradeaus, selbst wenn der jetzt für eine Stunde den Kontakt verlöre zu seinem Headquarter, wo der ICE gesteuert wird, wo nochmal 100 Leute da sitzen und den Zug begleiten sozusagen virtuell, könnte der trotzdem einfach fahren. Also sollte es auch ein marktwirtschaftliches Bestreben geben, zu sagen, dann lass doch den ICE mit dem einen Fahrer fahren und der Fahrer ist eigentlich nur noch zum Sicherheitsgefühl da, damit die Leute wissen, ah ja, zur Not gäbe es einen Ansprechpartner. So ungefähr. Also ich glaube schon, dass man noch sehr viele Menschen aus dem ökonomischen Prozess rausnehmen könnte, aus dem produktiven Prozess und man hätte trotzdem die gleiche Produktvielfalt, bei der Menschen sagen, das ist mir etwas wert. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage bei Marx, will man immer nur an diesem Wertgedanken rumhängen oder kommt man noch mal auf diesen Entfremdungsgedanken, der ja da auch drinsteckt. Man ist ja nicht nur von seiner Arbeit entfremdet, sondern auch von der Welt, wenn man marktwirtschaftlich arbeitet. Als kleines Rad im Getriebe, das in so einer Manufaktur das große Bild gar nicht mehr sieht, sondern nur noch dem einen Handgriff da ausgeliefert ist. Das macht man dann 45 Jahre und danach kriegt man Rente und so. Und die Ideen, die hier drinstecken in diesem Gedanken, vor allem bei Sam Oertman, die gehen ja über so was, sag ich jetzt mal, Profanes sehr weit hinaus. Also in dem Sam Oertman Buch redet sie ja über diesen...
Also du bist jetzt bei Kitsch, hey...
Genau, über diesen Brahman, diese Idee aus dem Hinduismus. Und Brahman steht ja so fast für alles. Das ist so die oberste Kaste, gleichzeitig der Gründungsgott. Und so ein Begriff für das Gesamtgefüge der Welt, was man sonst nur bei Avatar mit dem Baum oder so, ja. Alle sind miteinander verknetzt und so weiter. Und dann sagt Sam Oertman, ich bin durchaus bereit zu glauben, dass das Bewusstsein irgendwie das grundlegende Substrat ist und wir alle nur in einem Traum oder in einer Simulation oder wo auch immer existieren. Also im Podcast mit Lex Friedman, ich hab's mir auch noch mal angehört, nur so ein ganz kurzes Snippet, aber genauso, wie es im Buch steht. Ich finde es interessant, wie sehr sich die Silicon Valley-Religion, also er spricht selber von der Silicon Valley-Religion, der Simulation, also die Religion der Simulation, die im Silicon Valley so furorellend ist, dem Brahman angenähert hat und wie ähnlich sie sich sind. So, also man braucht jetzt glaube ich nicht den Hinduismus dafür, sondern die versuchen sich einfach nur so eine Reformulierung da zu finden. Aber eine Welt, in der Menschen, und jetzt mal ganz profan gedacht, wieder mehr Zeit haben für andere Menschen, weil sie nicht nur ihre Zeit nicht mit Arbeit verschwenden, sondern auch noch alles dafür haben, um sich einander näher zu bringen, also Mobilität, Grundversorgung und so weiter und so fort, wäre ja durchaus denkbar mit sehr viel effektiveren Maschinen. Genau.
Da muss man ja gar nicht zu Marx gehen, sondern das kriegt man ja von Keynes schon beantwortet.
Genau. Und die große Frage ist ja bisher immer gewesen, wenn wir mal eine Zeit hatten, in der 90 Prozent der Leute auf dem Feld arbeiten mussten, also gar nichts anderes möglich war, und wir es dann geschafft haben, meine berühmte Getreidemühle mit 10.000 Tonnen, die einfach nur noch von drei Ingenieuren im Schichtbetrieb betrieben wird, also dass dieser primäre Wirtschaftsproduktivsbereich, wir versorgen uns mit Nahrung, in Deutschland mit 1,6 Prozent der Bevölkerung auskommt oder der Beschäftigten so, und wir darüber trotzdem noch 60 Prozent exportieren. Warum haben wir dann die freien 98 Prozent für so viel Blödsinn bis hin zu Labubu verschwendet, statt jetzt einfach mal zu sagen, komm, wir nutzen jetzt mal die Freiheit, die sich bietet, und bringen uns als Menschen wieder zusammen?
Fast wie Harald Wälzer, also du hast in gewisser Weise völlig recht. Nur die Antwort darauf ist ja klar, dass wenn ich eine Wirtschaft habe, die auf Wachstum ausgelegt ist, und das ist nicht denkbar, dass der Kapitalismus nicht wächst, muss ich ja sehen, wo gibt es also neue Felder, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Und das kann dann zum Beispiel Labubu sein. Das ist aber auch eine Ausdifferenzierung in der Produktpalette, bei der man staunen muss. Ich war, weil ich ein neues Bett bekomme, in einem Bettenhaus, bin dort zwei Stunden eingeführt worden, in alle Dinge, die ich wissen wollte und aber zum Teil auch nicht wissen wollte über Betten. Es war hochinteressant, dann zu sehen, was alles möglich ist. Lattenrost, wie das heute ist, was da wie zu empfehlen ist und und und und und. Unglaublich viele Premiumprodukte, sehr viele Produkte, die sich nur ganz wenige leisten können, dann aber auch für eine breitere Masse sehr sehr angenehme Konstruktionen. Ja, das sind alles unglaublich große Innovationen für den Schlaf. Die werden auch personalintensiv mitunter sein. Es wird nicht alles völlig automatisiert und so sein. Da wird auch eine Automatisierung schon weit vorangeschritten sein, aber nicht so weit, dass da nur noch einer aufpasst, dass das Bett am Ende rauskommt. Ja und damit ist die Antwort ja schon gegeben. Also wir sind natürlich in einem Bereich da, wo wir uns weiterentwickelt haben, weil wir sagen, es reicht uns nicht, dass abends Brot auf dem Tisch ist und wir noch einen Krogwein dazustellen können, sondern wir haben eine unglaubliche Produktvielfalt, mit der wir zum Beispiel auch hier einen Podcast aufnehmen. Und das bedeutet einfach, dass wir, glaube ich, davon Abstand nehmen müssen, zu sagen, die KI kommt und dann werden diese ganzen Arbeitsplätze verschwinden, weil ja, es werden natürliche Arbeitsplätze dadurch verschwinden. Wie wir jetzt auch nicht einen Aufnahmeleiter hier brauchen, um den Podcast aufzunehmen, das kann man gerade selbst. Du guckst hin und wieder mal auf den Laptop, ob noch alles läuft und damit ist die Aufnahmeleitung erledigt. Und dann schneidest du das noch innerhalb von einer Stunde. Also den Cut haben wir auch nicht mehr. Aber es kommen natürlich ganz viele andere Bereiche, in denen die Arbeit wieder gefragt wird, die menschliche Arbeit. Ich sehe einfach, die bewegen sich ja da in einem Rahmen, wo sie nur Programmierung und alles sehen. Und dass es da eine Disruption gibt, auf jeden Fall. Aber in ganz vielen Bereichen, man muss dann nur mal durch die Straße gehen, gucken, wo wird gerade gehämmert, gekloppt und sonst was. Und da sieht man, ach ja, das wird jetzt nicht der Roboter sein und das wird auch nicht der sein, der bald greifen kann.
Genau. Und das müssen wir jetzt mal einpreisen in die Ideologie, die wir hier vor uns haben. Denn du hast jetzt eine historische Erfahrung aus, sagen wir mal, 150 Jahren Menschheitsgeschichte, also der jüngsten Menschheitsgeschichte. Wir sind alle Teil davon, bei dem wir sagen, nee, das mit der Wert und der Arbeit hat nicht nur mit Ausbeutung zu tun. Also im Sinne von, da kommt ein Mensch und bringt Wert rein und dann kommt ein Ausbeuter und zieht den auf seine Seite, sondern ein bisschen von diesem Wert bleibt immer bei dem Menschen, der arbeitet drin so und er braucht das halt irgendwie so. So und Sam Altman hat ja nicht nur diese Komische-Brahm-Idee, die ja da für sich als passgenau zur Silicon-Valley-Ideologie der Simulation, also dass es alles so eine Sinnhaftigkeit und so eine Richtung hat, in die es geht, sondern er sagt ja noch gleichzeitig, wir hatten ja in Amerika immer, also jetzt 200 Jahre lang, beispielloses Wirtschaftswachstum, von dem ich ja sage, das hat vor allem mit Bevölkerungswachstum zu tun und er teilt das in die Zeiten ein, okay wir hatten zuerst 100 Jahre territoriale Expansion und danach 100 Jahre neue Technologien und alle würden glaube ich jetzt sagen, also ich fühle mich nicht gerade wie am Ende eines Weges, vor allem nicht der Glückseligkeit, sondern okay wir brauchen eine neue Wachstumsstrategie nach Expansion und Technologie, was kommt denn als nächstes? Jetzt kommen die und sagen, ja wir haben jetzt den Brahmen, also den Weltgeist irgendwie für euch gepflückt. Das ist jetzt die neue Idee. Wir sind jetzt expandiert, wir haben Technologie erfunden und jetzt haben wir die neue Intelligenz, die uns da irgendwie weiterführt. Und da würde ich jetzt mit deinen Anmerkungen eigentlich gerne mal am Silicon Valley zurückfragen. Wie genau stellt ihr euch denn jetzt die Zukunft vor, wenn die Produktivität jetzt wirklich komplett von Maschinen gelöst wird als Problem? Was passiert denn dann mit dem Braham, mit dem Weltgeist und so weiter? Was macht denn die höchste Kaste als Nächstes? Welche Idee gibt sie denn vor? Welches Vorbild bildet sie denn aus, dem man nacheifert und so weiter? Und darauf haben die ja einfach gar keine Antwort. Also die denken ja wirklich nur in diesen BWL-Produktivität, wir verkaufen denen das und dann stellt Nike jetzt die Schuhe neu her, anders. Dann brauchen die ihre Belegschaften nicht mehr. Dann kommen immer alle schon hier mit diesen, die ersten Firmen, die jetzt sagen, ne, wir bei Airbnb machen jetzt alle Kundenabwicklung nur noch über KI, wir brauchen gar keine Belegschaft mehr und so weiter und fort. Was passiert als nächstes mit dieser Menschheit, von der es hieß, naja, bevor die gar nichts mehr machen, die lieber Suizidalen Expanditionismus so. Und eigentlich sind die ja die Anführer davon, ja?
Ich meine, der Mensch ist ihnen ja egal. Wenn wir nochmal zu Karen Howe zurückgehen, zu ihrem Buch, vielleicht, dass wir diese These, die ihr das Buch durchzieht, nochmal stark machen und fragen, ob sie wirklich gut ist. Ich finde sie nicht schlecht zumindest. Sie sagt, ich spreche hier von Kolonialismus. Dann bezieht sie sich nochmal auf Shoshana Zuboff, lange nicht zitiert, Überwachungskapitalismus. Das war dieser Begriff, mit dem Shoshana Zuboff beschrieben hat, wie Google arbeitet. Nämlich, bei Google gibt man nicht einfach nur eine Suche ein, ein Wort oder irgendwas, was man wissen will, sondern da ist ein Verhaltensüberschuss dabei. Bedeutet, zu welcher Zeit sucht man das? Gibt zum Beispiel Ausschluss darüber, dass man offenbar auch die Fernsehsendung, Wer wird Millionär gesehen hat, in der die Frage gestellt wurde, deswegen gibt man sie jetzt gerade da ein. Google kann daraus aus diesem Überschuss, der da drinsteckt, in der Info, ich wollte auch nur wissen, wer die Schauspielerin war, viel Schluss folgern und dann entsprechend Werbung an mich ausspielen. Das war das, was Shoshana Zuboff im Prinzip beschrieben hat, mit Verhaltensüberschuss und wie dann so ein Überwachungskapitalismus daraus entsteht, weil man natürlich am möglichst viel Verhaltensüberschuss kommen will. Jetzt haben wir eine ganz andere Dimension, nämlich davon, dass wir alles überwacht und ausgelesen und gecrawlt und gescraped haben, was die Menschen produziert haben oder gerade aktuell produzieren. Man möchte gerne Echtzeitdaten aufnehmen, würde gerne auch Streaming komplett abgreifen. Sie geht ein auf diese App, die es damals gab, diese Challenge, die es gab, Manneken-Challenge. Manche werden sich vielleicht erinnern, vor ein paar Jahren, das war so, man blieb stehen, zum Beispiel alleine oder vielleicht ein Fußballteam oder so, bewegte sich nicht und dann fuhr die Kamera so um einen herum und zeigte dann, wie also alle wie so Puppen dastehen. Da schreibt dann Karen Howe, das war ideales Trainingsmaterial für die AI, weil man sich dann, für die KI, weil man sich dann mal genau ansehen müssen, wie stehen Menschen, wie sehen sie aus, wenn sie den Arm strecken und so. Das war alles ideales Material. Dann führt sie den Begriff Extraktivismus ein und damit ist ja eigentlich gemeint, dass man herrenlose Natur hat, natürliche Ressourcen und und und und die werden jetzt einverleibt genutzt vermarktet. Jetzt sind die ja gar nicht mehr herrenlos die Sachen, sondern da sind zum Beispiel Urheberrechtsverletzungen oder so, die begangen werden. Und dann sagt sie, dieser Kolonialismus sieht aber auch dann ganz konkret so aus, dass man die KI optimieren muss, dass sie zum Beispiel Gesichter erkennt. Wo geht man da hin? Naja zum Beispiel da, wo es ganz viel Gesichtserkennung schon gibt und wo man vor allem auch daran interessiert ist, als Staat Kriminalität oder so zu bekämpfen. Man geht nach Johannesburg, also nach Südafrika und versucht dort, da haben sich dann alle angesiedelt, was an westlichen Konzernen so da war, die Gesichtserkennung zu optimieren. Denn es gab ja zu Recht diesen Vorwurf, dass nicht weiße Gesichter so schwer erkannt werden von der KI. Dann schreibt sie, nicht lange danach, im Jahr 2021, fand ich die selbe Dynamik der AI-Educations-Data in Südafrika spielen. Faschistische Bekennungen von Unternehmen aus all over der Welt, die sich um einen Fußdruck in das Land um wertvolle Faschistische Daten zu sammeln, haben sich nach der Verwaltung der Industrie mit einem großen Kritikum über ihre Produktfehler aufgeteilt, um die schmalen, schmalen Individuen zu entdecken. Das heißt, man hat also da den konkreten Kolonialismus. Man sagt, wir breiten uns aus, machen Gesichtserkennung, die staatliche Unterfinanzierung, die nutzen wir aus, indem wir jetzt da ein bisschen Geld hinbringen und machen uns dann damit die Welt zu untertanen. Ich glaube, dass man damit zunächst einmal sehr weit kommt mit diesen Beschreibungen, die da durchgehend an den Tag gelegt werden. Es geht ja dann noch intensiver um einzelne Klickarbeiter und deren Biografien. Nur kommen wir ja an so einen Punkt, bei dem wir sagen müssen, was ist denn jetzt die antikolonialistische Aktion? Das Buch schließt ja damit, dass sie sagt, es gibt aber jetzt so Communities, die sich zusammenschließen, um Daten gemeinnützig zu verwenden, um basisdemokratisch abzustimmen darüber, wie Daten verwendet werden sollen. Und das sind ja alles Projekte, die sie oder vor allem eins beschreibt sie ja dann da, bei denen man sagen muss, das sind ja interessante Ideen und und und. Nur ist da ja wirklich dieser Versuch, der unternommen wird, das Richtige im Falschen zu schaffen. Also man möchte eigentlich jetzt so mit so einzelnen Leuchtturmprojekten zeigen, es geht auch anders. Ich leugne ja an keiner Stelle, dass es auch anders geht. Nur würde ich sagen, in dem Gefüge aus so mächtigen Staaten und so viel Kapitalinteressen, und du hast eben die Summen genannt, die da mobilisiert werden, ist das ja geradezu lachhaft, jetzt darüber nachzudenken, ob man das auch in kleinen Communities organisieren kann. Es gibt ja außer in diesen kleinen Communities keinerlei Interesse daran, dass das passiert. Sondern wir sind ja, also müssten ja, wenn, dann zu nah. Und das ist, glaube ich, das, was dem Buch dann fehlt, schreibt von Desasterkapitalismus und erzählt, wie in Venezuela alles ausgebeutet wird und ist man da fertig, sagt man, warum jetzt nicht mal nach Nairobi oder so. Also man ist ja wahllos da unterwegs und sammelt alles ein, was man braucht an seltenen Erden wie an Daten. Aber eigentlich müsste man jetzt zu so einer grundsätzlichen Kapitalismuskritik kommen. Aber was sie, glaube ich, zu sehr ignoriert ist, einfach dieses Konkurrenzverhältnis der Staaten untereinander. Denn die sind ja klug drauf da im Silicon Valley. Egal, wo sie sind, ständig zu sagen, China ist so eine große Gefahr. Wir können aber hier gut mal zusammenarbeiten, damit wir diese Gefahr eindämmen. Und das ist ja eigentlich das, was wir dann bei Alex Karp in Technological Republic ganz klar auf den Punkt gebracht bekommen haben.
Ja, also ja, die Kritik teile ich auch. Also ich denke auch, wir haben hier von der HO in zwei Punkten sehr gute Aufklärung bekommen. Eigentlich hätten es drei sein müssen. Das eine ist Landnahme, Ressourcenverschwendung, Wasser und so weiter. Da erklärt sie ja sehr gut auf. Das zweite ist Ausbeutung dieser Belegschaften, die da einfach in Kenia die Daten aufbreiten sollen für Sama und Scale, diese Firmen, die man gar nicht so kennt, aber die auch milliardenschwer sind, weil sie einfach den Datenbestand geben. Und das dritte, was sie auch ein bisschen kurz macht, finde ich, ist diese gigantische Urheberrechtsausbeutung, die jetzt einfach stattfand, die bei ihr auch ein bisschen zu kurz kommt. Und hier würde ich sagen, ist die Kritik, wie du sie formuliert hast, genau richtig. Denn wir kommen ja daran nicht raus. Also dieses Geld ist jetzt mobilisiert. Und mithilfe des amerikanischen Militärs werden die Unternehmen noch einiges machen, damit da ihre Vormachtstellung gewahrt wird. Und China wird trotzdem da mithalten, natürlich, weil die haben ja genauso diese Ressourcen.
Und schau doch an, auch in Deutschland, ich meine, wir haben gerade Baden-Württemberg, Grün regiert, die jetzt mit Palantir zusammenarbeiten. Also diese ganzen Dinge, da könnten wir jetzt hundert Sachen aufführen, die in diese Richtung gehen. Deswegen, also ich kann ja verstehen, dass man sagt, wir müssen jetzt nochmal einen Lösungsvorschlag machen oder so. Ich glaube, dass man geht dann wieder so ins Klein-Klein. Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen diese falsche, oder vielleicht auch bei Zug auf schon angelegte Rezeption gewesen, wie schütze ich jetzt noch mal meine Daten oder so etwas. Und dass wir dann in einem ganz anderen Bereich sind. Und wenn dann Carole Hau am Ende sagt, wir müssen Wissen jenseits der Konzerne organisieren, Ressourcen redistribuieren und auf Bildung setzen, dann würde ich sagen, ja, das ist ja gut gemeint. Nur sind wir jetzt gerade an einem Punkt, wo diese große Macht da ist, was ja nicht in Fatalismus führen soll. Aber das bedeutet ja eigentlich, dass man nur darüber reden kann, wie will man eigentlich jetzt staatliche Institutionen aufgerüstet haben. Weil will man das eigentlich, also diese alte Kritik, sie hat ja manchmal noch so, sie kritisiert ja mehrmals so den Neoliberalismus und bezieht sich da auf Naomi Klein. Ich halte das ja für nicht mehr so tragfähig, wenn man jetzt sieht, wie sehr ja Staate und Konzerne zusammenarbeiten. Das ist ja ein anderes Konzept, als das, was der Neoliberalismus ursprünglich mal war.
Ja, ich will mal eine etwas verwegende, aber ambitioniertere Lösung vorschlagen.
Bin gespannt.
Denn der Sutzkäfer hat sich jetzt irgendwie zurückgeschlossen und will das so ein bisschen anders machen. Und Sutzkäfer kam von Google zu OpenAI, mit hinten im Gepäck und so weiter und so. Ich glaube nämlich auch, und das ist ja auch eine der großen Erfahrungen, die die Welt jetzt gemacht hat. Also GPT-5 war einfach, wie soll man sagen, also kein Erfolg. OpenAI hat zu viel versprochen und im Grunde sehen die Leute nicht wirklich, was jetzt der Unterschied ist von O3 und O5. Und OpenAI hat ja auch schon diese Erfahrung jetzt gemacht. Die Leute wünschen sich 4O zurück und das ist wirklich ein sehr viel dümmeres Modell nach allen Gesichtspunkten, weil der Ton der Ansprache in der Kommunikation so gut war.
Ja, mehr Empathie.
Genau, also diese ganze Idee von die Maschine muss ganz viel Wissen und ganz viel Intelligenz liefern, ist es wahrscheinlich gar nicht, sondern es ist wie beim Telefon. Wir haben uns in Hamburg schon drüber lustig gemacht. Das Telefon wurde erfunden mit, und jetzt können alle Informationen miteinander und so weiter. Und 99 Prozent ist einfach nur gelabert, das auch gar nicht hätte stattfinden können. Also es ist einfach nur...
Hallo und du so?
Genau, ich bims. So, und das haben wir ja jetzt hier wieder. Also Leute sitzen heute schon vor GPT-5 und denken so, ah ja, das ist jetzt irgendwie ein Promovierender auf allen Themen-Ebenen, aber ich habe gar keine Frage. So wie man vor 30 Jahren oder 20 vor der Google-Zugleiste, das könnte ich dann mal googeln, so ungefähr. Also eigentlich ist das Leben schon ziemlich erfüllt.
Und wir wissen ja, was in Google am meisten gesucht wird.
Und zu dieser Intelligenz, die uns jetzt schon irgendwie so ein bisschen, naja gut, wir haben uns dran gewöhnt und so, führte der Weg über diese riesige Ausbeutermaschinerie und so weiter. Nur, und das jetzt wieder zurück zum Gehirn, zu diesem Vergleich. Wenn ein Kind geboren wird, dann wissen wir, okay, es gibt diesen Joke mit der Ressourcenverschwendung, jedes Kind verbraucht so und so viel CO2. Aber um ein Kind zu trainieren, im Leben klarzukommen und mit 20 dann erfolgreich in den Arbeitsmarkt einzusteigen und die Eltern ein bisschen zu entlasten, mit eigenem Gehalt, muss man jetzt nicht in Afrika, Kenia ausbeuten oder so. Sondern es scheint ja doch irgendwie ein anderes Prinzip der Intelligenz zu geben, dem man sich ja auch mal nähern könnte. Nur, das hat vielleicht ein bisschen weniger mit Datenmasse zu tun, als mit Computergröße. Und wenn jetzt Nvidia demnächst diese neuen Computerdings vorstellt oder wir sogar Quantencomputer bekommen, also die Hau klärt ja darüber auf. Es gibt ja diesen Gary Marcus als großen KI-Kritiker, der auch so einen eigenen Blog da schreibt und der immer wieder drauf hinweist, nee, vielleicht haben die sich so ein bisschen vertan. Die haben einfach nur ein großes Produktivitätsversprechen, das sie wahrscheinlich am Ende nicht einlösen können, aber vielleicht braucht es ein neues Paratikmann. Und da hinten hat er ja darauf hingewiesen, also das menschliche Gehirn hat etwa 100 Billionen Parameter oder Synapsen, sagt er 2020. Und das ist im Vergleich zu GPT-3 mit 175 Milliarden Synapsen oder Neuron Faktor 1000 Unterschied. Ich würde ja dann sagen, ja, und nach dem, was ich bei Arte in den Dokus gesehen habe, kommt es nicht nur auf zwei Neuronen an, sondern noch die 10.000 verschiedenen Arten, wie sie miteinander in energetischen Kontakt treten können. Also müssen wir nochmal Faktor 10.000 drauflegen. Wir sind also, wenn wir das jetzt über Scaling Wars Inhalte müssen bereitgestellt werden, geht gar nicht. So und sie weisen ja beide in den Büchern darauf hin. Tesla ist jetzt mit dem Autopiloten einmal durch die ganze Welt gefahren und es reicht trotzdem noch nicht, um die nächste Kreuzung vorherzusehen.
Ich habe hier ja mal einen Artikel vorgestellt, der nicht böse kritisiert wurde, der in der FAZ erschien und genau das sagte.
Genau. Und vielleicht kriegt man es ja hin, eine Maschine erst mal miteinander so zu verschachteln, aber sie nicht die ganze Zeit mit Inhalten zu belästigen, sondern erst mal nur das Prinzip aufzubauen und dann Schritt für Schritt im kleinen Maßstab da Sozialisation wie für einen Menschen zu machen und mal gucken, wohin das so führt. Der Sutzkäfer hat ja damals schon, und wir kommen nachher auf diesen Text zu sprechen aus der New York Times, dass die Region des Gehirns, die dafür zuständig ist, dass wir sprechen, also überhaupt soziale Menschen sind und es gibt ja sehr viele Ideen. Wir haben sie ja thematisiert in vielen Büchern, dass eigentlich die Intelligenz der Menschheit in der Kommunikation steckt, weil der Neanderthaler war ja kognitiv uns überlegen, aber irgendwie hat er es nicht geschafft. So. Und wenn man jetzt ein Sprachzentrum hat, das nur so klein ist wie eine Erdbeere, also nicht das ganze Gehirn, muss man ja gar nicht so auf ach das ganze Gehirn und so, sondern man guckt sich mal die Einzelteile an. Und Sutzkepper, das weiß ich noch, als wir vor zwei Jahren übers Alignment gesprochen haben, war ihm ja ganz wichtig zu sagen, wichtig ist nicht das Modell, und wir sind immer noch voll in diesem, das Modell ist so riesig und so, sondern wie man die Modelle miteinander in Kommunikation bringt. Also so spezialistische Modells. Die haben das jetzt bei OpenAI so ein bisschen, dass sie sagen, naja, ihr stellt eine Frage und wir wählen dann für euch das Modell aus, und dann hat das den Leuten schon wieder nicht gepasst und so. Aber ich glaube, so in diese Richtung würde es wahrscheinlich eine KI-Entwicklung geben, die jetzt sehr viel von diesem Kolonialismus, aber es muss halt technisch funktionieren, ansonsten bleiben wir diesem Ausbeuterdingen, genau.
Ich will zwei Anmerkungen machen, einmal nochmal auf einen Denkfehler hinweisen bei Karen Howe, dass sie ein bisschen sehr noch, wie man früher über Internetkonzerne schrieb, diese Geschichte erzählt, die machen gute Lobbyarbeit und deshalb sind die so einflussreich. Die machen gute Lobbyarbeit und sind auch deshalb einflussreich. Und das beschreibt ja dann auch Keatsch Hagge nochmal, wie Sam Altman durch die Welt tourt und mit jedem Führer einer Nation mal eine Stunde plaudert. Jedoch muss man, glaube ich, schon in Bezug auf die USA, und darauf bezieht sich ja Karen Howe vor allem erkennen, dass es nicht so ist, dass Open AI seine Positionen den der jeweiligen Regierung aufquatscht, sondern dass Open AI hier eigentlich der Regierung hilft, beziehungsweise mit der Position des Staates schon reingeht. Und dann gibt es eine Zusammenarbeit. Und das muss man, glaube ich, jetzt sehr fundamental erkennen. Wir sind jetzt hier nicht in dem Bereich, irgendein Handyspiel, irgendeine Porno-Seite oder so, wo ein bisschen lobbyiert wird, damit auch schon 16-Jährige da rein können. Das ist das nicht. Sondern hier wird schon auch Regierungsinteresse direkt vertreten. Diese Verbindung gibt es ja, auch weil man sich auf ein Manhattan-Projekt so sehr bezieht. Naja, das ist ja ein staatliches Projekt gewesen. Das ist die eine Anmerkung. Die andere Anmerkung, die ich machen will, ist, ja, Sam Altman ist eine gefährliche Gestalt. Und das merkt man ja auch an seinen Äußerungen selbst, wenn er 2018 sagt, ja, das Buch, das ihn am meisten beeindruckt hat, ist The Mind of Napoleon. Und er sich mit Napoleon offenbar sehr stark identifizieren kann und das faszinierend findet, welches Talent er hatte, große Massen zu mobilisieren und in die eine oder andere Richtung zu delegieren. Das sollte einen aufhorchen lassen und in ihm nicht den ja bedächtigen Mann sehen, der auch um Sicherheit und Regulation bedacht ist. Aber ich habe mich dann schon gefragt, wenn diese Psyche von Sam Altman mir in ellenlangen Kapiteln beschrieben wird, wie die Verhandlungen ablaufen, ob er jetzt wieder Chef werden kann oder wen er als nächstes rausbockt und und und und und sehr sehr kleinteilig. Haben wir hier nicht auch so ein bisschen ein Robin Alexander Buch aus dem Silicon Valley?
Ja, ja, so ein bisschen schon.
Ja, also Robin Alexander erzählt mal und dann hat Christian Lindner da ein Glas Wein getrunken und dann hat Ricarda Lang was per WhatsApp geschrieben und hinten hat der und der das gesagt. Ich frage mich so ein bisschen, ist das so eine neue, ist das unsere neue Beschäftigung, unsere neue Freizeit Beschäftigung geworden, die ganze Zeit in so mächtige Köpfe reinzukriechen und diese Intrigen so alle soap-oppermäßig zu entschlüsseln?
Also zur...
Da muss man schon mal einen Schritt bitte zurück machen und sagen, ich gehe mal ins Allgemeine und spreche darüber. Ich glaube, das hat viel mehr als das Buch könnte halb so lang sein und doppelt so gut.
Sagen wir mal so. Ja, das stimmt. Also ich finde diese Länge nicht verkehrt, denn hier muss man auch immer so ein bisschen an die Historiker denken. Irgendwer muss es mal aufgeschrieben haben.
Okay.
Und in diesem Wirr war ein Information.
Aber ich soll es lesen.
Und die KI fragen in zehn Jahren, wie das damals war. Nee, jetzt haben wir hier so ein Buch als Datengrundlage. Allerdings, wir hatten ja bei Robin Alexander die Kritik, dass er März in den Kopf schaut und immer dann fasziniert ist, wenn März ganz erschrocken war und dann irgendwie drauf reagierte, wenn ihm dargeboten wurde, welche großen Gefahren jetzt in Aschaffenburg wieder sichtbar wurden durch die Migration. Und dann muss man ja irgendwie politisch handeln. Und dann wird eben komplett übertrieben. Hier haben wir es ja so, die Geschichte, also die Geschichte der KI in Silicon Valley ist ja wie folgt. KI ist sehr ressourcenabhängig. Der Staat versteht das aber nicht. Darunter leiden die Chinesen, weshalb die das nie hinbekommen hätten. Und in Amerika, Gott sei Dank, haben die Konzerne die Staaten abgelöst in der Bedeutung, in der Mobilisierung von Geld. So, also gibt es Google. Google kauft DeepMind. Elon Musk ist besorgt, dass Larry Page die Teufelsgestalt in der Welt wird, die plötzlich das Schicksal alle in der Hand hat, weil er die KI kontrolliert. Also gründet Elon Musk OpenAI. Wird aber von Sutzkever rausgekegelt, weil könnte ja sein, das wäre ganz gefährlich, wenn der Musk die OpenAI-Intelligenz in der Hand hätte. Daraufhin wird Sam Altman Chef. Und Amo Dai sagt, oh, das wäre aber ganz gefährlich, wenn der Sam Altman jetzt... So, ich gründ das mal selber, ja?
Ja.
Und so zieht sich das eigentlich durch die Bank durch, dass dann Amo Dai noch sagt, die Gefahr muss sehr ernst genommen werden. Also ein Altmans Verhalten, das geht gar nicht. Sein Verhalten kann das Schicksal der Menschheit gefährden. Das ist der Gründungsmythos von Ed Schoppick. Und so zieht sich das die ganze Zeit durch. Da will mal einer nicht, dass der andere so ein Tenet, ich habe den Drücker in meiner Hand, von mir geht die Welt unter und so.
Vermutlich, weil jeder sich selbst von denen gut kennt und ahnt, dass der andere auch so schlimm drauf ist, wie man selbst.
Genau. Also wir können hier durchaus in ein Rotkar Brechmann Phänomen reinstopfen, dass wir nicht nur fragen, warum sind die politischen Spitzenkräfte immer so irre, sondern was hat es mit diesen Sam Oughtmans auf dieser Welt. Ökonomisch scheint es ja dasselbe Phänomen zu sein. Denn wir normalo Leute, wir wollen die Welt nicht zerstören. Diesen Antrieb haben wir einfach nicht. Aber wir haben jetzt auch nicht den Antrieb, ein zweites menschliches Gehirn zu basteln. Aber das scheint so Hand in Hand zu gehen. Also wenn man einmal drauf aus ist, jetzt eine Billion Euro einzusammeln, um die größten Computer der Welt zu bauen, wie Elon Musk und so weiter, dann hat man wahrscheinlich auch immer so einen fatalen Trieb mit in sich.
Jaja, also wir haben ja jetzt über Kern und Hau mehr geredet als über die Biografie. Wollen wir darüber noch ein bisschen reden? Also ich würde sagen, das ist ein bisschen viel für eine Person, die noch nicht so lange unterwegs ist, beziehungsweise ich muss von Sam Altman nicht so genau wissen, was die Großeltern, Eltern und Geschwister und sonst was gemacht haben und wo er zur Schule gegangen ist, dass er da schon aufgefallen ist. Ich kann also diese 150 Seiten, die da zunächst einmal vorgeschaltet sind, fast ignorieren, würde ich sagen. Und ja, es gibt diesen Skandal da um seine Schwester und die Vorwürfe seiner Schwester. Wer will, kann das nochmal näher nachlesen. Aber ich glaube jetzt für unsere Debatte um KI ist es nicht so relevant. Es zeigt nochmal, dass Sam Altman ein eigenartiger Charakter ist, um es mal vorsichtig zu formulieren. Jedenfalls erfahren wir aber dann immer so ganz interessante Dinge in dieser Biografie darüber, wie Sam Altman so tickt. Also er hatte erst mal so die Idee, dass er 2016 verkündet, ich brauche nur noch ein Vierzimmerhaus. Ich ziehe mich da drauf zurück, brauche gar nicht so viel Luxus. Dann merkt er aber, als er immer bedeutender wird, ach so Privatsphäre ist gut. Und dann kauft er ein 27 Millionen Dollar teures Anwesen mit Infinity Pool. Weiter hat er dann noch ein Wochenendhaus in Big Sur. Das kostet 15,7 Millionen, 380 Hektar Land. Also man will richtig Platz haben. Er datete weiterhin jüngere Männer, die seine Leidenschaft für Wissenschaft und Technologie teilten. In 2019 ging er eine Beziehung mit Nick Donahue ein, dem damals 21-jährigen Mitgründer von Atmos, einem Startup, das für seine Kunden individuelle Häuser zu einem erschwinglichen Preis entwickeln will. Sie lernten sich kennen, als Altman in das Startup investierte. Dann heißt es laut Donahue, rang Altman in ihrer gemeinsamen Zeit mit ähnlichen Fragen, etwa, wie Spiritualität und KI aussehen, wie sich das alles entwickelt und verändert. Immer wieder wird gefragt, was der Kosmos ihnen eigentlich sagt. Also es gibt immer diese religiöse Komponente da drin, auch in den Beziehungen, die man dann pflegt. Altman hat früh verstanden, dass er sich so als Partner der Regierung verstehen muss. Er weiß auch, dass er auffallen muss. Also er macht das dann auf eigentlich eine sehr simple Art und Weise. Bei den ersten Präsentationen, die er so hat, zieht er zwei unterschiedlich farbige Polohemden übereinander an, damit alle danach sagen, wer war eigentlich dieser Typ mit diesen zwei Polohemden? Was war das bei einer? Das erfahren wir dann hier. Wir erfahren auch von Altmans erfolgreichste Investition. Das will ich kurz vorlesen, weil die Zahlen so unglaublich sind. Und zwar gibt es da eine Investition, eine Programmierschnittstelle, die es Websites erlaubt, mit nur neun Zeilen Code Kreditkarten zu akzeptieren. Also ein kleines Unternehmen, die 15.000 Dollar die Altman in Stripe steckte. Da sind wir jetzt bei dem großen Player. Da brachten ihm zwei Prozent eines Unternehmens ein, das heute 70 Milliarden Dollar wert ist. Es ist eines der wertvollsten Startups in den Vereinigten Staaten und die erfolgreichste Investition in Altmans Karriere. Da er die Investition als Sequoia Scout tätigte, durfte er etwa die Hälfte des Gewinns für sich behalten. Das sind also die Summen, die hier im Raum stehen. Also früh, völlig unabhängig. Interessiert sich dann auch für Free Oceana, wie übrigens auch, das war mir auch nicht klar, Julian Assange, der dann auch da auftaucht und weitere. Also dort diese Idee, man müsste doch mal irgendwo so eine freie Insel haben, auf dem Meer, wo man machen kann, was man will. Also diese Gründung, das findet er faszinierend. Altmann ist ein absoluter Verfechter von Wirtschaftswachstum. Er hält Wirtschaftswachstum für notwendig für die Demokratie. Sie kann nur dann funktionieren, wenn Wirtschaftswachstum da ist, weil Wählerinnen und Wähler dann tatsächlich mehr bekommen werden und nicht irgendwann in so einem Nullsummenspiel ist. Das nur noch die Dinge anders verteilt werden. Ich glaube sogar, hier ist ein Punkt, wo ich ihm zustimmen würde. Also es ist zumindest in kapitalistischen Verhältnissen anders, sehr schwer denkbar, da eine Demokratie aufrechtzuerhalten. Und er wird dann auch sehr bald, wir haben das schon erwähnt, zum Prepper und sagt das auch ganz offen in Interviews. Also das ist jetzt nicht so, dass das herausgefunden werden musste. Ich habe Waffen, Gold, Jotapletten, Antibiotika, Batterien, Wasser, Gasmasken von den israelischen Verteidigungskräften und ein großes Stück Land in Bixur, wo ich hinfliegen kann, sagt er dem New Yorker. Wir sehen hier einen jungen Mann, der sich zum einen philosophisch beeinflussen ist, der aber auch ein Programmiertalent offenbar hat, aber wir erfahren nie so richtig, wie viel er eigentlich selbst programmiert, weil immer wieder auch bei Karen Howe zu lesen ist und hier bei Kichai Giao, dass er mehr der Visionär ist und andere, aber diejenigen, die was umsetzen. Also das bleibt immer so unklar. Was macht eigentlich der Unternehmer? Jedenfalls ist er davon überzeugt, dass das, was er tut, das absolut Wichtigste ist. Und es ist neben der Philosophie dann auch noch die Fiktion, die ihn fasziniert. Neben Science-Fiction-Geschichten ist es aber auch eine Fernsehserie. Ich lese das kurz vor. Im Herbst 2016, drei Tage vor der offiziellen Premiere der HBO-Serie Westworld, in der Anthroiden, die einen Western-Freizeitpark bevölkern, ein Bewusstsein entwickeln und sich gegen ihre menschlichen Herren auflehnen, zeigten Altman und der langjährige YC-Investor Yuri Milner die mit Spannung erwartete Serie in einer privaten Vorführung in Milners Villa in Los Altos Hills. Anschließend stellten sich die Mitschöpfer der Serie, Jonathan Nolan und die Hauptdarstellerinnen Eve Rachel Wood und Thun Dive Newton den Fragen aus dem Publikum ebenso wie später Altman und der MIT-Professor Ed Boyden. Laut dem Journalisten Kate Metz erzählten Boyden bei dieser Gelegenheit Wissenschaftlerstunden kurz davor, eine vollständige Karte des menschlichen Gehirns zu erstellen und es anschließend zu simulieren. Wie die Einladung deutlich machten, war der Sinn dieses Abends, mit Unterstützung von etwas Promi-Power aufzuzeigen, dass die Grenzen zwischen Wissenschaft und Science-Fiction immer mehr verschwammen.
Also das sind auch die beiden Punkte, die mir am wichtigsten sind, eigentlich als Lehre aus diesem Buch, vor allem den zweiten Sam Altman. Also ich finde, da steht zwar Sam Altman drüber, aber da lernt man doch ganz schön viel über andere Leute noch, die jetzt peripher zu Altman, also Altman ist ja jetzt nicht der Interessanteste, denn ich denke mir irgendwie, Altman hat man auch schnell durchschaut. Also diese Idee ist ja hier er selbst, also Altman bezeichnet laut dem Buch die Scaling-Gesetze, die in einer Studie 2019 von Amodai formuliert werden, der heute für Entropic Chef ist. Zur wichtigsten Entdeckung des 21. Jahrhunderts. Also es ist nicht die Neuronen müssen miteinander irgendwas machen, sondern die Größe. Sollte also ausschlaggebend sein. Es ist das eine zu wissen, dass ein Modell mit zunehmender Größe besser wird, sagt Altman, aber es ist etwas ganz anderes, kalkulieren zu können, wie sich das Modell durch die Skalierung verbessert. Das war eine wirklich große Sache. Da würde ich jetzt sagen, ja, aber genau so hat Jonathan Nolan, der Autor von Westworld, eben auch einfach gesagt, ich habe da so einen Hirn gespinst, ich male das mal auf im künstlerischen, ja, wir folgen einem Drehbuch und visualisieren uns das mal. Aber ich wüsste nie, wie man das selber macht. Und ich glaube, der Sam Ortman hat auch gar keine Ahnung davon, wie man das macht. Der ist da sehr abhängig, dass der Brockman da ist und dass vorher alle anderen Sutzkever da waren und so. Und er ist dann mehr der Typ, der diese Essen organisiert, dass dann das Kapital zur Intelligenz findet und die dann irgendwas machen. Und es hat ihm, glaube ich, sehr viel Arbeit gemacht und ihn wahrscheinlich auch nicht sehr glücklich, diese Position des Blenders immer wieder zu verstecken und da auf Augenhöhe zu bleiben. Denn eine, und da gibt es Wegbegleiter, die dann so über ihn reden, das wird dann hier zitiert, er tritt immer so auf, als wüsste er alles, dem ist aber nicht so. Sein Wissensstand liegt manchmal vielleicht nur auf dem Level 3. Aber so wie er redet und klingt, denkt man, er wäre auf Level 10.
Ja.
Und genau das kann man ausspielen, wenn man in der Politik und so weiter, da einfach diese Abendveranstaltungen, dieses Fundraising läuft genau so.
Wir haben es ja bei Christian Lindner hier sehr deutlich im Podcast schon behandelt. Die Rhetorik funktioniert.
Diese Leute können Vortrag halten, aber die halten kein Kolloquiumstand.
Nein.
So. Und das halte ich für ein echtes Problem, denn es ist nicht so, dass ich jetzt sage, Sam Altman ist ein Blender oder so, sondern der Typ wurde durchschaut von den Leuten, die es verstehen. Eher so, Skever hat ihn durchschaut. Und der hinten sagt nicht ohne Grund, am stolzesten bin ich, dass einer meiner Studenten Sam Altman gefeuert hat und so. Also Sam Altman wurde eigentlich durchschaut, aber die alten marktwirtschaftlichen Prinzipien, Ownership, CEO, Verantwortung, was auch immer, jemand kennt jemanden, man kann deswegen gut fundraisen, die halten ihn am Leben. Und gleichzeitig will er diese Welt aber abräumen. Also wir sind hier.
Und die Politik, also das wird hier auch nochmal deutlich, wie er die Politiker umgarnet. Es gibt diese Kongressanhörung, er sitzt dort und dann wird er gefragt, aber sie werden da richtig reich mit. Und er sagt dann, nee, ich hab da überhaupt gar nicht investiert in Open AI. Ja, aber warum machen sie das, dann brauchen sie vielleicht einen Anwalt oder so. Nein, nein, ich mache das einfach aus Purpose, das ist für ihn wichtig. Naja, und die Politiker sind dann fasziniert von einer solchen Gestalt, wissen aber nicht, dass der in 400 Unternehmen investiert ist und natürlich damit zusammenhängt, ob der jetzt nochmal direkt, dass da von denen bekommt das Geld. Er sagt dann sogar noch, er bekommt so viel Geld von Open AI, dass er damit seine Krankenversicherung zahlen kann. Wir haben es da einfach mit einem Milliardär zu tun. Es ist schon absurd, dass das Politiker bereit sind zu glauben.
Genau, sein Privatbesitz wird jetzt geschätzt auf irgendwie so zwei oder drei Milliarden und er investiert hunderte Millionen in zum einen Kernfusion, weil er hofft, dass da einfach die Energie herkommt und so andere wie Gehirne einfrieren. Ja, noch mit der Aber mit dem Feature, genau, man muss das Gehirn aus dem lebenden Betrieb einfrieren. Man kann nicht warten, bis man alt und krank ist, sondern man müsste jetzt sein Gehirn einfrieren. Also solche Ideen.
Ja, das ist ja das Problem an deren Religion. Die anderen Religionen, die wir schon haben, die sagen ja, ist nicht so schlimm, wenn hier was nicht richtig funktioniert, im Jenseits aber. Das ist ja hier nicht gegeben, sondern die wollen ja quasi das Jenseits.
Die vertrauen ja doch nicht so drauf.
Ja, die möchten ja die AGI soll ja hier, soll ja das göttliche sich enthalten. Und da sage ich ja nicht, ich warte mal, bis ich auf der anderen Seite bin. Und das ist natürlich nur herzustellen oder länger daran zu glauben, indem man das Leben verlängert, was die ja all diese merkwürdigen Praktiken dadurch führen.
Als jemand, der damals, 2000 irgendwann, Mark Zuckerberg eine E-Mail schrieb, um ihn zu fragen, warum er sich hier von StudiVZ und so den Rang ablaufen lässt. Also ich wollte schon zu Facebook, als noch niemand Facebook kannte. Und als es dann da war, habe ich gesagt, ne, Finger weg und so.
Du hast wirklich Mark Zuckerberg eine E-Mail geschrieben? Hat er geantwortet?
Nein.
Schade, das wäre jetzt die Geschichte.
Ich unterstelle mir jetzt also einen kleinen, prophetischen Gedanken, abgeleitet aus meinem eigenen Verhalten.
Ja.
Ich war auch mal Kunde von 200 Euro.
Stell dir vor, wo du heute sein könntest.
Ja, genau. Es fehlt nur die ordentliche Infrastruktur hier, weil das hier nicht Silicon Valley ist. Weil ich aus Thüringen komme.
Wärst du da hingegangen und hättest du das mal...
Hätte ich jetzt mein Gehirn entgegen, ja.
Ja.
Ich will dir jedenfalls Folgendes sagen. Auch, das kann man ja in fünf Jahren, ich sag's jetzt für die KI, die das Transkript macht, also in fünf Jahren bitte, also 2031, mal so hier nachschauen. Ich habe ja auch mal für GBT 200 Euro im Monat bezahlt und hab einen echten Nutzen darin gesehen. Und ich habe mit GBT 5 jetzt einiges ausprobiert. Zum Beispiel wollte ich mal gucken, meine Trainingsgestaltung, Abseits von Claude, könnte ich die jetzt damit machen. Ich habe andere Sachen ausprobiert. Die Antwort war immer nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. So, ich bin also kurz davor, GBT ganz zu kündigen. Ich lasse es nur noch, weil dieses kleine Feature, dass man mit GBT reden kann und der relativ zügig antwortet. Und in diesen leichten, einfachen Modellen, die eben schnell Antworten, Wissensfragen beantwortet werden, die relativ nützlich sind, wie zum Beispiel 200 Milliliter Milch, wie viele Eier brauche ich jetzt und so für Pfannkuchen. Also die offensichtlichsten Antworten, die ich auch googeln könnte, kriege ich noch mal schneller dargeboten. Und ich weiß, damit zerstöre ich den Planeten, weil das jagt immer die Rechenzentren hoch. Aber das ist das einzige Feature, für das ich GBT gerade noch buche und da denke ich mir so 20 Euro, okay. Aber ich sehe ehrlich gesagt in dieser sehr pluralen Welt der KI's mittlerweile nicht mehr wirklich einen Sinn für Open AI. Also in wirklich tiefgehenden Recherchen muss man zu Gemini gehen, weil die haben einfach den Google-Index und das Transkriptarchiv von YouTube und so weiter. Das findet mit mir, also das hat GBT einfach nicht. Und für die Sachen, wo es ein bisschen auf Grafiknesser der Argumentation angeht, ist Claude einfach das Maß der Dinge, so wenn man keinen klugen Gesprächspartner zuhand hat. Und von daher würde ich sagen, ich gebe GBT jetzt noch drei Jahre und nur weil sie auf allen Handys so präsent sind und so in dieses AI-Companion-Ding abgewandert sind, also so eine richtige Consumer-Elektronik machen, funktioniert das, glaube ich. Aber die wirklich große Idee des, lieber Arbeitgeber, bevor du hier bei monster.de noch Nachwuchskräfte suchst, überleg doch bei uns für 3000 Euro im Monat eine KI zu buchen, dieser Markt wird für Open AI, glaube ich, unerreichbar sein, weil es einfach aus prinzipiellen Gründen, also die Technologie gibt es einfach nicht her, glaube ich. Wir sind ein anderes Unternehmen.
Wir werden sehen, ob wir hier vielleicht schon ein bisschen das Ende von Sam Altman einläuten oder nicht. Und da er wieder mit ganz neuen Verbindungen Ja, mal sehen, ich bin jetzt auch ein bisschen gespannt. Es ist jedenfalls viel Kapital im Rücken, dass er also alles noch machen kann, was ihm so vorschwebt. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass er auch vielleicht nur an Open AI gebunden ist, vielleicht gibt es noch ganz andere Wege. Wir bleiben an der Sache dran und gehen nun über zu unseren Empfehlungen. Ich will einen Roman empfehlen, nachdrücklich. Es ist ein Roman von Dorothee Elmiger. Das ist eine Autorin, geboren in der Schweiz, lebt inzwischen in New York. Der Roman heißt Die Holländerinnen, erzählt von zwei Holländerinnen, die im lateinamerikanischen Urwald unterwegs sind und dort verschwinden. Der Roman erzählt dann aber nicht von dem Verschwinden dieser beiden, sondern davon, dass ein Theatermacher ein Theaterprojekt darüber realisieren will. Dazu eingeladen wird außerdem auch neben Dramaturgen und Schauspielern etc. eine Schriftstellerin, die protokollieren soll, ihre Sichtweisen mit einbringen soll, die darüber schreiben soll. Und so macht man sich also gemeinsam auf dort in den Urwald. Aber wie ich das so gerade erzähle, ist es völlig falsch, denn der Roman ist sehr viel komplexer konstruiert. Nämlich, es ist so, dass wir eigentlich erzählt bekommen, was eine Autorin in ihrer Poetik-Vorlesung darüber erzählt, dass sie mit diesem Theatermacher dorthin gereist ist, in den Urwald, um diesen Holländerinnen nachzuspüren und ein Theaterprojekt daraus zu machen. Es ist also ein Buch, das komplett in indirekter Rede verfasst ist. Und hinzu kommt auch noch, dass also wiedergegeben wird, nicht nur, was die Autorin in dieser Vorlesung erzählt, sondern diese Autorin erzählt in ihrer Vorlesungen auch noch von anderen Anekdoten, Geschichten, exstatischen Ereignissen, die sie von anderen Leuten berichtet bekommt oder die sie irgendwo liest, die sie auch wiederum in indirekter Rede wiedergibt. Also eigentlich ist alles indirekt und es klingt jetzt so, als sei das wahnsinnig kompliziert zu lesen und ist es überhaupt nicht. Man muss sich einmal einstellen auf den Ton und dann will man nicht mehr davon lassen. Denn die interessante Frage, die hier gestellt wird, ist ja, wenn es so indirekt uns eigentlich alles erzählt wird, kann es uns dann trotzdem noch ergreifen? Können wir von der Literatur fasziniert sein, wo doch so viel eigentlich dazwischen geschaltet ist? Und die Antwort ist ja, trotzdem und dann auch wieder nicht, weil diese Schriftstellerin, von der uns erzählt wird, die in ihrer Vorlesung von diesen besonderen Momenten ergriffenen, ergreifenden Ereignissen weiter erzählt, die reflektiert natürlich auch wieder selbst ihr Schreiben, während natürlich erzählt wird, dass sie auch wieder darüber reflektiert wird, dass zum Beispiel die Autorin, die da gerade ihre Poetikvorlesung hält, stockt in ihrem Vortrag, sich durch die Haare wischt, dann wieder ansetzt, ein paar Bilder zeigen lässt, dann wieder weiter erzählt. Also wir werden immer wieder herausgeworfen aus der Situation und kommen wieder in eine neue Situation hinein. Und ich versuche mal, einen Eindruck davon zu geben, wie das erzählt ist. Und vielleicht ist es dann ein bisschen besser nachzuvollziehen.
Ich glaube, man kann sehr gut nachvollziehen. Es ist nur die Frage, ob es gelingt, wie es als Idee konzipiert ist.
Es gelingt so hervorragend, dass man denkt, man kann da eigentlich nur so erzählen. Das ist das Beeindruckende. Man kann nur mit so vielen Flechtungen Figuren, die auftreten, die nochmal was erzählen, die von jemandem erzählen, die sie mal getroffen haben. Das wird wieder in indirekter Rede wiedergegeben. Das zeigt natürlich auch, die eine große Erzählung, die eine große Bogen ist nicht mehr möglich. Aber wir drängen eigentlich daran, wieder die nächste großartige Geschichte zu erleben, von der wir uns aber nie so sicher sein können, ob wir hier nicht einfach auch einer literarischen Strategie aufsetzen. Denn darum geht es natürlich auch. Es geht ja auch darum, in einer Poetikvorlesung das Schreiben zu reflektieren und wie das wird auf mehreren Ebenen getan. Im Januar vor drei Jahren sagt sie, also das ist jetzt die Schriftstellerin in dem Vorlesungssaal, habe sie der Anruf eines Theatermachers erreicht, dessen Name ihr zwar ein Begriff gewesen, dem sie aber bis dahin selbst nie begegnet sei. In Interviews und Gesprächen habe er sich oft auf Arendt bezogen, auf Arendt, auf Adorno und einige französische Soziologen, deren Werk sie selbst stets nur gestreift habe. Er baue an einer großen Theatermaschine, habe er oft erklärt. Es gehe ihm um nichts weniger als einen neuen, einen hypnotischen Realismus, wie ihn eben nur das Theater, dieser Ort der ständigen Doppelungen schaffen könne, wo Wirklichkeit und Fiktion, wie es ein bekannter deutscher Traumatiker so treffend beschrieben habe, aufeinandertreffen und in einer heiligen Kollision ihre Fassung verlieren. Er sitze gerade an den Vorbereitungen zu einem neuen Stück, habe der Theatermacher damals, im Januar, am Telefon gesagt. Es handele sich um die Rekonstruktion eines Falls, ein schwieriger, tragischer Stoff, den er sich zurzeit als eine Art tropische Passion vorstelle, als Referenz auf Herzog, auf Coppola. Und sie selbst sei in diesem Moment mit eingeschalteten Warnblinklichtern an den Straßenrand gefahren, um ihn besser hören zu können. Was wir hier schon sehen, also wir sind hier auf zwei Ebenen, es wird das erzählt, sie hört zu, fährt zum Straßenrand, das wird uns alles innerhalb eines Satzes erzählt. Was sie ihm vorschwebe, sei eine groß angelegte Recherche, so sei er fortgefahren, eine Recherche, die nur in der Wiederholung der Nachbildung der Ereignisse geschehen könnte. Ja, es gehe wie stets am Theater darum, die Dinge am eigenen Leib zu erfahren. Er habe ihre Bestrafung der Märkte, ja ihr ganzes Mythenprojekt über die Jahre hinweg mit Interesse verfolgt, habe er erklärt und wollte sie deshalb als Autorin für sein Vorhaben gewinnen. Vorausgesetzt, sie könne reisen und sei bereit, 10 oder 14 Tage vor Ort zu verbringen. Zwischen den Wendekreisen, wo man das benötigte Material im Kollektiv erarbeiten wolle. Hier steckt auch in diesem Indirekten so eine gewisse Ironisierung manchmal drin. Wir merken das dann auch, wenn da später die Dialektik der Aufklärung auf dem Tisch legt und der Dramaturge oder der Regisseur immer wieder dazu übergehen, Vorträge darüber zu halten. Was kann eigentlich erfahren werden? Was muss theoretisiert werden? Wo greift die Theorie eigentlich nicht? Oder wo werden auch so Wortblumen gebildet, mit denen man aber dann doch eigentlich wenig anfangen kann? Wo wird die Erfahrung eigentlich wieder existenziell? Oder gibt es sie überhaupt? Das ist also etwas, womit dieser Roman spielt. Und natürlich will er uns auch mit in den Abgrund hineinbringen, indem offenbar die Holländerinnen verschüttgegangen sind. Aber es geht auch darum zu sagen, welche Verantwortung hat eigentlich die Literatur und hat das Schreiben? Und inwieweit kann man sich ja selbst eine Ethik verpflichtet fühlen, wenn man schreibt? So wird beispielsweise erzählt, dass jene Schriftstellerin eine Autorin bewundert, die den Namen Trapenard heißt und über diese wird dann wiederum erzählt, dass die einen One-Night-Stand hat und dann dieser Affäre wiederum Geschichten erzählt, um wirklich einmal zu sagen, wer sie ist oder was auf ihr lastet. Und das wird auch wieder wiedergegeben. Und ich versuche mal so eine Geschichte hier vorzulesen, damit wir auch davon Eindruck bekommen, weil da diese Struktur ganz gut erfahrbar ist, worum es immer wieder in diesen eingewobenen Geschichten geht. Als sie, also Trappinar, am Wiener Westbahnhof aus dem Zug steige, werde sie noch im Bahnhofsgebäude von einem Jungen von vielleicht 17 oder 18 Jahren angesprochen und um 50 Euro gebeten, die er brauche, um mit dem Bus nach Hause fahren zu können. Trappinar habe Mühe, seinem gebrochenen Deutsch zu folgen, glaube aber zu verstehen, dass er aus Bulgarien stammt. Sie wäre ab, ein Reflex nach der langen Fahrt, die sie schweigend verbracht habe, sei sie nicht darauf vorbereitet gewesen, so plötzlich angesprochen zu werden. Außerdem habe sie die Höhe des Betrags überrascht. Der junge Mann, Nicke, freundlich, verständnisvoll und beide entfernen sich bereits voneinander, als er sich doch noch einmal umdrehe. Er kommt zurück zu mir und versucht es noch einmal. Ich verstehe nicht, was er sagt, aber ich lehne nun Resolute ab mit einer Härte, von der ich nicht gewusst habe, dass sie mir zur Verfügung steht. Nein, er geht dann ohne Widerspruch. In diesem Moment seines Weggehens, so Trappinar, sehe sie, wie sich etwas in seinem Blick verändere, ein flackernd, flackernde Verzweiflung. Auf einen Schlag, glaube sie, zu verstehen, was sie rückblickend als die Katastrophe meines Neins bezeichne. Für den Bruchteil einer Sekunde meine sie, tief in das Leben eines anderen zu blicken. Ein Leben, das sie an Kafka, an Kurt C. Michael K erinnere, tombé hors du système, für immer am Bahnhof irgendeiner Stadt gestrandet. Sie glaube, den Möglichkeitsraum zu sehen, der im Moment ihrer Begegnung kurz offen stehe, nur um dann wieder in sich zusammenzusacken. Trafena bringe ihr Gepäck zum Hotel, aber der Blick des Jungen gehe ihr auf unerträgliche Weise nach. Und also hebe sie nach dem Bezug ihres Zimmers seine größere Summe Geld ab und gehe dann zurück zum Westbahnhof. Es regne bis zum Beginn der Veranstaltung im Akademietheater, bleibe ihr nur noch eine knappe Stunde. Sie hasse mit suchendem Blick durch die Hallen und Geschosse des Bahnhofs, aber eigentlich wisse sie schon, dass sie den Jungen nicht mehr finden werde, dass er auch weiterhin, wie sie schreibe, in der höllischen Unmittelbarkeit der Tage und Nächte gefangen sein werde. In den Saal des Akademietheaters, wo sie verschwitzt und mit nassem Haar eintreffe, lasse man sie erst herein, als sich eine Wiener Autorin in der Schlange hinter ihr einmesche. Kurze Zeit später stehe sie auf der Bühne zwischen Blumensträußen und halte ihre Dankesrede, die im österreichischen Standard am Tag danach als eindringlich und zutiefst politisch besprochen werde. Marilyn Trappanar ist eine Autorin, der nichts Menschliches fremd ist. Seither schreibe sie, hänge der Junge an ihr dran, wie ein Toter, der sie nicht mehr loslasse, schleppe sie ihn mit sich herum.
Das ist mir zu viel konjunktiv.
Es ist wunderbar zu lesen. Es macht großen Spaß. Und es ist ja auch wieder nur die Wiedergabe eines literarischen Werks. Und dass man in dieser Mittelbarkeit trotzdem eine unmittelbare Wirkung erzielen kann. Also, dass das über Sprache geht, das ist so beeindruckend. Und natürlich ist auch diese Geschichte nicht einfach so stehen gelassen, sondern es gibt da noch eine Tochter dieser Schriftstellerin, die noch ganz anderes über ihre Mutter wiederum zu berichten weiß. Wir sind also hier in einer Literatur, die unglaublich nach Meta-Meta-Ebene klingt, die aber gerade deshalb versucht, nochmal das existenzielle, ekstatische möglich zu machen. Und so geht dann auch die Schriftstellerin-Figur durch den Urwald mit diesem Team. Da heißt es, so sei sie eine Weile gegangen, murmelnd, flüstern, als bräche, eine milde Form von Wahnsinn durch. Die verbundene Hand habe sie wie ein Bündel, ein Kind vor der Brust getragen, die Hitze sei aufdringlich gewesen, Schweiß sei ihr über den Bauch, das Steißbein geronnen, sie habe den Wald wie hinter Schleiern gesehen. Irgendwann habe Trepper, Tepper, der der Regisseur zu ihr, aufgeschlossen. Ob sie sich an Herzog erinnere, wie er sage, die Vögel sengen in seinen Augen nicht, sie kreischten nur vor Schmerz. Beide hätten sie gelacht. Er selbst sei kein Herzogianer, habe Tepper dann gesagt und sich das verschwitzte Haar aus der Stirn gestrichen, obwohl man als Filmemacher nicht um ihn herumkomme, wie man auch um andere, um Marker oder Lynch, nicht herumkomme. Wir sind hier in einem Bereich der Literatur, in dem wir es mit einer unglaublich gebildeten Autoren zu tun haben. Aber es ist nicht Bildungshuberei, die hier vorgenommen wird, sondern es ist tatsächlich die Frage, wenn man diese Theorie-Intus hat, die literarischen Vorbilder und so, und sogar noch hinzukommend Figuren, Schriftstellerfiguren, wie eben die genannte Tapenar erfindet, ist dann man wirklich ganz in der Welt nur der schönen Literatur angekommen? Oder gibt es noch die echte eindringliche Erfahrung und ist sie vielleicht nur noch indirekt herzustellen? Also ist man nur über das Indirekte in der Lage, zu diesem Äxtatischen zu kommen? Das ist wirklich die große Literatur, die hier geschieht. Ich bin hingerissen davon. Und ja, das klingt alles ein bisschen anstrengend, ist es aber überhaupt nicht zu lesen. Es macht große Freude.
Na gut. Ich hoffe, die Autorin hat ordentlich gearbeitet, sodass der Redigator nicht allzu viel zu tun hatte. Und die Tiefungen wieder aufzulösen und den richtigen Konjunktur zu finden. Was ganz profan ist, Wohnungstausche. Aufgeschrieben in der Zeit von Karlott Brouh. Ich will deine, nimm du meine. Der Text beginnt wie folgt. Wie viele Arbeitszimmer braucht ein Mensch? Wir würden sagen viele. Der nicht mehr arbeitet. Die Frage drängt sich auf. Wenn man durch 175 Quadratmeter Altbauwohnung in Berlin Tempelhof geführt wird, hier wohnen Sabine und Helmut Schuster. Sie ist 70, er 72 Jahre alt. Neben Küche, Schlafzimmer, Wohnzimmer und zwei Bädern gibt es vier Zimmer, in denen jeweils ein Schreibtisch einstaubt. 90 Meter entfernt tummelt sich Familie Fiesel. Sie lebt zu 5 auf 81 Quadratmetern. Also wir sind schon geprimed auf, ja warum tauschen die nicht einfach? Und die Autoren will den emotionalen und ökonomischen Gründen nachgehen, warum so wenig getauscht wird, obwohl so viel zum Tauschen da ist. Ökonomische Eckdaten hier. Die beiden Schusters wohnen für 1475 Quadratmeter auf ihren 175 Quadratmetern.
Euro meinst du?
Euro, genau. Was also 8,40 Euro pro Quadratmeter macht. Der Durchschnitt in diesem Gebiet, Berlin Tempelhof, liegt beim Angebot 18,50 Euro. Also sie liegen im 40-Prozent-Bereich. Weil es natürlich durch alte Mietverträge und so gang und gäbe ist. Helmut Schuster war Professor für Wirtschaftswissenschaften. Er sagt, wir suchen ja etwas kleineres, aber wir wollen uns finanziell nicht so sehr verschlechtern. Meine Pointe ist ja immer wieder, wenn jemand eine kleinere Wohnung sucht, ist sie doppelt so teuer. Also halbe Größe hat doppelter Preis. Sie nennt dann kurz tauschwohnung.com. Das ist ja eine Seite, die extra dafür angeboten wird. Denn die Idee ist ja so plausibel, dass man an sie glauben will, beginnt dieser Absatz und er endet mit, das ist die Hoffnung, nachdem das beschrieben wurde, wodurch wir schon hören, ah ja gut, also da kommt es also nicht dazu. Glaube und Hoffnung. Inzwischen, das wusste ich auch nicht, war ganz fasziniert, die Hälfte der Inserate auf Emo-Scout und so, also auf den regulären Wohnungsmärkten online, die Hälfte ist mittlerweile Tauschwohnung. Dass jemand seine Wohnung nur anbietet, wenn er im Gegenzug eine andere bekommt für sich. Die Inflation der Wohnkosten.
Ich hörte jetzt gerade aus, guck mal, es war eine Dame, die ihr Haus verkauft, die ist da auch allein im großen Haus und hat auch dann zu Bedingungen gesetzt, dass derjenige, der es kauft, ihr eine Wohnung suchen muss. Die Frau ist auch über 70 und will sich das nicht antun. Und es geht aber auch da jetzt um die Frage, also die verkleinert sich deutlich. Sie sagt, sie hätte jetzt so gerne 75 Quadratmeter oder was und hat jetzt ein wirklich sehr, sehr großes Haus. Und auch da ist jetzt das große Problem, dass das, was da ist, oft extrem teuer ist. Und sie sagt ja, gut, dann ist mit der Rente ja oder das ist ein Schluss.
Ja, also diese Schluss, dass hier wohnen im vierten Stock, für die ist das noch mal kein Fahrstuhl und so. Da gibt es ein paar Kriterien, aber wir hören es gleich. Die Wohninflation von 2010 bis 2022, 50 bis 70 Prozent, also 50 im Schnitt, 70 in den hochpreisigen Lagen. Inflation, zur selben Zeit 25 Prozent. Sie hat dann nicht noch mal die Einkommensinflation mit aufgeschrieben, weil die gibt es ja nicht. Und sie kommt auf den Wirtschaftsgeografen Robert Kitzmann zu sprechen. Der hat in der Humboldt-Uni eine Forschung gemacht in München, Berlin, Potsdam und Hamburg. Er meinte, Ausweichbewegungen am regulären Markt vorbei sind einfach zu große rechtliche Grauzone. Denn das Mietrecht regelt das einfach nicht. Denn es zieht ja jemand Neues ein und will den alten Vertrag mitnehmen. Das kenne man nur aus der DDR oder der Zwischenkriegszeit. Also das, was hier als Hoffnung verkauft wird, ist schon nicht die besten Zeiten, würde ich sagen. Die Linken fordern Wohnungstausche, bei denen Mietverträge bleiben. Das allerdings ist Oppositionsarbeit, genau wie aktuell von den Grünen. Die wollen das zumindest für öffentlich getragene Wohnung. Also wenn Städte und Kommunen, gibt es in Berlin auch 300.000 kommunale Wohnungen, aber auch da gibt es das immer noch nicht. Sie porträtiert dann kurz eine Noemi Götz, die sich gegen Wohnungstausche engagiert, TikTok-Videos macht mit 10.000 Views zum Thema. Denn sie hat einen Wohnberechtigungsschein, einen Schwerbehindertenausweis, einen Dringlichkeitsschein und sie ist schwarz, aber was sie nicht hat, ist eine Wohnung. Sie kann also nicht mittauschen, wodurch sie sich zurecht nochmal natürlich ausgekegelt sieht. So klappt also dieses ganze Programm nicht. Und jetzt werden hier Zahlen genannt. Berlin hat 2018 ein Programm organisiert. Es liefen 450 Tauschanfragen auf und getauscht wurden am Ende 824 Wohnungen. Ich habe einmal die Zahl aus Hamburg genannt. Nachdem hier, also es waren ja 8 Wohnungen in der 1,8 Millionen Stadt Hamburg. Tauschwohnungen bleibt also bei dem Hin- und Herziehen, wie wir es kennen, immer noch im 1%-Bereich. Also nicht im einstelligen, sondern 1%-Bereich. Tauschwohnungen ist also ein Konzept, das in Deutschland überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Ältere Menschen in günstigen, großen Wohnungen verspüren, keinen Druck umzuziehen. Deshalb kommen auf den Tauschportalen auf jeden, der sich verkleinern will, fünf, die sich vergrößern wollen. Und dann sehen aber die, die sich verkleinern wollen, immer das Angebot und sagen, ne, kann ich auch nichts mehr noch machen und so. Die Menschen in großen Wohnungen erwarten zu viel. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es mit dem Tausch klappt, ist de facto Null, sagt dieser Kitzmann. Und die Schusters sagen, das Problem sind wir, weil wir im Kiez und bei unseren Freunden bleiben wollen. Das mit dem Fahrstuhl hat ja noch Zeit.
Ja.
Also diese Zahlen sind...
Das ist ja auch nachvollziehbar.
Ja. Also tauschen, Wohnungstausch ist nur eine Idee, das findet faktisch in Deutschland nicht statt.
Wir klappen den Laptop auf. Ich klappe den Laptop auf, denn ich habe tatsächlich das alles im PDF bearbeitet, damit ich die Stellen sehr gut finden kann. Du siehst auch ich komme so langsam in der Gegenwart an. Nein, das war jetzt ganz hilfreich. Und zwar habe ich ja nochmal das Unabomber-Manifest gelesen. Und wir feiern da ja ein kleines Jubiläum. Das ist jetzt tatsächlich 30 Jahre alt. Ein Wort zum Unabomber, also wir reden hier von Ted Kaczynski, der hat Berühmtheit erlangt dadurch, dass er Briefbomben an alle möglichen Leute schickte, unter anderem auch an den Forscher David Gelernte, also auch einer, der sich mit neuronalen Netzwerken beschäftigt hat. Er hat also einen Krieg gegen den Fortschritt geführt und hat entsprechend dann Leuten diese Bomben zugeschickt. Manche sind dabei gestorben oder wurden schwer verletzt. Man hat ihn dann mit einem aufwändigen Profiling irgendwann ausfindig gemacht. Er lebte in einer Hütte im Wald, ganz abgeschottet. Er hatte damals die Washington Post dazu gebracht, sein Manifest abzudrucken. Das war sozusagen ein Zugeständnis, das man machen musste. Kann man auch alles in einer sehr guten Serie über den Unabomber nachsehen, die bei Netflix mal lief. Ich glaube, sie ist jetzt nicht mehr da. Jedenfalls gehen wir jetzt in dieses Manifest, das 30 Jahre alt ist, rein. Das beginnt wie folgt. Die folgende industrielle Revolution haben sich für die Menschen als eine Katastrophe erwiesen. Unsere Lebenserwartung ist dadurch in den fortgeschrittenen Ländern bedeutend gestiegen. Gleichzeitig aber trat infolgedessen eine Destabilisierung der Gesellschaft ein. Das Leben wurde unerfüllt. Die Menschen gerieten in eine unwürdige Abhängigkeit. Diese Entwicklung hat zu weit verbreiteten psychischen Problemen geführt. Er spricht dann von Entwurzelung und von Depressionen, Anstieg von anderen Krankheiten. Das sieht er also, wenn er den Fortschritt sieht. Er beginnt also erst einmal fortschrittskritisch. Und dann fragen wir uns, wen macht er denn jetzt so als erstes verantwortlich? Und dann werden die ersten fast 20 Seiten einem Phänomen gewidmet. Eine der verbreitetsten Erscheinungen unserer wahnwitzigen Welt ist der Leftismus. Also die Linken sind schuld. Was versteht man darunter? Während der ersten Hälfte des 20. Jahrhunderts konnte man Leftismus etwa mit Sozialismus gleichsetzen. Heute ist die Bewegung zersplittert und es ist nicht mehr deutlich, wen man eigentlich als Linken bezeichnen kann. Wenn wir in dieser Abhandlung über Linke sprechen, dann meinen wir vor allem Sozialisten, Kollektivisten, Politically Correct Anhänger, Aktivisten im Bereich Feminismus, der Homosexualität, der Behinderten, Verteidiger des Tierschutzes und dergleichen. Jedoch kann nicht jeder, der zu dieser Bewegung gehört, als Linker bezeichnet werden. Also es ist dann auch immer so ein schwammiger Begriff, immer wie es gerade passt. Aber uns fällt gerade auf in dieser Aufzählung, dass das genau diese Kulturkämpfe sind, die wir heute die ganze Zeit erleben. Nämlich diese Linken hätten Minderwertigkeitsgefühle. Sie versuchen dann auf eine Übersozialisierung zu setzen. Das heißt, sie wollen alles kollektivieren, überall soll der Staat ran. Diejenigen, die besonders empfindlich, hinsichtlich einer politically incorrect Terminologie reagieren, sind nicht die durchschnittlichen schwarzen Ghettobewohner, sondern aus privilegierten Gesellschaftsschichten. Ja, also ich meine, hier stehen natürlich auch Sätze, die an sich so stimmen. Also er spricht dann an auf die Linken an Universitäten, die eigentlich der Mittel- und Oberklasse angehören, aber dann so eine Sensibilität ausbauen. Die sieht er aber als den eigentlichen Feind an, gegen den zu kämpfen ist. Denn er sagt, diese Linken, und damit meint er dann immer so alle, von den Uni-Eliten bis darüber hinaus, sie hassen Amerika, sie hassen die westliche Zivilisation, weil sie ja den Kolonialismus kritisieren, sie hassen weiße Männer und sie hassen Rationalität. Das ist also seine große These, die er dann immer wieder wiederholt. Und die würden, weil sie Rationalität hassen, auch nichts von IQ-Tests halten. Dabei seien die aber nützlich. Sie wollen eigentlich die individuellen Fähigkeiten nicht fördern, sondern schreien immer nur nach dem Staat. Linke protestieren, indem sie sich vor Autos auf den Boden legen, schreibt er. Er sieht darin aber jetzt nicht irgendwie, ihr könnt ihr sagen, die sind ja auch fortschrittskritisch oder so. Nein, die sieht ja alle nicht als Verbündeten an, sondern die haben erst zu diesen großen psychischen Störungen geführt, die in der Gesellschaft vorherrschen. Und das hat sich dann verbunden mit der entsprechenden Technik. Es ist dabei herausgekommen, sagt er, der überangepasste Mensch der psychologischen Zaum gehalten wird. Das verursacht bei vielen Menschen ein Gefühl von Zwang und Ohnmacht, was ein schweres Leiden verursachen kann. Unsere Meinung nach gehört überangepasstheit zu den schlimmsten Grausamkeiten, die Menschen angetan werden können. Und wir wissen ja, wie jetzt in den rechten Kulturkämpfen so merkwürdige Freiheitsrufe raus werden. Ja, so Ulf Poschert will nochmal mit 200 über die Autobahn und und und. Was erstaunlich ist, dass er, der Unabomber jetzt hier, glaubt eigentlich, man könne eine Gesellschaft organisieren, ohne eine gewisse Anpassung. Was ja nicht gehen kann. Also es funktioniert ja nur mit einer gewissen Anpassung, dass wir mit so vielen in einer Stadt zusammenleben können oder so. Und er sieht aber alles, was quasi dem modernen Leben dient, also dass ja sagen wir friktionslose Abläufe stattfinden kann, als eine Form der Anpassung, die dazu führt, dass angepasstes Denken passiert, die dazu führt, dass also das Individuum seiner Freiheit beraubt wird. Und dieses Individuum fühlt aber, dass es der beraubt wurde und ist deshalb so traurig darüber. Und hat deshalb diese ganzen Leiden. Alles läuft darauf hinaus, sagt er, dass der überangepasste Linke den schwarzen Menschen in das System integrieren will und von ihm verlangt, dessen Werte zu übernehmen. Er sagt also, die linken Bestrebungen, zum Beispiel bessere Schulbildung für Schwarze oder so, herzuführen, das würde ja alles nur dazu führen, dass man die auch gerne dem Anpassungsdruck unterwerfen will. Also er glaubt überhaupt nicht an eine integrative Kraft, sondern sieht eigentlich, dass damit wird man nur ins System eingespeist. Er sagt dann auch, die heutige Gesellschaft versucht uns in einem weitaus größeren Umfang anzupassen als irgendeine frühere. Wo man auch sagen würde, hä? Preußen? Das viktorianische Zeitalter, also wo sollen wir hingehen, wo wir nicht eine extreme Anpassung erleben. Er sagt dann, Experten bringen uns sogar bei, wie wir essen, uns bewegen, lieben und unsere Kinder erziehen sollen.
Ja, die haben immer so eine Idee von so einer Originalität des, was auch immer.
Ja, denn er sagt, naja, das sei zwar hart gewesen, das Leben der Primitiven, also das ist noch nicht der technische Fortschritt, da war das weiter damit, aber das sei echt und ehrlich gewesen.
Echt und ehrlich, genau.
Frauen, sagt er hier, auch das kennen wir aus der Inselbewegung, werden ermutigt, Karriere zu machen. Warum? Weil ihre Begabungen dem System zugute kommen. Noch wichtiger ist die Tatsache, dass berufstätige Frauen sich besser in das System integrieren und eben stärker verbunden sind als ihren Familien. Damit trägt man dazu bei, die Familien-Solidarität zu schwächen. Auch das musste, dass wir jetzt wieder kennen. Wir dürfen auf keinen Fall da irgendetwas sozialisieren bei der Kindererziehung. Das soll bitte bei den Frauen ganz alleine bleiben. Es ist so interessant, wenn man das liest, weil man ja erstmal ein technikkritisches Manifest denkt zu bekommen. Und dann geht das erst nur in diese Richtung. Ja, er hat dann immer so Sätze, in denen er erklärt, die Gesellschaft funktioniert nach diesen zwei Prinzipien. Und dann erläutert er das so ein bisschen. Das funktioniert aber die meiste Zeit gar nicht. Dann sagt er, zu den abnormen Bedingungen der modernen industriellen Gesellschaft gehört das ständig zunehmende Bevölkerungswachstum. Wir haben ja gerade von dir erfahren, das war also das Wohlstandswachstum Amerikas. Die Isolation des Menschen von der Natur, die außerordentliche Schnelligkeit sozialer Veränderungen, der Zusammenbruch von natürlichen kleinen Gemeinschaften, wie der Großfamilie des Dorfes und des Stammes. Darum muss es eigentlich gehen. Also so eine Rückkehr zum Tribalismus. Die Konservativen beschimpft er als Dummköpfe, weil die auch Wirtschaftswachstum wollen. Und er sagt ja nein, das macht das ja alles noch viel schlimmer, die Vereinzelung. Aber er spricht nicht über den Kapitalismus, sondern glaubt immer, das sei durch die Technik dann entstanden. Also es ist auch, wenn man so vom Kapitalismus gar keine Ahnung hat, wird es halt auch schwierig mit dem Manifeste schreiben. Er sagt dann, unsere Bedürfnisse, die wir haben, sind nicht natürlich. Denn unsere Großeltern hätten ja niemals von solchen Gerätschaften oder so geträumt. Das heißt, die wurden uns vom Marketing, von der Werbung eingetrichtert. Sonst hätten wir die ja nicht.
Ist ja nicht ganz verkehrt.
Ist natürlich nicht. Genau. Da sind so ganz viele Punkte, bei denen man sagt, ja klar, spielt die Werbung da eine Rolle und kein Mensch aus dem Marketing würde das leugnen. Aber er sieht dann einfach so, dass man das überspringen könnte und sagen, wir können jetzt auch mal ohne Verfahren, die wir brauchen in einer bürokratischen Gesellschaft auskommen. Wir können auch mal ohne Technik auskommen, ohne all das. Und dabei erkennt er nicht, was eigentlich die Situation ist, nämlich von Menschen, die davon abhängig sind, ihre Arbeitskraft zu verkaufen. Er schreibt, ob wir eine Arbeitsstelle finden oder eine verlieren, hängt von den Wirtschaftsexperten der Regierung ab oder von der Exekutive. Würde ich sagen, na ja, und davon, wie die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung allgemein ist.
Ja, vor allem, was nützt es, sich dann in eine Zeit zurückzuwünschen, in der keiner von oben verordnet, welche Berufe es gibt, weil es keine gibt.
Das war schön, das schreibt er dann tatsächlich.
Das war ja ehrlich.
Das schreibt er, denn dann wusste er, das war zwar nicht sicher, aber er sagt, der primitive Mensch kann sich verteidigen, wenn ihn ein wildes Tier bedroht. Oder anderswo Nahrung finden, wenn er dem Hunger ausgesetzt ist. Es gibt für ihn zwar keine Gewissheit, dass er dabei erfolgreich sein wird, jedoch ist er den Bedrohungen keineswegs hilflos ausgeliefert. Dagegen ist der moderne Mensch vielen Bedrohungen hilflos ausgeliefert. Nukleare Unfälle, krebserregende Stoffe, Umweltverschmutzung usw. Dann denke ich mir, nee, der Mensch war damals auch völlig ausgesetzt und hatte man eine Zahnentzündung, hätte man auch daran sterben können, dann war man dem ausgesetzt. Die moderne Gesellschaft sei zwar freizügig, aber eigentlich sei das ja immer nur innerhalb des Systems. Dann denkt man, ja klar, innerhalb des Systems. Also ich kann jetzt, sonst muss ich, das ist so Reichsbürger-Idee, ich begründe jetzt einfach hier nochmal meinen eigenen Staat und lasse mir von denen nichts sagen. Es gibt kein Gesetz, das uns zwingt, jeden Tag eine Arbeit nachzugehen, schreibt er. Und trotzdem würden das alle tun. Dann denke ich mir, doch, das ist ja der ökonomische Druck, der einen dazu führt, dass man seine Arbeitskraft verkauft. Da brauchen wir nicht nochmal ein extra Gesetz.
Ich meine, ich weiß, was er sich wünscht als das ursprüngliche, ehrliche. Jeder kann einfach in den Wald gehen und dort so leben. Also, es ist ja nicht jetzt, es hat ja noch nie eine Technologie, eine andere abgelöst, im Sinne von komplett verdrängt. In der Hinsicht steht ihm das ja zur Verfügung. Er kann ja seine Kommune gründen, wie auch immer.
Versuchen wir mal, die Freiheit zu definieren mit ihm. Wir verstehen unter Freiheit die Möglichkeit einer Selbstverwirklichung durch echte Ziele anstelle von künstlichen Ersatzhandlungen. Frei von Einmischung, Manipulation oder Kontrolle durch irgendjemanden, besonders durch große Organisationen. Also große Organisationen grundsätzlich schlecht. Freiheit bedeutet, die Kontrolle über die eigenen existenziellen Dinge zu haben, die Leben und Tod bestimmen. Nahrung, Kleidung, Unterkunft und Verteidigung gegen Gefahren der Umwelt. Aber diese Kontrolle war ja immer eine Illusion, dass man die hatte. Es sagt dann, Freiheit bedeutet, Macht zu haben, aber keine Macht, um andere Menschen zu kontrollieren, sondern Macht über die Kontrolle der eigenen Lebensumstände. Aber dass in dieser Macht natürlich auch immer liegt, dass eine Macht über den anderen ist, wirklich gesehen, das ist so viel halbgare Denken.
Es ist so paradoxisch.
Aber interessant ist ja, dass wir so viel davon heute wiederfinden. Wenn wir jetzt ja hören, ja wir sind ja kurz vor dem Sozialismus jetzt, weil eine Erbschaftssteuer vielleicht mal kommen könnte. Er sagte auch, die Massenmedien sind so total und lassen die anderen Meinungen nicht mehr zu, dass er ja Menschen töten musste, um unsere Botschaft mit nachhaltigem Eindruck zu veröffentlichen. Also das war die einzige Notwendigkeit, weil das System so total...
Das System hat ihn gezwungen zu morden.
Ja, hat er ja nicht so viel. Deswegen kann man sich die Summe der Geschichte so vorstellen, es gibt zwei Komponenten, einem unberechenbaren Teil, der aus unvorhersehbaren Ereignissen besteht und einem nicht erkennbaren Muster folgt und einem erkennbaren Teil, der langfristige historische Abläufe beinhaltet. Gut, das trifft irgendwo immer zu, aber damit ist auch gerade gar nichts ausgesagt. Also ich war echt nochmal verblüfft darüber zu sehen, dass man einfach so sich hinsetzt und sagt, ich schreibe jetzt mal auf, was das System ist. Und er kommt dann auf die Idee, ja, dass die Menschen jetzt so angehalten werden, Wissenschaftler, Ingenieure oder Mathematiker zu werden. Das sei ja klar, weil das dem System dient. Dann denke ich mir, ja, ein deutsch-rötlicher Kapitalismus wird Ingenieure brauchen. Das liegt mir auf der Hand. Das scheint mir aber jetzt nicht irgendwie so verrückt zu sein.
Ich bin auch immer wieder sehr dafür, auch das Lenkerlager daran zu erinnern, dass eine Win-Situation für den einen auch immer eine Win-Situation für den anderen sein kann. Ja. Also Ausbeuterei geht meistens einher mit sehr hohen Gehaltszahlungen, die man durchaus gutiert.
Ja.
Bevor man im Wald leben muss, weil Ted das sagt.
Wenn früher ein Mensch zu Fuß ging, konnte er gehen, wo er wollte, ohne irgendeine Verkehrsvorschrift beachten zu müssen. Er war unabhängig von einem technologischen Hilfssystem. Die Erfindung motorisierter Fahrzeuge schien die Freiheit des Menschen zunächst zu vergrößern. Aber wir ahnen, in dicht besiedelten Gebieten kann man sich mit einem Auto nicht einfach bewegen, wie man will, sondern man muss sich dem Verkehrsfluss und den Verkehrsregeln anpassen.
Aber man ist trotzdem noch schneller als zu Fuß.
Aber du bist nicht mehr so frei. Du kannst nicht nach rechts und links ausscheren, wie du willst. In diesem Ductus ist es geschrieben, was für uns jetzt noch mal relevant ist, dass er tatsächlich in allem, was nicht männlich ist, was er unter männlich versteht, dass er darin das Problem sieht, also der Feminismus, LGBT, all diese Sachen, sind das große Problem. Und er sieht eigentlich sein Projekt darin, die Selbstverwirklichung zu ermöglichen. Um wieder an die große alte Zeit anzuknüpfen. Er sagt, die heute sichtbare gesellschaftliche Zerstörung ist keineswegs Ergebnis eines Zufalls, sondern kann nur aus den Lebensbedingungen hervorgegangen sein, die das System den Menschen auferlegt hat. Wie wir bereits dargelegt haben, ist einer der Hauptgründe die Zerstörung der Selbstverwirklichung. Und das ist das Erstaunliche hier. Und auch der Denkfehler bei den vielen Rechten, die jetzt so gerade auftreten. Wir haben ja mit Eric Ahrens ja auch so einen merkwürdigen Fall gehabt. Das Konzept der Selbstverwirklichung, wie wir das heute verstehen, ist ein hochmodernes. Und schon bei unseren Großeltern in Teilen nicht mehr so anzutreffen. Die verstehen nicht, ich habe mich scheiden lassen, weil ich mich selbst verwirklichen wollte. Das ist für die überhaupt kein Argument gewesen vor 60 Jahren. Da haben die gesagt, wie bist du verrückt geworden, oder wie selbst verwirklichen oder so. Du bist doch jetzt verheiratet, ist doch gut. Das, was hier als Selbstverwirklichung jetzt plötzlich von rechts artikuliert wird, ist ein hochmodernes Konzept. Das sind quasi die Früchte dieser ganzen Entwicklungen, die sie kritisieren, ist diese Selbstverwirklichung. Also das ist so verrückt, dass jetzt auch dann so getan wird, als sei es von links heraus das Problem gewesen, die Selbstverwirklichung zu... also die würde die bremsen. Sondern es ist ja genau umgekehrt gewesen, dass wir immer wieder von konservativer Seite, von der Kirche oder sonst wem gemerkt haben, dass da die Selbstverwirklichung eingeschränkt wurde, dass plötzlich sagen, du sollst aber nicht und das nicht und das nicht und das nicht.
Ja, das kann man ja in Amerika gerade gut sehen. Da regiert gerade die Partei, die seit 100 Jahren oder mindestens 50 sagt, wir sind die Partei für Small Government und Land of the Free. Ja. Und jetzt ist es Big Government und niemand ist free.
Er schreibt, unsere Gesellschaft neigt dazu, jede Art des Denkens oder Verhaltens, die dem System unbequem ist, als Krankheit anzusehen. Da würde ich sagen, ja genau, das ist aber ein rechter Diskurs. Dass man sagt, die Homosexuellen sind pervers, die emanzipatorischen Frauen sind hysterisch und weiß ich nicht mehr, Transpersonen sind neurotisch. Also das sind ja genau die rechten Diskurse, die stattfindet. Für ihn ist jedenfalls klar, es kann keine Reform mehr geben innerhalb des Systems. Die Fabriken müssen zerstört werden, die technischen Lehrbücher müssen verbrannt werden. Es geht darum, dass man zunächst einmal überlebt, aber wenigstens muss man dann trachten nach einem sinnvollen Leben und gibt sich nicht mehr solchen Ersatzbefriedigungen hin. Und da wir ja schon gehört hatten, als wir uns mit The Cathedral auseinandersetzten, mit diesen Denkern da rund um JD Vans, ist offenbar bei aller Techniknähe, die da ist zu Peter Thiel, Altman und so weiter, diese Idee, dass man auch vielleicht alles zerstören muss erstmal, um wieder ganz bei sich anzukommen, eine momentan in diesen rechten Kreisen beliebte Theorie. Denn sonst würden die sich ja nicht jetzt neuerdings wieder laufend auf das Unabomber-Manifest beziehen.
Ja, ich hab hier gerade dieses Zitat offen von Geisra Klein, aber er reformuliert nach einer Stunde mit Yoram Hassouni, ich stell ihn nochmal vor, wenn wir Ende des Monats drüber reden, der ihm versucht, und das ist mal ein außergewöhnliches Gespräch, weil das in so einem ganz sanften, ich bin hier der Professor, ich veranstalte zwar diese Conventions, wo die ganzen Jedi-Vanses rumhängen und so, aber ich bin ja hier nur die Bühne, auf der dann so und nach einer Stunde, das dann, also nach diesem Statement, wo nur die Rückfrage kommt, ist das Gespräch vorbei und Israel Kleinere formuliert dann, also sie müssen die Macht des Staates auf eine Weise nutzen, die ich als intolerant bezeichnen würde, um das Zentrum wieder aufzubauen, um die nationale Stärke wiederherzustellen, sodass wir wieder tolerant sein können, fragt Israel Klein ihn und er dann, das ist, was sie denken, was sie tun, ja. Und damit ist das Gespräch vorbei.
Ja, ich habe das auch gehört. Das ist unglaublich. Wir müssen, bringst du da Clips mit, weil das müssen wir, müssen wir sehr ausführlich behandeln.
Ich habe auch auf stefanschulz.com schon über dieses Gespräch geschrieben. Ah ja. Und da schrumpfen und verkümmern das neue Zauberwort Kohäsion, das scheint ja bei ihm auch ganz groß zu sein, wie diese Nationalkonservativen jetzt ihre brutale Degrowth-Fantasie einfach entwickeln und praktisch umsetzen.
Wir wissen, wie abschätzig ein Ulf Poscher zum Beispiel über alle, die aktivistisch unterwegs sind, spricht. Wir wissen, wie er darüber redet, wenn jemand gerne mehr soziale Gerechtigkeit oder etwas haben möchte. Das ist eins zu eins das, was wir hier auch lesen können. Das ist das Letzte, was ich daraus zitiere. Der Unabomber will dann nochmal so charakterisieren, woran man eigentlich den Linken erkennt. Da sagt er, er benutzt gerne allgemeine Schlagwörter. Rassismus, Imperialismus, Neokolonialismus, Genozid, gesellschaftliche Veränderung, soziale Gerechtigkeit, gesellschaftliche Verantwortung. Heißt also, wer das in den Mund nimmt, ist auf der Gegenseite.
Ich weiß, woran wir die Rechten erkennen. Die wollen nur die ganze Zeit. Gender, Gender, Gender, Gender, Geschlecht, Geschlecht, Geschlecht, Gender. Ja.
Also es ist so absurd, das nochmal zu lesen, aber dass diese Gedanken jetzt auch 30 Jahre später so eine neue Blüte erleben, dann aber wiederum gemischt mit neuen. Also das ist ja alles nicht kohärent, was da so ausgebreitet wird, sondern selbst...
Das ist wahnsinnig paradox.
Die treffen sich irgendwie mittags mit Peter Thiel und sagen genau, wir brauchen AGI und danach treffen sich mit jemanden, der sagt, wir müssen uns mal wieder am Unabomber-Manifest konzentrieren und dann treffen sie noch da, den von dir gerade erwähnten, der sagt, wir müssen mal wieder so zu den Gründervereltern, zu diesem alten Amerika zurück, um dann wieder neu tolerant zu werden.
Ja, und am Ende, du hast es ja mit Ole auch in der Speakeasy Bar besprochen, diejenigen, die immer die Frau am Herd verankern wollen, den Herd im Haus der Familie, das Haus der Familie auf dem Grundstück des Clans und so, das sind diese Somewheres, die dann irgendwo, Anywheres, ja. Anywheres, genau, die dann irgendwo Vorträge halten, nur in ihrem Laptop leben und nur in Hotels. Das passt einfach alles nicht zusammen. Es ist kein Zufall, dass Russland ukrainische Kinder entführt. Wir kommen auf ein Thema zurück, das wir schon häufiger besprochen haben, aber es gibt aktuelle Zahlen und Literatur in journalistischen Maßstaben von Isolde Rudorfer bei den Krautreportern. Und wir gehen nur kurz die Zahlen mal durch, denn die eine Grafik, wahrscheinlich hat sie diesen Text auch nur geschrieben, weil diese Grafik aufkam. Ich zeig sie dir auch gleich, ist wirklich beeindruckend. 2024 starben in der Ukraine eine halbe Million Menschen, schreibt sie. Also dreimal mehr als geboren wurden. Die Zahl der Geburten sank um 35 Prozent im Vergleich zu 21. Also Vorkriegszeit. Und das ist die Grafik des Bevölkerungserwachstums, natürlich mit umgedrehten Vorzeichen, für 22 auf 23. Und im Februar 22 begann der Krieg. Japan minus 0,5. Und wir wissen, das ist schon dramatisch. Albanien minus 0,6. Bosnien-Herzegowina minus 0,6. Kosovo minus 1. Griechenland minus 1,6. Tuvalu Flüchtlingkrise wegen, wird überflutet und so. Minus 1,8. Ukraine minus 8,1. Also da kann man einfach mal Faktor 4,5 auf die allgemeine Entwicklung draufschlagen. In den 90ern lebten mehr als 50 Millionen Menschen in der Ukraine. Nach aktuellen Schätzungen Anfang 2024 38 Millionen. Also da hat man einfach doppelt dezimiert mehr als 20 Prozent rausgenommen. Wenn man sich nur die ukrainisch kontrollierten Gebiete anschaut, könnten es sogar rund 30 Millionen Menschen sein. Also je nachdem, wie erfolgreich Putin jetzt Trump überredet, da irgendwie zugeständigt ist es zu machen und so weiter, ist er einfach ein Land von 50 auf 30 Millionen geschrumpft. Von 20 Jahren, das kann man sich aber gar nicht vorstellen. Ganz wichtig, schreibt sie, ein Scheinfrieden oder nur ein Waffenstillstand würde daran erst mal nichts ändern, denn du brauchst einfach Perspektive und Zukunft. Und die ist nur geboten, wenn es eine richtige Nachkriegsordnung gibt. Und sie kommt dann nochmal auf Russland zu sprechen. Die Statistikbehörde Rostat hat jetzt einfach komplett aufgehört, überhaupt Zahlen zu veröffentlichen. Also nicht nur Trump sagt einfach, Arbeitsmarktzahlen kommen jetzt von meinem Typen, den ihr von dem Foto kennt vom 6. Januar. So. Sondern auch in Russland gibt es jetzt zu Geburt, Todesfälle, Eheschließung, Scheidung keine offiziellen Daten mehr. Seit Ende Juni weigert sich die Behörde komplett, die Sterblichkeit für 24 herauszugeben. Also das ist mal eine Idee von Umgang mit Demografie, dass man einfach sagt, okay, wir verschweigen sie, aber sie ist ja dann trotzdem noch da und so. Also das ist völlig Hanebüchen. Sie kommt dann auch auf einen anderen interessanten Text, den konnte ich leider nicht nachgehen, weil Paywall von, was war es eigentlich? Ah, Foreign Policy, in dem nochmal argumentiert wurde, dass es vielleicht sogar Kriegsgründe gab, für Russland die Ukraine zu übernehmen. Finde ich sehr interessant, da Putin ja jetzt immer wieder auffiel, zu sagen Kriegsgründe, Kriegsgründe, Kriegsgründe, die Kriegsgründe müssen beseitigt werden und so weiter und so fort. Und die Kriegsgründe sind hier aber einfach demografischer, Natur. Wir greifen an, weil Russland nicht 500 Millionen Einwohner hat. So, diese Kriegsgründe lassen sich nicht beseitigen. Selbst 150 Millionen Unterferner liefen. In Russland leben aktuell 145 Millionen Menschen, sagt sie. Bis 2100 könnte es auf 126 Millionen schrumpfen. Also, Demografie scheint für mich weiterhin das Maß aller Dinge zu sein, gerade in solchen kriegerischen Außenlandersätzen.
Damit kann man Europa nicht erobern.
Nee, also da schafft man es. Nee, das sind die Polen, die Deutschland gefährlich werden, nicht die Russen.
Oder die Deutschen den Polen. Das wissen wir noch nicht, in welche Richtung sich diese beiden rechten Lager verkämpfen.
Ja, also wenn das nochmal Schlüssel übergibt zum Frieden, dann muss er daran erinnern, dass dieser Schlüssel notwendig war, weil Polen und Deutschland im Krieg waren. Auch Russland, aber es war vor allem auch Deutschland-Polen.
Wir kommen nun zu einem Text, den ich doch ganz erstaunlich fand. Man fragt sich ja immer, wer kämpft so alles in der Ukraine außer Ukrainer? Und für die Tagesschau wurde das jetzt aufgeschrieben von Marie-Christine Böse. Sie schreibt über kolumbianische Söldner im Ukraine-Krieg. Da ist Jacob, ein Kolumbianer, einer von vermutlich hunderten, die in der Ukraine in den Krieg gezogen sind, tausende Kilometer entfernt von der Heimat. Das Gehalt habe ihn gelockt, erzählt er. 3000 US-Dollar monatlich zahle die Ukraine. Als Soldat in Kolumbien verdient man trotz Risiko nur 400 Dollar. Das ist also der Gehaltssprung, den man machen kann. Es war entsetzlich. Wenn die Ukraine sechs Drohnen schickt, antwortet Russland mit 150 Drohnen. Wo Jakob sich in Kolumbien aufhält, will er nicht verraten. Der Ex-Soldat hält sich aus Angst versteckt. Er habe Drohungen bekommen, weil er von der Realität des Krieges erzähle und Mittelsmännern in seinem Land das Geschäft mit den kolumbianischen Söldnern verderbe. Denn diese komischen Mittelsmännern, die es da gibt, sind daran interessiert, möglichst viele Leute der Ukraine zu übergeben, die dann dort kämpfen. Man muss fast nichts mitbringen. Man muss schon mal Streitkraft gewesen sein, dürfe jetzt keine Krankheiten haben und sonst auch keine Vorstrafen. Aber dann ist man frei dort zu kämpfen. Sie spricht auch mit einem anderen Rückkehrer, der will anonym bleiben. Der sagt, am Boden bewege man sich auf vermintem Gebiet, in der Luft kreisen Drohnen. Wenn Soldaten versuchten, Leichname von gefallenen Kameraden zu bergen, würden auch sie angegriffen. Das ist ein Szenario wie in einem Kriegsfilm aus Hollywood. Kolumbiens linksgerichteter Präsident Petro ist wenig begeistert und will versuchen, diesen, wie er es nennt, Menschenhandel zu beenden. Es geht dann noch um einen weiteren, José heißt der. José habe von Toten erzählt, von Drohnen und Artillerie und dass der Krieg ganz anders sei als der Konflikt in Kolumbien. Auch José wollte schnell wieder nach Hause, war bereits auf dem Weg, als er bei einer Zwischenlandung in Venezuela festgenommen wurde. Venezuelas autoritärer Machthaber Nicolas Maduro und Russlands Präsident Vladimir Putin sind Verbündete und Venezuela übergab den Kolumbianer den Russen. Am Schluss steht dann noch mal, die Kolumbianer werden als Kanonenfutter eingesetzt hier. Und ja, das ist auch die Situation, über die wir hier sprechen. Leute, die sagen, ich bekomme 2600 Dollar mehr im Monat und setze dafür mein Leben aufs Spiel, sterbe auf dem Feld oder komme vielleicht noch in irgendeine russische Kriegsgefangenschaft. Ja, das sind die jungen Männer, von denen viel zu wenig hier Rede ist.
Dass die Russen das auch machen, wir sagen es immer wieder dazu, ist jetzt klar. Genau, naja, klar. Aber ja, immerhin Tagesschau. For some patients, wir reden also hier bei kranke Menschen, the inner voice, also ihre innere Stimme, may soon be audible. Könnte hörbar gemacht werden. Es gibt eine Krankheit Amyotrophel Lateralsklerose, die schwächt die Muskeln so in den Atemwegen, dass du nicht mehr reden kannst. Bist dann also grundsätzlich auf Hilfe angewiesen, kannst dich nicht mehr selbstständig körperlich bewegen, kannst dabei noch denken, also nicht mehr kommunizieren. Und jetzt ist hier eine Studie erschienen in der Fachzeitschrift TESEL, über die die New York Times Karl Zimmer ausführlich schreibt. Also wirklich sehr ausführlich dafür, dass es so eine Studieaufhänger war. Denn es gelingt jetzt den Computern immer häufiger, aus sichtbaren oder sichtbar gemachten Gehirnaktivitäten Sprache zu errechnen, wenn man die Muster einmal kennt. Es gibt eine sehr langjährige klinische Studie namens BrainGate2, in der man das versucht. Ich nehme mal an, das ist auch so die Idee von Neuralink und so. Da geht es ja auch viel um Patienten, die den man da schon, also die eigentlich dem Tode geweiht sind, aber die dann da sich nochmal bereit erklären. Es wird also eine Gehirnmaschine, Schnittstelle entwickelt. Elektroden werden also richtig im Gehirn platziert, und zwar im motorischen Cortex. Also da, wo würden die inneren Willensbekundungen sich zu bewegen, in motorische Bewegung als Befehle übersetzt. Also da gibt es einen Gehirnbereich, der sich damit befasst. Es geht also nicht so richtig hier um das inhaltliche Denken, sondern um diesen Übergang zum motorischen Geschehen. Und jetzt hat man 6000 Wörter kartografiert, die mit einer Genauigkeit von 97,5 Prozent vorhergesagt werden können. Und man stellt sich ethische Fragen, wie zum Beispiel, könnte ein Computer versehentlich mehr aufzeichnen, als Patienten tatsächlich sagen wollen? Man will ja also untersuchen, ob die Gefahr besteht, dass Wörter entschlüsselt werden, die dann laut ausgesprochen werden, obwohl sie gar nicht laut ausgesprochen werden wollten. Denn in dem Moment, wo man beim motorischen Cortex ansetzt, hat man ja noch diese Unterscheidung zwischen, ich denke nur vor mich hin oder ich will es gerade aussprechen. Also da ist man noch so einen Schritt weiter. Und man versucht jetzt, diesen Spot zu finden, dass man nicht zu sehr im Inneren, in der Gedankenwelt ist und man versteht die auch noch nicht so richtig, sondern beim Aussprechen. Oder aber, und das ist eine Neurowissenschaftlerin in Stanford, die sich jetzt die Frage stellt, sollten wir nicht lieber auf die innere Sprache abzielen direkt? Denn dann könnten wir noch diese restkörperliche Anstrengung, der dir mit einhergeht, dass jemand zumindest etwas aussprechen will, kann man nochmal rausnehmen. Also dann müsste der Patient sozusagen gar keine motorischen Versuche mehr mobilisieren, sondern könnte nur noch denken. Und dann hätte man es mit der inneren Sprache zu tun. Also wir haben es mit ausgesprochener Sprache, dem Versuch etwas auszusprechen und mit der inneren Sprache. Also mit diesen drei Ebenen zu tun. Und man ist jetzt an dieser dritten Ebene, also da, wo es wirklich reine Gedankenwelt ist. Und da gibt es aktuelle Studien, dass nämlich grundsätzlich erstmal unverstanden bleibt noch, wie jetzt überhaupt der Zusammenhang ist zwischen innerer Sprache und, ich sage jetzt mal äußerer Sprache, aber die man noch nicht hört. Also das Gehirn macht das schon in diesem motorischen Bereich, aber eben noch nicht. Viele Menschen haben keine Ahnung, wovon sie sprechen, wenn sie sagen, dass sie eine innere Stimme haben, sagt hier Evelina Fedorenko vom MIT. Also wir sind wirklich nur die ganz großen MIT Stanford und so weiter. Und man versucht jetzt gerade dadurch, dass man überhaupt mal eine Bildgebung, also Bildgebung hatten wir schon vorher, aber dass man jetzt eine nachträgliche Sinngebung aus dieser Bildgebung hat, versucht man jetzt überhaupt mal zu verstehen, was eigentlich passiert, bevor man einen Gedanken aussprechen will. Also der reine kognitive Gedanke. Die Computer sind jetzt so weit, dass man dieser inneren Sprache mal nachgehen kann. Und man weiß aber noch nicht so genau, was man da jetzt eigentlich sieht. Man hat erstmal grundsätzlich nur Wachbarkeitsstudien, so grundsätzlich. Und im Text fragt jetzt immer nach der mentalen Privatsphäre, wie er sie nennt. Denn gelegentlich konnten die Forscher Wörter erkennen, die die Teilnehmer nicht laut gedacht haben. Also die sie noch nicht aussprechen wollten und die die Computer trotzdem schon aufgefangen haben. Und sie haben jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten. Das eine ist, sie bleiben ganz konsequent bei diesem Bewegungskortex und ignorieren den Rest. Oder sie entwickeln ein System mit Passwörtern. Also du musst ein bestimmtes Wort denken. Das war hier auch, damit es besonders leicht auf dem Computer erkennbar ist, war das so eine richtige Phrase. Klang sehr albern. Also man muss sich jetzt vorstellen, wie Snowden gesagt hat, dass man Passwörter haben soll. Eine richtige Phrase. Nicht nur so ein Wort, sondern seine Idee war damals zu sagen, so Wolfgang ist 20% sexier than me oder sowas. Also dass man so einen richtigen Satz hat, der einfach keinen Sinn ergibt. Und genauso ist das hier auch. Also die müssen dann einmal so ein sehr kompliziertes, aber sehr leicht erkennbares Wort denken. Ab dann wird in Sprache übersetzt, bis sie das Wort wiederdenkt und dann wird es wieder zurück übersetzt. Während ich mich natürlich frage zum einen, wie ist das genau gemeint? Also sind die dann so diszipliniert, dass sie genau dieses Wort, dann denken sie nicht an den Elefanten, bis sie wieder an ihn denken und so. Ist sehr schon mal kompliziert. Zum zweiten heißt das aber auch, diese zweite Möglichkeit mit dem Passwort bedeutet, der Computer registriert trotzdem, was sie sagen. Man muss ja auf das Passwort warten und gibt das nur einfach nicht weiter. Also es wird sozusagen im Arbeitsspeicher gelöscht oder sowas. Da müsste man auch erst mal drauf vertrauen, dass Leute mit anderen Ansinnen die Computer dann auch so programmieren. Also mentale Privatsphäre scheint hier ein Ding zu sein. Und zum anderen zitiert hier ein Dr. Herf. Diese Experimente finde ich am spannendsten, also da wo es um die innere Stimme gibt, weil sie darauf hindeuten, dass Sprache über die reine Kommunikation hinaus eine Rolle in vielen verschiedenen Formen des Denkens spielen könnte. Was bedeutet, nachdem wir vorhin so viel über das Gehirn gesprochen haben, bislang weiß man vom Gehirn, dass es am Ende Sprache kommuniziert, wenn wir was vom Gehirn mitkriegen. Weil ansonsten äußert sich es ja nicht. Also klar, Gesten und so. Aber der kommunikative Teil ist wohl sehr wichtig. Und so wie wir auch bei den Large-Language-Models nicht genau verstehen, was passiert, bevor der Satz formuliert ist, also in den neuronalen Stufen vorher. Genauso wenig weiß man das beim Gehirn. Und man kann jetzt allenfalls so Leute fragen, und die kommen dann auf darauf zu sprechen, dass dann die eine Forscherin sagt, ja, mein Mann meint irgendwie, er denkt nicht in Worten. Und die sich dann fragen, aber wie denkt er denn dann? Ja, irgendwie anders, keine Ahnung und so. Die versuchen das jetzt irgendwie zu verstehen, was überhaupt dieser Denkprozess mal ist, wenn man ihn jenseits von Worten oder ausformulierbaren Sätzen...
Artikulierte Worte.
Genau. Also, wie läuft es eigentlich ab? Da habe ich dann auch so gedacht beim Lesen, wenn man immer diese Austauschschüler so fragt, ab wann hast du in deiner Fremdsprache begonnen zu träumen oder so, dann sagen die immer, keine Ahnung, so nach einem halben Jahr habe ich meinen ersten englischen Traum gehabt oder so. Aber selbst das ist ja schon wieder nur eine Idee davon, dass man wirklich auf Englisch geträumt hat. Und nicht in völlig anders. So und aber eben auch nicht innerhalb des Textes. Die KI, wenn sie miteinander kommunizieren, finden ja so eine eigene Sprache. Und es gab jetzt auch von Google so erste Veröffentlichungen, dass man die Sprache der Computer da nicht mehr versteht. Also dass sie machen ja eh schon keinen Unterschied zwischen Deutsch und Englisch und so. Für Claude dann einfach nur, welche Sprache willst du jetzt, dann gebe ich halt da aus. Also dass da Übersetzungsleistungen stattfinden und der Computer für sich noch mal eine neue Sprache gefunden hat, die nun gar keine Ableitung von uns ist, sondern der Computer lernt ja selbst. Und dass wir es hier vielleicht mit, also die Unterscheidung von Cognizum und Kommunikation vielleicht doch noch mal ein bisschen größer denken müssen, als einfach nur, ah ja, ich prompte was rein, da kommt was raus. Sondern so unklar ist, wo kommt der Prompt her, ist halt auch, wo kommt die Antwort her. Und das ist hier noch ein in dem Text auch wiedergegebenen Streit zwischen, nö, die eine Forschungsgruppe sagt, wir denken in Worten und der andere sagt, nee, macht keinen Sinn, wir finden dann erst Worte, wenn wir es aussprechen, fand ich schon erstaunlich. Also da gibt es keine gemeinsame Haltung gerade, wie es abläuft. Jetzt habe ich auch dieses Passwort hier gefunden, Chitty Chitty Bang Bang.
Okay, na.
Also wenn du Chitty Chitty Bang Bang denkst, dann war es die NSA bis jetzt privat unterwegs.
Ich habe mal ein bisschen Feindbeobachtung gemacht, habe Tichys Einblick mir angesehen. Das ist ja, wie es sich selbst nennt, das Liberalkonservative Meinungsmagazin. Ich würde aber sagen, naja, es ist so das Vorfeld für alles, was mit AfD zusammenhängt. Dort hat Mario Turnis einen Artikel geschrieben, der überschrieben ist mit den Worten Friedrich Merz, höre die Signale, es ist das letzte Gefecht. Aber hier geht es natürlich nicht um den Sozialismus, sondern darum, dass erst mal konstatiert wird, völlig richtig, um 19,2% ist die Zahl der beantragten Regelinsolvenzen von Juli 2024 auf Juli 2025 gestiegen. Noch sei das ja nicht die Wirtschaftskrise des neuen Bundeskanzlers, denn wir wissen ja die Ampel und vor allem Hrbac, also das wird nochmal kurz erwähnt. Aber Friedrich Merz ist auf dem besten Weg, sie zu seiner Krise zu machen, auch weil er wie gehabt seine Versprechen bricht. Ja, dann fragen wir uns, worum geht es hier? Zitiert wird hier fast nur der Verband, die Familien unternehmen. Das ist ja der reaktionäre Arm des Kapitals, könnte man sagen. Ganz schlimm. Lustig auch, wenn man es dann nochmal so nachliest. Dieser Verband hat 6.500 Mitglieder. Aber man sagt, dass man im Verband 180.000 Unternehmen vertreten, repräsentiert. Weißt du warum? Also sie gestehen sich quasi selbst ein, dass sie keine Familienunternehmer mehr sind, nämlich diese 6.500 Menschen sind natürlich einfach reich und sind in ganz viele andere Unternehmen investiert. Sie haben ein Portfolio, wie wir es immer gesagt haben. Die schließen sich morgens das Fabrik-Tor auf und dann kommen die Arbeiter und abends schließen sie wieder ab, sondern die haben weit gestreute Portfolios und darüber dann gerechnet ja repräsentieren die 180.000 Unternehmen. Das zeigt sich aber dann eben schon, dass diese Debatte um die Erbschaftssteuer, dann werden all die Unternehmen geschlossen, wo unsinnig ist, sondern man würde diese einzelne Person besteuern und dann würde sich vielleicht deren Portfolio verkleinern, aber die Unternehmen würden nicht verschwinden. Aber klar, das ist bei Tichis Einblick dann nicht zu finden. Vielmehr wird gesagt, also hier läuft so viel schief. Nämlich dieser starke Anstieg von Insolvenzen, der sei vor allem auf die Stromsteuer zurückzuführen, auf lähmende Bürokratie, auf das jetzt bald kommende Tariftreuegesetz.
Ja, natürlich.
Denn das würde ja noch mehr Bürokratie verursachen.
Die Pflichten sind ja wieder gestrichen.
Außerdem sei ein Problem, dass Friedrich Merz nicht, wie versprochen, die Lohnnebenkosten gesenkt hat.
Ja.
Zwar gibt es ja diese Absenkung der Körperschaftssteuer, aber die kommen natürlich viel zu spät. Die müsste längst da sein. Hier heißt es dann, nach gerade mal 100 Tagen als Kanzler ist das Vertrauen in Friedrich Merz bereits verloren gegangen. Ich meine, diese Websites und diese Content Creator auf der rechten Seite funktionieren ja nur durch einen permanenten Alarmismus, das die Welt untergeht. Und auch wenn jetzt eine CDU- Regierung kommt, muss man weiterhin schreiben, dass es ganz, ganz schlimm ist. Was wir aber hinzuführen müssen, das wäre ja erst mal so diese Aufmerksamkeit zur Ökonomie und Polarisierungsunternehmer, all das. Was wir aber hinzufügen sollten ist, wir haben ja damals sehr ausführlich in einem Live-Salon über Krah und Kubitschek gesprochen, wie dann Krah sagt, ich sehe da jetzt auch Hoffnung, ich saß jetzt schon ein paar Mal so intern mit Familienunternehmern zusammen. Da wird man dann vom Landrat mit eingeladen. Und den muss ich mal zeigen, dass wir auch mit Messer und Gabel essen. Und dann sehen die auch, es geht ja wirtschaftlich nicht voran, dass die uns wählen können. Genau das kann man hier in diesem Text, da steht dann natürlich nirgends, wir wählen jetzt die AfD. Aber das kann man natürlich genau nachvollziehen, dass man jetzt diese Brücke baut. Großes Problem natürlich für die Familienunternehmer. Und ich schieße einen Blick, die Verschuldung. Rund eine Billion Euro nimmt der Staat seinen Bürger jährlich an Steuern und Abgaben ab. Fast eine Billion Euro neuer Schulden will die neue Regierung noch oben draufsatteln. Und die Fantasie der regierenden Parteien beschränkt sich auf die Frage, an welcher Stelle sie Steuern und Abgaben für die Bürger noch weiter erhöhen kann. Dann wird einfach wahllos aufgelöstet, Erbschaftssteuer für Vermögende. Wo steht das? In keinem Koalitionsvertrag, den ich gelesen habe. Höhere Kassenbeiträge für Besserverdienende. Zehn Prozent pauschal auf alle Erbschaften bei Abschaffung sämtlicher Ausnahmen. Habe ich auch nirgends gefunden. Eine höhere Mehrwertsteuer. Gut, das könnte tatsächlich kommen, aber das trifft ja dann wirklich die kleinen Momenten, die wenig zu haben. Höhere CO2-Abgaben, da hat man Angst vor. Höhere Steuern auf Tabak und Alkohol hat man Angst vor. Dass dieses Geld, das da jetzt neu aufgenommen wird, diese Billion, von der da die Rede ist, so etwa zu 70 Prozent, die Rechnung ist natürlich jetzt noch nicht klar, aufzumachen, in die private Wirtschaft fließt. Wie doof sind die eigentlich?
Ich weiß auch nicht.
Also es ist ja nicht auszuhalten, dass sie jetzt einfach meinen, das wird so verjubelt in den Ämtern oder was passiert damit. Also das geht ja dahin. Ja, nein, der Großteil des Geldes, dass man sich hier sicher fließt, sind den Konsum.
Ja genau, davon profitieren die ja.
Nee, das wäre ja Binnenmarkt. Da müsste man ja erstmalig auf den Binnenmarkt ausrechnen. Das kennen die auch gar nicht. Also die deutschen Unternehmer wollen ja gerne so gut wie keine Löhne zahlen und wollen aber teure Produkte produzieren. Fragt man sich, wer soll die abkaufen? Und dann will man das einfach exportieren. Irgendwo wird schon Geld sein. Dann guckt man nach Europa. Ach so, die sollen im Süden von Europa alle sparsam sein. Also die können uns eigentlich auch nicht abkaufen. Mit China haben wir Knies, die anderen sind, weiß ich nicht was. Also wie soll das gehen? Das ist ja wirklich so unüberlegt. Und dass man dann, wo man abhängig ist so sehr von der Weltwirtschaft, nicht versteht, dass das die größeren Prozesse sind, die auch in Friedrich Merz nicht irgendwie an einem Hebel ziehen jetzt gerade ändert. Das ist wirklich so fatal, wenn man so von Volkswirtschaft gar keine Ahnung hat. Und das Einzige, was sie fordern ist, Stromkosten senken, Lohnnebenkosten senken, Sozialkosten senken. Das würde schon mal helfen, aber das ist ja ganz schlimm, nämlich durch die SPD vor allem. Das sozialdemokratische, Anführungszeichen, Arbeitsministerium, geht sogar so weit, im Ausland auf Englisch und Arabisch dafür zu werben, wie gut Deutschland fürs Nichtarbeiten bezahlt.
Also ich frage mich immer auch bei so Bürgergeld-Diskussionen, wenn es dann irgendwie heißt, ja 50 Millionen im Jahr und was auch immer. Wenn wir am ersten eines Monats das Bürgergeld auszahlen, wissen die dann nicht, wo das Geld am 20. dieses Monats ist?
Der Name heißt Lidl Schwarz. Die könnten das auch gleich an die Konzerne überweisen. Es geht nämlich genau 100 Prozent dahin.
Ja, macht man jetzt, indem man sagt, wir geben euch eine Essensmarke, dann wird es direkt geteilt.
Man hat es direkt gemacht, aber es geht ja nur dahin. Also es sagt ja keiner, ich leg's dir auf den Kaimanninseln an.
Diese Familienunternehmer, also in Anführungszeichen, Unternehmerfamilien mit 800 Unternehmen im Portfolio, wie Elphetris das aufgeschrieben hat, das sind ja die, die das Geld außer Landes bringen. Aber nicht die Bürgergeldempfänger oder die Rentner.
Die geben das komplett hier aus.
Die geben das ja im Umkreis von zehn Kilometern aus, einfach zu 80 Prozent. Nee, ist alles auch so.
Also es ist so wahnsinnig, wenn man das sieht. Aber ich glaube, hier können wir schon so einen Text symptomatisch sehen für das, was da passiert, nämlich wirklich so diese Brücke zur AfD.
Ja, Musik.
Ja, ich habe wieder Musik gehört und zwar gibt es ein wunderbares Streichquartett, das heißt Novus-Quartett, die habe ich auch schon mal live erlebt und die haben jetzt gerade ihre neue Doppel-CD rausgebracht. Gibt es natürlich alles auch zu streamen. Und zwar haben sie die drei Brahms-Streichquartette eingespielt. Brahms ist erst sehr spät zum Streichquartett gekommen. Mit 40 hat er sein erstes komponiert. Nein, falsch gesagt, mit 40 wurde sein erstes aufgeführt. Aber zuvor hat er nach eigenen Aussagen schon 20 komponiert und die sind alle in den Papierkorb gewandt. Denn die Last war groß. Beethoven war ein Meister des Streichquartetts und er hat nicht nur diese Symphoniebrocken hinterlassen, auch unter denen Ächtste Brahms und Tarzig Schwer seine eigene Symphonie dann erst mal zu komponieren. Genauso ging es ihm dann auch mit den Streichquartetten. Aber diese drei, die dann entstanden sind, sind wirklich exquisit. Das erste Quartett ist wunderschön in C-Moll. Da haben wir also nochmal die fünfte Symphonie von Beethoven, wenn man so möchte. Also C-Moll, das ist die trage schicksalhafte Tonart. Und die fünfte Symphonie von Beethoven ist die Schicksalssymphonie. Und tatsächlich ist es so, wenn man das jetzt hört und das arbeiten die Musiker vom Novus Quartett auch wunderbar heraus, haben wir es hier mit so einer Symphonie zu tun, aber nur auf vier Instrumente. Also zwei Geigen, eine Pransche, ein Cello. Wahnsinnig satt, voll im Klang. Ein Schönklang ist hier angestrebt, ganz klar von den Vieren. Das ist jetzt nicht so schroff, wie man das bei anderen vielleicht hören mag. Aber ich finde, dass sie sehr klar dadurch so zeigen, wie symphonisch das Quartett gebaut ist und auch wie dicht an Motiven es ist. Also der erste Satz beginnt wirklich mit Anspannung, Entspannung, Aufruhr, so ein plötzliches Aufgewühltsein und dann wieder so ein Zur-Ruhe-Kommen, aber in Form einer tiefen Melancholie. Dann hören wir weiter dann in einem Satz eine Romanze. Das ist alles sehr komprimiert. Und ich habe bei Brahms immer so meine Probleme, weil mir das manchmal unzusammenhängend vorkommt, wenngleich ich mir habe sagen lassen, dass Brahms der ist, der wirklich versucht, dem nochmal eine Form zu geben. Ich finde aber, dass hier in dieser Interpretation des Novus Quartett wirklich das sehr gut so zusammengebracht wird, also dass es hier wirklich darum geht, viele Motive unterzubringen, also dass es was sehr Komprimiertes hat. Auch ist dann noch ein Triozöner, also im Teil Vierteltag so ein Ländler. Aber dass es eben nicht so nacheinander kommt, sondern doch wohl zusammengehört, das wird in dieser Einspielung sehr klar. Das zweite und dritte Quartett auch ungeheuer beeindruckend. Sie spielen es nicht zu forsch, nicht zu extrem. Sie legen Wert darauf, die Struktur beizubehalten oder die Struktur herauszuarbeiten. Und vor allem geben sie sich durchaus diesem Schönenklang hin. Und tatsächlich hat man mitunter den Eindruck, man lauscht hier eigentlich schon einer Symphonie. Und ich bin sehr begeistert davon und mir ist Brahms, und das ist nicht der Komponist, der mir besonders nahe steht, doch deutlich näher gekommen durch diese Einspielung. Wer jetzt noch nie Brahms gehört hat, umso besser, dann kann man sich ja ganz nochmal neu reinbegeben. Ich glaube jedenfalls, dass auch wenn das jetzt so ein bisschen intellektualistisch klingt, was ich jetzt so ausgeführt habe, man kann diese Streichquartette auf sich wirken lassen und wird fasziniert davon sein, wie vielschichtig und vielseitig so eine Unterhaltung von vier Instrumenten miteinander sein kann. Überhaupt, sage ich ja, das Streichquartett ist eigentlich so die schönste Formation überhaupt. Und dass wir jetzt diese drei Brahms-Quartette neu eingespielt haben vom Novus-Quartett, ist ein guter Anlass, sich dem zu stellen.
Man kann das sowieso einfach so hören, denn ohne dass ich jetzt ausführen kann, warum ich das so gut finde, habe ich jetzt noch mal, was heißt noch mal, ich habe es vorher nie gehört, Beethovens fünftes Piano-Konzert, wo ja man denkt, das ist ein Piano-Konzert, ist ja auch, aber dann sitzt er trotzdem im ganzen Sinfonie da und spielt.
Ja.
Und das ist sehr schön. Ja, mehr kann man nicht sagen aus meiner Richtung.
Es lohnt sich, das alles wieder zu entdecken. Und es ist so, man kann ja auch gerade, wenn man diese Dienste abonniert hat, Spotify oder Apple oder was auch immer, bekommt man ja gleich angezeigt Einspielungen von anderen. Man kann ja dann einfach mal den ersten Satz des ersten Quartetts hören, wie das Novus Quartet das spielt. Und dann hört man sich eine Einspielung an von einem anderen Quartett und das mal den Zugang zu vergleichen. Und das sind dieselben Noten. Die machen nicht, die sagen nicht wir lassen fünf weg oder so, sondern die spielen das und es ist radikal anders häufig. Und dann sind es natürlich auch Fragen des Geschmacks. Manche werden vielleicht sagen, ach, das klingt ein bisschen zu glatt, was jetzt das Novus Quartet macht. Ich glaube dir wird es eher gefallen. Du hast dich ja schon mal bei mir beklagt, dass ich manchmal Empfehlungen habe und dann würden die Musiker so laut schnaufen, während sie spielen. Das erlebst du hier nicht. Hier kriegt man gar nicht mehr mit, wie der Ton hergestellt wird. Das werden wir doch immer andere kritisch sehen.
Das ist ja eine richtige Fahrradquartetten.
Man kann sich den durchs Schnaufen gut dirigieren, aber das hat auch seine Tücken.
Sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut. Ich höre ja sowas dann gezielt über diese Apple Music App, die irgendwie Klassik, also es gibt so eine Klassik-App.
Klassiker, die ist sehr gut, ja.
Und wenn man da sucht, sieht man ja auch die unterschiedlichen Einspielungen und die Längenunterschiede.
Auch schon, das ist interessant.
Erster Teil, manchmal 19, manchmal 21 Minuten. Dann sieht man schon, okay, da sind offenbar Unterschiede. Man darf nur einfach nie diese Karajan-Dinger oder so anklicken, weil die sind einfach zu alt. Das ist mit so einem Röhrenmikrofon aufgenommen und so. Das kann man auch mal unter akademischen Ansichtspunkten.
Nee, nee, nee, kommt sehr drauf an.
Man hört es schon, dass es alt ist.
Also die alten Aufnahmen sind ja auch gut. Es gibt auch tolle Fortwängler-Aufnahmen oder so, die sind noch viel älter. Nur bei Karajan gibt es ja ein anderes Problem. Der hat sich ja dann auf die CD konzentriert und der hat ja zum Teil einen sehr transparenten Schönklang reinbringen wollen, der eigentlich den Werken nicht mehr gerecht wurde, sondern er hatte da so eine eigene Vision im Ohr, sage ich mal, die er umsetzen wollte. Deswegen sind da vielleicht manche Dinge mit Vorsicht zu genießen, die er da gemacht hat. Aber sonst kann man auch das alt hören, also gerade bei, es gibt wunderbare Quartette-Einspielungen aus den 60er, 70er Jahren und die hatten auch zum Teil eine echt gute Technik, das einzuspielen.
Wenn sie eine gute Technik hatten, dann ja. Aber es gibt auch viele Aufnahmen, gerade bei Apple, die von dem Kompass verheizen.
Oben ist auch ein Problem, bei manchen hat man den Eindruck, da ist wirklich nur so, wurden zwei Mikrofone irgendwo hingestellt. Aber das muss man dann wirklich testen, welche Aufnahmen. Oder sehr viel wird ja digital bemastert. Ich hatte ja hier mal diese Colors-Aufnahmen vorgestellt, bemastert. Das ist ja erstaunlich, was man da dann rausholen kann.
Das wird demnächst alles generiert.
Nein, wird es nicht. Jetzt fangen wir nicht wieder damit an. Wir sehen uns erstmal live analog auf der Bühne. Wer kommen möchte, ein paar Karten gibt es noch. Am 23. ist dann der Live-Sanon. Und für all die, die nicht da sein können, natürlich gibt es dann den Live-Sanon auch zum Hören. Wir würden uns freuen, wenn ihr den Podcast und auch den Salon speziell weiterempfehlt. Und wir würden uns auch freuen, wenn ihr vielleicht den Salon hin und wieder verschenkt an Leute, die wichtig sind oder wo ihr sagt, die sollten sich das unbedingt mal anhören. Das geht über Steady. Da ist die Möglichkeit, den Salon für ein Jahr zu verschenken.
Kostet so viel gehen, la boo boo im Jahr.
Stimmt. Ja.
Okay, Leute, ciao.
Bis dann.